COMMITTEE HEARING BEFORE WE
BEGIN- THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS- THEY WILL KICK OFF IN
EARNEST THE BEGINNING OF MARCH-
I DON'T QUITE KNOW THIS- A
QUORUM BUT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND BE- I DO THE FACT THAT THE
SIX. ZERO I'D LIKE. ONE TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE.
IN RECENT YEARS A STATUS TAKEN
ACCESS TO ADDRESS THE ON HOUSE
CRISIS THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
HOUSING RELATED BILLS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF A DEDICATED SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING VIA SENATE BILL. TWO
THIS COMMITTEE ALSO INVESTED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES IN
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS INCLUDING MORE
THAN ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DIRECT EMERGENCY AID TO LOCAL
ENTITIES OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. BUT WE ARE ALL CLEAR
MORE MUST BE DONE. THE HOMELESS
CRISIS IS NOT GONE AWAY AND THE
STATE NEEDS TO FIND A WAY TO
MOVE PAST THE EMERGENCY ACT AS
OF THE LAST TWO YEARS AND MAKE
REAL PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS GRIPPING ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. ADMINISTRATIVE
PROPOSED A NUMBER OF AMBITIOUS
PROGRAMS TO DEAL WITH THIS
PRESSING ISSUE IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET. THIS HEARING WILL GIVE
US A CHANCE TO DISCUSS THESE
PROPOSALS AT A TEN THOUSAND
LEVEL BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DELVE. MORE DEEPLY INTO
SPECIFICS. BUT TODAY WILL HEAR
THE OVERALL STRATEGY THE SENATE
ON THE CHASE STRAP. AND HOW
CALLS COMPLEMENT PROGRAMS A
PROPOSAL'S ALREADY A-
LEGISLATURE. IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
TO GET INPUT FROM BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL RULES AS WE BEGIN IN
OUR DELIVERY. WELL START
HEARING ISN'T TATIAN FOR THE
ELDEST THE CON WE'RE HAVING
CONVERSE F. WHICH GIVE ME THE
BUSINESS SIR AND AGING WILL
PROVIDE AND ON THE- OF RECENT
INVESTMENTS. NET V.
UNDERSECRETARY MISS BASS OFF
FROM HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WILL PRESENT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AT A
HIGH LEVEL BEFORE OFFICIALS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH SERVICES AT
STATE HOSPITALS PROVIDE. TELL
LASTLY WE'LL DISCUSS THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE ON ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF OUR OWN HOUSE FAMILY
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. AND THE
ROLE OF THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE'LL HEAR FROM
OFFICIALS FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE AS WELL AS SERVICE
PROVIDERS WHO WERE DOING THE
HARD WORK ON OUR COLLECTIVE
BEHALF EVERYDAY. AFTER
COLLEAGUES WE CONCLUDE ALL
PANELS MUCH LIKE OUR HEARING
LAST WEEK THAT'S WILL OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM. BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF COURSE AS
ALWAYS WE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL- SENATE- COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHO WILL PROBABLY BE
IN AND OUT WILL BE JOINING US
TODAY OR NOT YEAH MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET BETTY BUT BASED ON
THE HAND MAKES THE NAME SO OF
COURSE WE INVITED. TO JOINING
INTO HERE TODAY'S PRESENTATION
FROM TO NIELSEN IN THE OPENING
REMARKS SIR THANK YOU MATT-
VERY. AND THE- THEN LOOKED AT
BUT NOW IN GREATER DEPTH. THE
GOVERNOR HAS OFFERS A CHAIR
NOTED SOME. NEW PROPOSALS THAT
THE- WOULD GO A LOT FURTHER- IN
TERMS OF THE LONG TERM
RESOLUTION. OR ASK. FOR THE
DISH. FROM THE ARE NOT A- BIT
OF PROBLEM FOR SOCIETY AND A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS. OF IS GOT
TO BE NOT JUST PROVIDING
SHELTER BUT ALSO EMPOWERMENT
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS TO ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT HAVE CAUSED HIM TO
BE IN THIS FIGHT. AT THIS TIME
AND GETTING. DURING AND THEN OF
COURSE THE DEEPER WORKED IT
WILL BE DOING IN THIS
COMMITTEES AND THEN BEFORE THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE LATER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE SEEING THE
CORE ISSUES OF POVERTY YEAR GOT
TO BE AT THE FRONT OF MIND FOR
ALL OF US. WILL GO HERE BEGIN
TODAY ON THE INVITE THE FIRST
PANEL UP. AGAIN UNDERSECRETARY-
BASS- I'VE SKIPPED RIGHT INTO
THE MEAT OF THE HEARING LET'S
START WITH THE FIRST PANEL.
WILL PROVIDE US CONTACT AN
UPDATE ON RECENT INVESTMENTS
WILL HEAR FROM LORD OF MORALIS.
FROM THE OILS OFFICE ALLEY
CERTAIN DEBBIE SIX REFER
HOMELESSNESS BUSINESS CONSUMER
ASSIST AND HOUSING AGENCY.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS UNDER THIS
MORALIS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED I ASKED TO PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT FOR THE COMMITTEE
AS YOU. CONSIDER THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO RESPOND
HOMELESSNESS. I'LL BE MAKING
COMMENTS FROM THIS HAND OUT AND
LEAVE YOU HAVE IN YOUR BRIEFING
MATERIALS. SO MY NOTING THAT
WHILE HOMELESSNESS IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM WITH MANY CAUSES THE
HIGH COST OF HOUSING IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR IN THE
STATE. CALIFORNIANS SPENT- YOUR
SHARE OF THEIR INCOME ON RENT
AND HOUSEHOLD IN THE REST OF
THE NATION AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE FIGURE ON THE FIRST PAGE
OF. OUR HOUSING. COSTS CD WAIT.
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSE. HAVE PUT
ADDITIONAL STRESS ON
INDIVIDUALS- FIFTY POTENTIALLY
FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS AND THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR THE
ONE POINT FIVE. MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS THAT PAY AT LEAST
HALF OF THEIR- INCOME ON RENT
SO FOR THE POPULATION. AN
UNEXPECTED- SIXPENCE OR JOB
LOSS COULD RESULT IN
HOMELESSNESS. ON THE SECOND
PAGE OF YOUR HAND OUT YOU SEE
SOME OF THE CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION
DO YOU SEE THAT AN ESTIMATED
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ARE
HOMELESS THIS IS BASED ON THE
TWENTY NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNTS. THIS IS ABOUT 27% OF
THIS TOTAL HOMELESS POPULATION
ACROSS THE NATION. YOU SEE THAT
THE GREATEST CONCENTRATION IS
IN LOS ANGELES WHERE THERE'S
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE HOMELESS. AND ABOUT
27% OF THE TOTAL HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE STATE IS
CHRONICALLY LESS. ON PAGE THREE
WE HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AMONG THE- ALONG THE
STATE. YOU SEE THAT THE SEVEN.
LEGIONS OF IDENTIFIED ON THE
MAP HOLD AROUND TWO THIRDS OF
THE TOTAL HOMELESS POPULATION
IN THE STATE WELL THE REMAINING
ONE THIRD ABOUT FORTY NINE
THOUSAND OURS. AROUND TO THE
REST OF THE AREAS. CALIFORNIA
WE DO KNOW THAT THESE NUMBERS
ARE LIKELY UNDER COUNTY GIVEN
CHALLENGES WITH A DOING THE
POINT IN TIME COUNT ACCURATELY
THERE ARE CHALLENGES WITH THE
TRAP TORY NATURE OF THE
POPULATION AS WELL AS
CHALLENGES AND CAP ALL
DIMENSIONS OF HOMELESSNESS TO
FOR EGGS BUT JUST OUR COUCH
SERAPHINE OUR FAMILIES THAT
LIVE IN THAT HOUSE JUST THE
CATCHER IN THE POINT IN TIME
ACCOUNTS. AND LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS SO WE SEE
THAT THE STATE RELATED
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM'S REALLY
FALL INTO THREE MAIN. TYPES OF
RESPONSE THE FIRST- TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT HELP BUILD NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO THIS IS-
THINGS LIKE TAX CREDITS THEN WE
SEE THE STATE ALSO OPERATING
PROGRAMS THAT HELP INDIVIDUALS
AFFORD HOUSING IS ARE THINGS
LIKE VOUCHER PROGRAMS ANOTHER
RENTAL SUBSIDIES. WE ALSO SEE
THAT THE STATE OPERATES HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS
THAT MAY NOT DIRECTLY PROVIDE
HOUSING SERVICES BUT BY HELP.
OF SAUSAGE PROVIDE DRESS. BUT
PROGRAM ARE OPERATE IN THIS
USING SERVICE AS WELL AS
FEDERAL. AND ARE ADMINISTERED
AT VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE SO WE SEE. THE
HOUSING AND URBAN I'M SORRY
EACH CD HAVE ROLE WE SEE A
HOMELESSNESS SO HAVE A ROLE
HERE AND WE ALSO SEE ROLES FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS CDC ARE IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS WELL. AND
ALL THAT FOR THESE PROGRAMS SIX
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING TO THE
SHIFT FROM YEAR TO YEAR IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT MORE. FUNDING BASED
ON TIME AUGMENTATIONS. AND SO
ON THE FIFTH PAGE OF YOUR HAND
OUT WE TALK ABOUT THE LOCAL
RULE AND SO WE DO KNOW THAT
MOST OF THE HOMELESS SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL USING STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS AS WELL. THIS IS BASED ON
LOCALS HAVING THE KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THE CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION
COMMITTEE AND OUR STATE IN THEM
TO MAKE THE DECISION. WHAT
SERVICES BEST SUIT THAT. IN
FEDERAL FUNDS IN SOME CASES
IDENTIFYING THEIR OWN YOU
REVENUE SOURCES AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING POLICIES TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS OF FOR
EXAMPLE MAKING THE INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING POLICIES OR RENT
STABILIZATION POLICIES IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES TO HELP ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. ON PAGE SIX WE
HAVE A FIGURE THAT OUTLINED
SOME OF THE MAJOR RECENT STATE
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
SO WE HAVE THE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME. THE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZED BY THE VOTERS THAT
MADE A TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE. FOR PERMITS A PART
OF HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE MENTALLY ILL. AND THEN WE
SEE A TWO PROPOSALS THAT IN
NEXT PANELIST WILL SPEAK ON IN
PROVIDING AN UPDATE WHERE. WERE
BILLION DOLLARS MADE LEVEL TWO
CITIES COUNTIES CANYONS OF CARE
TO PROVIDE A NUMBER. IS PRIME.
I IF. LESS IT'S ON THE FINAL
PAGE OF THE I WANTED HER TO
TRANSITION TO A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE FREE MARKET HAS A TO
THINK THROUGH NEXT AT. THE
LEDGE HAS DEMONSTRATED IN IN
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH SORT OF-
YOU KNOW THE APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN RISE IN RECENT YEARS.
CHRIS AGAIN EVEN SAID. INVEST
COULD BE MADE WITHOUT SHOWING
MUST BUDGET PROGRESS OF THERE'S
NOT A STRATEGIC APPROACH IN HOW
THOSE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED. AND
SO THIS IS A FINAL PAGE LAYS
OUT. I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSENT AS YOU START
FORMING YOUR PLAN FOR THE
SUBSEQUENT EARS ON ABOUT HOW
YOU IDENTIFY GOALS IN
UNDERSTANDING THE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN A BROAD APPROACH AND
MORE FOCUSED APPROACH WHERE A
BROAD APPROACH- COULD PROVIDE
WORK MORE GREATER MORE RELIEF
SOARED ACROSS THE BOARD BUT
WHAT CONNECTICUT. OF HE SPOKE
PACIFIC. A WAS A THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT YOU THINK THROUGH
WHAT YOU'RE YOU KNOW FOR ORDER
PRIOR ARE IN THE NEAR TERM.
SOLUTIONS ALIGNED WITH THOSE
GOALS OF FOR APPLE IF ONE OF
YOUR FIRST PRIORITIES MIGHT BE
TO. FOCUS ON PREVENTION.
EMERGENCY SHELTERS OUT ONE THAT
WITH A LINE A SISTERLY WITHOUT
YOU CALLED. IMPORTANT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE STATE. AND LOCAL
RELATIONSHIP WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD. ISN'T INTERESTED
MAINTAINING THE CURRENT ROLE
WHERE THE STATE PROVIDES INTO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR HOW THEY
RESPOND OR- LIKE TO TAKE A MORE
ACTIVE. ROLE AND HELP. THOSE
POLICY DECISIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THE GIRL AND STRUCTURE AT
THE STATE LEVEL SHOULD. BE
RESPONSIVE TO THOUGH THE
DECISION TO ULTIMATELY MAKE FOR
THE QUESTIONS ABOVE AND THE
FUNDING STRATEGY NEEDS TO LINE
AS WELL BUT WHETHER ONE TIME OR
ONGOING SOURCES ARE BEST SUITED
FOR THE- THIRTIES THE HOPE TO
ADDRESS. AND ULTIMATELY ANY
PROPOSAL NEEDS TO HAVE GUESTS
OVERSIGHT THAT BOTH TRACKS
PROGRESS. WE HAVE TAKEN
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ACTUALLY GONNA HOLD
QUESTIONS- COLLEAGUES TO END OF
ALL THREE PANELS PLEASE THANK.
I'M THE ALISON FROM THE HOMES
CANADIAN FINANCING COUNSELORS
IN A REALLY GREAT JOB OF SORT
OF PROVIDING A LOT OF THE
CONTEXT OF WHERE WE'RE AT IT'S
GOING TO HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN THE DETAILS OF. SOME OF
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE AND
ONE THING I JUST DO WANT TO
MENTION BECAUSE IT WAS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR
MENTIONED IN HIS STATUS AS WELL
OVER AS WERE THINKING ABOUT
TRENDS AND STATISTICS ARE ON
HOMELESSNESS POPULATIONS. WE
HAVE BEEN REALLY THINKING
CRITIC LEHRER THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN- ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CAL SO ONE
OF. THE POINTS JUST LIKE I DO A
FACT THAT ROUGHLY 30% OF TIME.
POPULAR IS BLACK. PERSON OF
OURS. BLACKS THANK ABOUT WITHIN
OUR COUNCIL RIGHT NOW FROM AS
YOU CENTER MR A WEEK NEED TO DO
MORE AND DO BETTER SON THE
CONTEXT OF THAT I'M TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THE
COUNCIL THAT THAT IMAGE CREATED
IS UP TO ALONG WITH OUR EIGHT
WERE- IMPLEMENTING THE DOLLARS
FROM LAST YEAR AND A HALF HOURS
FROM THIS- AND I'LL GO BACK-
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING OF I'M-
JUST. BRIEFLY EXPLAIN. CONNECT
ANYTHING AND SO IS MADE UP OF
EIGHTEEN COUNCIL MEMBERS AM A
HANDFUL ABOUT ELEVEN FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT'S- A COUPLE
FORMALLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
IN CALIFORNIA TO LOCAL CONSUMER
CARE PRESENTED AND TO STATE
ADVOCATES- WE HAVE A HANDFUL OF
PRIORITIES AND I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT IT JUST ALL OUT HERE
VERY QUICKLY- BEING- THAT THE
STATE WHAT HOMELESS THE
WAREHOUSE AT THE GOVERNMENT
STATUS ARE WORKING VERY ACTIVE.
AND ARE IN THE MIDST OF
THINKING THROUGH OUR TIMELINE
FOR THAT RIGHT NOW- AND ARE
CONTINUING OUR OVERSIGHT OF THE
HOUSING FIRST. WE WERE WE WERE
CREATED UNDER. I ALSO HAVE A
STRONG WORLD. CAN BETWEEN STATE
DEPARTMENTS. AS OURS MENTION
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW DIFFERENT
STATE DEPARTMENTS WITHIN- OUR
GOVERNMENT THAT ARE PROVIDING
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING RIGHT NOW
AND WE ARE IN EFFORTS. OF
TRYING TO COORDINATE AND
STREAMLINED ON. THAT FRONT TEST.
IS SO. A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. AT
THE GRANT THOSE OF YOU. DON'T
LIKE. THIS WAS A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR THAT WAS LOCATED
IN LAST YEAR'S AT. TINA BUDGET.
THREE THREE ZERO. AND. ELEVEN
ALL FIFTY FOUR OR SECTION THERE
IS FUNDING ARE REQUIRE TO ALEC
A MINIMUM OF FIVE TOWARD
HOMELESS. AN OFFENSE MY BE
SPENT BY JUNE FOR TWENTY ONE.
WE WERE PART OF CENTURY. OF ALL
OF THE AT RISK FUNDING IS THAT
THEY HAD TO SEND US ANNUAL RE
THIS JANUARY WE ARE IN THE OF A
EARLY. OF THAT RIGHT NOW BUT
JUST SOME EARLY EARLY FINDING
AS OF WHAT WE SEEING FOR FROM
OF THE FUN. A LARGE MAN OF THAT
SPENDING HAS BEEN SPENT ON
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS. SHALL NOT
CENTER. THE THREE RIGHT OUTRAGE
AND HOW NAVIGATE ALSO APPEAR TO
BE A PRETTY. PIECE OF THIS BY
RENTAL AS A- THESE. AS OF THE
SO WE'LL SEE HOW IT CONTINUES
FROM THERE BUT OVERALL WE ARE
SEE NEED REALLY THINK COULD
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS CRISIS
IMAGE OF COMMUNITIES I WOULD
SAY ARE THE ABOUT AND OF THREE
TO. THEY BY THE CHOSEN USES
FUNDING INNOVATE OR CREATE
CITRIX IT CREATE THREE ARE IN A
CENTER THAT HAD NOT BY
AVAILABLE IN THEIR ARE TWO
THINGS. SOME THAT HAD SEEN
THAT'S WHY A PILOT OR IN SORT
OF A FUNDING THAT. HAD WAIT.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE. WE ALSO
JUST SET TO SORT OF TEASE OUT
AS A REPORT THAT WILL BE COMING
YOUR WAY WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH
SEE IF YOU TO DO SORT OF AN
EARLY ASSESSMENT. FOR MORE
ABOUT THE SENATE THIS POINT I'M
AND THAT PART WERE A COMMAND.
THAT'S AS FAR AS- I'M OF THE A
SIGNIFICANT MILLION AT IN THE
FY NINETY TWENTY BY TO THAT WAS
TO A CO SEES THIRTEEN LARGE
CITIES CAN USE AND ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES SO THAT'S HOW
FOURTEEN DRESSED OF. RECEIVING
OF THEIR REQUIRED TO MIDDLE OF
EACH FOR AND THAT SPENDING ON
YOU SOME. AND OFFER MUST BE
SPENT BY JUNE TWO FIVE JUST
PAST THE DE. FOR A LOCATIONS.
FIFTEEN SO MY TEAMMATE IS THE
THROES OF THOSE RIGHT NOW BUT
WE JUST LIKE TO CALL OUT IT IT
IS KEEP IN A FEW A- THAT WE
THINK ARM AND I THINGS WERE
CONSIDERING IS ARE YOU APPLE.
THEIR RELATIVE USES FOR FUNDING
STREAM BUT LESS FOX THAN WAS IT
REQUIRE STRONGER INSPIRATION
REGION COLLABORATION THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO SEE AND IT IS
REQUIRING GOALS ATTACHED TO THE
FUNDING SO WE ARE REALLY.
THROUGH COMMUNITIES ARE ON ON.
WE YOU MAY I HAVE SEEN THE
ACCESS. LAND THAT HONOR HAD IN
HIS EXACTLY ORDER RELEASED TO
THE- IT IS ON OUR WEBSITE.
CURRENTLY TO ENTER EIGHTY SIX
STATE ON PROP ARE ON THAT BUT
WE- TO. SORT OF ADDITIONAL ONES
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER HAPPEN COMES AND
ARE THOSE ARE AND TO BE USED
FOR COMMUNITY AROUND EMERGENCY.
THEY'RE NOT LONG TERM A
PROPERTIES I CAN PART OF. BUT
ARE OUR CONTENT I. FOR MORE. AS
OF LAST WEEK AND MANY OF THEM
ARE ACTUALLY BEING TRANSFERRED
TO COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW. THOSE
ARE TO BE IS ALSO FOR EMERGENCY.
BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE COMMUNITY PROVIDED
WRAPAROUND SERVICE TO ENSURE
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
HOUSED IN THE TRAILERS. HAVE AN
X. ANOTHER GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
TO. THAT IS A TIE TO OUR
FUNDING IS HUNDRED DAY TOWN THE
FIRST. OF THE WAS A NON ON
MONDAY WE ARE. TO SEE THE A
BEING SORT OF RE UP HERE IN THE
NEXT. OR SO. WITH OUR TECHNICAL
OF THIS PROVIDE WHO CREATED THE
CON AND MODEL OF A HUNDRED A
CHALLENGE. RESULTS SO WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OUT THE THERE WILL BE.
PARTS THROUGHOUT OUR- STOP
THEIR. BEGIN PULL QUOTE. TO THE
FINAL ALSO ASK YOU BY TO PLEASE
AND THEN WHAT WE'LL DO TRY TO.
EVERYONE BACK UP TO THE TAPE TO
BECAUSE IN CA. THANK VERY
MUCH. FOR YOU. NOW WILL MOVE
THE STATE PANEL. ON AN INVITE
TO A BAD. IS JOHN DIRECTOR OF
THE OF SERVICES J. C. COOPER
STATE DIRECTOR AND SHE DEPUTY
OF HOW CARE PER FROM THE OF
HEALTH SERVICE. STEPHANIE
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITAL. THANK YOU VERY
WELCOME. UNDERSECRETARY GOOD TO
SEE YOU IT'S EASY TO GOOD
MORNING CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I I'M HONORED TO PER
IN TODAY'S HEARING AND I THE
COMMITTEE BUCKS AND ME TO PART
ON THIS. BEHALF AS YOU KNOW THE
RECENT ELEMENT ON THE CORONA
VIRUS HE IS TO. HOPE IS A
CRISIS. FOR ANYA. I'D WE ALL
DRESS AS SUDDEN POINTED OUT ON
YOUR LAST PANEL WE RESPONDING
THE IN THE HAVE MADE MAJOR AND
IN POLICY AND YEARS BUILDING
THESE. THE GOVERNOR'S TO SOME
RECENT EMERGENCY ACTION INCLUDE
THOSE IN THE RE GET OF AS JUST.
YOU KNOW THAT GAPS AND GOING
FOR ME. WITH THE RELEASE OF
BROTHER BUDGET THE GOV AND THE
MINISTRY ARE SEE TO PART WITH
THE LEAD. TO TAKE FOR ACTION.
THE BUDGET AND A FEW KEY PER
AND THE HEALTH AND HE SERVICES
AREA THAT SPEAK TO WORK. TO
WORK TO THIS COMP CRY FUHRMAN
PERSPECTIVE. NOT THE PROPOSALS
PERIOD HELLO. FIRST THE CALL
ACCESS BUT THE FINE THE
GOVERNOR FOR. SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ONE GENERAL FUND STOP
THIS THIS. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL. THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE
FOR ARTS TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
FINE. SERVICES INCLUDING SUB.
AND ANY WERE RIGHT TO. RELATED
FIND ASSISTANCE AND DEPOSITS.
TO STABLE. ADULT REYES FOR. AND
REYES CARE. FOR THE ELDERLY ARE
KNOWN AS- FACILITIES. AND TO
FIND IN WHOLE OR PART THE- OF
NEW OR- THE- EXIST AFFORDABLE.
THERE'S WAS THIS SIX NINETY
MILLION TOTAL FIVE TO BE AND-
DRAMATIC CALIBER PROPOSAL OVER
TO A CAL A CAL AMY BROAD
INTENDED TO PROVIDE MORE CALM
CARE TO WITH COMP NEED AND INTO
I MET CAL WORKS HOME YES AND
MEDICARE PILOT PROGRAM AT THE
MINISTRY HOSP. THANK POINT SIX
NOT NORTH AND IS INITIATIVE
ESTABLISH A SIX YEAR PINE PRO
INTO THREE TO FOR INCENTIVES TO
TREAT AND SIR INTO DEAN INST
COMPETENT TO TRIAL IN THE
COMMUNITY. THESE EFFORTS COM TO
PASS. IN IN. OUR DESIRE DETAILS
THE STATE OBISPO. I WOULD LIKE
TO VOTE MY ROOM ON A TO HOW
IMPROVE THE TO THE FIRST TWO
PROPOSALS MENTION. REFLECT IN
ON PRESS AND APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING. AND USING MEDI CAL
AS A TOOL TO BUILD EQUITY
ACROSS ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. WE ARE PROCEEDS
SOME DIFFERENT SOMETHING BROWN
SOMETHING IN MY- HERE'S THE
CASE. MISTER JONES IS A FOR
FIVE YEAR OLD HOME INTO WHO
SLEEP UNDER A BRIDGE IN LOS
ANGELES. GET THE LONG HISTORY
EMERGING ROOM USAGE AND
OCCASIONAL SHORT ADMISSIONS FOR
HIS POORLY CONTROLLED DIABETES.
HE IS A CLEAR ENDS ID DISORDER
BUT HAVEN'T HAD MEDICATIONS
WITH ANY CONSISTENCY BECAUSE HE
STRUGGLES TO MAINTAIN STRUCTURE
AND POSITIVE HABITS. HIS TWENTY
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER VISITS HIM ON
THE STREETS BUT SHE'S JUST
GETTING HER ON HER FEET AND
DOESN'T HAVE THE TIME TO HELP
AS MUCH AS YOU'D LIKE. MR NEEDS
IT IS. SUPPORT SIR. REGULAR AND
RELIABLE PRIMARY AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE AND A HOME. HOW
DOES MR JONES GET THESE AND
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO A
YEAR FROM NOW. FIRST SINCE
MISTER JONES IS IN A MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN WITH HEALTH
NET HE HAS ACCESS BY VIRTUE OF
HIS HOMELESSNESS AND IT'S
CHRONIC CONDITIONS TO ENHANCE
CARE MANAGEMENT AS PART CAL
AIMED. HERE HE SHOULD HAVE A
CASE MANAGER WHO IS SUPPORTING
HIM TO NAVIGATE HIS HEALTH CARE
NEEDS AND ENSURE HE CAN STAY
COMPLIANT WITH MEDICATION
REGIMEN. TWO SINCE MISTER JONES
IS MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE AGAIN
WITH HEALTH NET HE'S ELIGIBLE
FOR IN LIEU OF SERVICES BUNDLE
FOCUSED ON TENDENCY SUPPORT
SERVICES TO HELP HIM FIND
HOUSING. APPLY FOR AND SECURE A
LEASE FOR HOUSING AND THE
MANAGES MOVE AS HE MOVED INTO
THE HOUSING. THESE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED BY A NONPROFIT
COMEDIAN HOUSING ORGANIZATION
THAT IS CONTRACTED WITH HEALTH
NET TO PROVIDE THESE IN LIEU OF
SERVICES TO MISTER JONES. AND
FINALLY BE WE KNOW THAT ANY A
PLACE TO LIVE IS ONE. AND
AFFORD IT IS A WHOLE OTHER
THING MISTER JONES BENEFIT THIS
DAY SUPPORTED FIND IT. HOUSING
CALIFORNIA OUTFIT TO HOUSING
FIND. THIS FUN HELP PAVE POOR
OF HIS RENT AFTER TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT SOME HIS ABILITY TO
FIGHTS INCOME TOWARDS. BECAUSE
OF THIS BUT- LOCAL ENTITIES
COME INTO THE- OF HELL FINE
HOUSING. WOULD LAND. WE WILL.
WORK WITH. ULTIMATELY HELPS
MISTER JONES SIX HOUSING IS
ALSO THE HEALTH NET IN LIEU OF
SERVICE PROVIDER THAT IS FINE
TO BE AT THE CAL AIMED PROPOSAL.
TOGETHER THE MEDI CAL BENEFITS
OF ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT AND
HOMELESS IN LIEU OF SERVICES
UNDER CAL AIMED ALONG WITH THE
pRENTAL SUBSIDY SUPPORT FROM THE
FUND HOT MISTER JONES NOT ONLY
GET HOUSING. BUT MOVE MOVE IN
AND SUCCEED IN HIS NEW HOUSING.
IF EVER MISTER JONES WAS GOING
TO HAVE A SHOT AT GETTING AND
STAYING OFF THE STREETS EIGHT
OUT OF THE EMERGENCY ROOMS THE
TRI FACTOR OF THESE EFFORTS
MAKE IT MUCH MORE LIKELY. THE
WHOLE PERSON FOCUS NATURE THE
SERVICES BLANK THE FUNDING AT A
LEVEL FOR MISTER JONES SAID
THAT EVEN THOUGH VARIETY OF
FINDINGS COME TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT MISTER JONES. COUNTY
MEETING HOUSING HE ONLY KNOWS
THAT HIS PRIMARY. ALSO THE DOES
THE CARE PROVIDER. THAT HE
CONTRAST HOW'S THIS PROVIDER
THAT IS EAGER TO WORK WITH HIM
AND SIX EIGHT. RIGHT. THE THAT
PULLS. BECAUSE THE HOUSING
SEPARATE CITY IS BUILT WITH
STATE GENERAL FUND AND OTHER
COUNTY AND HEALTH PLAN AND
POTENTIALLY PRIVATE AND
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS THE COST
OF THE HOUSING IS NOT ONLY ONE
ENTITIES BURDEN THIS MODEL
BUILDS ON THE NOTION THAT
MISTER JONES IS A MEMBER OF A
HEALTH PLAN AS IS A RESIDENT OF
THIS AND COUNTY. HOW FANS CAN
AND SHOULD INVEST IN THE FUND
BECAUSE THEY WELL UNDERSTAND
THAT CASE MANAGEMENT AND SORT
SUPPORT SERVICES WITHOUT A
REALLY HOUSE REAL HOUSING
OPTION IS MOSTLY INEFFECTIVE.
THE FACT THAT THE FUND HAS BEEN
BUILT ON AS AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT VEHICLE ALSO MEANS
THAT ONGOING RENTAL SUBSIDY
FUNDS TO SUPPORT MISTER JONES
TO STAY HOUSE. ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO FLOW THEM PRIOR
EFFORTS THAT PROVIDED ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR JURISDICTIONS TO
SOLVE WHAT IS KNOWN. WHAT IS
OUR LONG STANDING AND ONGOING
PROBLEM OF MR HOMELESSNESS FOR
MISTER JONES. THE BEST NEWS IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S THROUGH THE
REFORMS DESCRIBED ABOVE IS BOYS
NOT JUST TO DO THIS FOR MISTER
JONES. FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO EXPERIENCES
HOMELESSNESS AND DEPEND ON MEDI
CAL FOR HEALTH COVERAGE. THIS
EXAMPLE HIGHLIGHTS THE CLEAR
OPPORTUNITY THESE PROVIDE
PROPOSALS ARE COMPLEMENTARY TO
EACH OTHER AND REALLY FORM A
NEW WAY OF THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS THAT I KNOW
CONTINUE TO BE RAISED WHITE
AGES AT HHS AND Y. DSS. AND WHY
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS. WHITE
HHS. AS YOU KNOW A TEACHERS
OVERSEES AND COORDINATES THE
SAFE STATE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
WE ARE DESIGNING OR PROGRAMS TO
SEE THE WHOLE PERSON AND WE SEE
HOUSING AS A VITAL COMPONENT TO
SEEN. THE WHOLE PERSON. HOUSING
TO THE DRIVER OF HEALTH AS
EXEMPLIFIED IN THE CASE EXAMPLE
I JUST DISCUSSED. WITHIN HHS.
DOES IS ARC Q. LEADER ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESS PROGRAMS
AND DIRECTOR JOHNSON WILL SPEAK
TO WHY AT SOCIAL SERVICES. WHY
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS
HOMELESSNESS KNOWS NO
BOUNDARIES CITY OR COUNTY LINES
WHEN ENTITIES IN A REGION SUCH
AS CITIES ADJACENT TO ONE
ANOTHER. WORK ON SILENT SILO
PROJECTS AND LACK COORDINATION
ON A PROJECT WE GET NO WHERE WE
HAVE EXAMPLES ACROSS THE STATE
WERE ONE CITY IS SPENDING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME AND
MONEY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
THE NEIGHBORING CITY IS DOING
NOTHING. IT IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WHEN NEIGHBORING CITIES BEHAVE
SO DIFFERENTLY. THE GOAL OF
HAVING A REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE
IS THAT EVERYONE IS IN AND PART
OF THE PROCESS WE WANT THIS
FIND AND IT'S REGIONAL APPROACH
TO INCENTIVIZE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. TO THE TABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER. NOTHING WILL CHANGE
IF WE ALLOW EVERY CITY AND OR
COUNTY TO CONTINUE TO GET
GUARANTEED FUNDING THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY BAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I WILL FOCUS ON THAT
FUND PROPOSAL THAT HAS JUST
BEEN OUTLINED THE PRIMARY
PURPOSES OF THIS FIND ARE TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS BY MOVING
ALGEBRA ELIGIBLE PERSONS INTO
AFFORDABLE PERMANENT HOUSING
AND TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PERMANENT HOUSING UNITS
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE HOMELESS OR AT
RISK HOMELESSNESS THE FUND WILL
PUSH THESE PURPOSES IN THREE
WAYS THE FIRST PART ANYHOW
RELATED ANGELES SINCE ORDER POT
AND RENTAL SUCH AS- THE SECOND
STABLE. ADULT DENTAL FACILITIES
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND THE THIRD
DEVELOPING UNITS WHETHER NEWLY
BUILT OR CONVERTED FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING THE FUND WILL TAKE
THE REGIONAL APPROACH THAT YOU
JUST HEARD THE UNDERSECRETARY
DESCRIBE RECOGNIZING THE
CHALLENGES OF MOVING PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS AND INTO HOUSING
OFTEN CUT ACROSS CITY AND
COUNTY LINES. REQUIRE REQUIRED
BROUGHT XIN. BOTH LOCAL. AND
NON PROFITS MAY APPLY TO SERVE
AS THE ADMINISTRATOR FOR A
GIVEN REGION. SINCE DIFFERENT
READ REACH DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ENTITIES MAY BE BEST POSITIONED
TO DELIVER THE GOALS OF THE
FUND DEPENDING ON THAT REGION.
REGIONAL MINISTERS WILL BE
SELECTED BASED ON THEIR ABILITY
AND TRACK RECORD AND EVALUATED
AND HELD ACCOUNTABLE ACCORDING
TO CLEARLY DEFINE METRICS. THE
FUND WILL NOT SUBSTITUTE FOR
THE SERVICES CURRENTLY PROVIDED
BY CITIES AND COUNTIES INSTEAD
IT WILL FOCUS DIRECTLY ON THE
NEED TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNITS AND ENABLE MORE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHO ARE HOMELESS OR AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. TO MOVE
AND STAY IN THESE UNITS THESE
EFFORTS WILL ENABLE CITIES
COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO FOCUS ON WHAT
THEY DO BEST. IN A SOCIAL
SERVICES WILL DEVELOP A DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING
PERFORMANCE MONITORING AND
EVALUATION FRAMEWORK TO ASSESS
THE IMPACT OF THE FUN. THE
FRAMEWORK FOR MICHAEL AS I HAD
MENTIONED WILL HAVE CLEAR
METRICS SOME OF THOSE MAY
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF NEW LEASE
IS SIGNED TO THE END OF THE
NUMBER OF NEW HOUSING UNITS
CONVERTED OR BUILT. THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS- STABILIZE TO
RENT SUBSIDIES THE NUMBER OF
INTO IT BUT THE MOVE OFF THE
STREETS AND INTO HOUSING. AND
THE CONNECTIONS MADE TO OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. WE WILL
DESIGN THIS FRIEND IN DATA
COLLECTION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY. DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND THIS IS SUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY.
DIFFERENT WORK WILL BE AND- I
DIDN'T. REQUEST OKAY FOR THREE.
STRAIGHT WE REQUESTED THAT WE
ASK CAN WE BELIEVE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE- REPLICATE. I
CAN BE REAL. SOON DURING AND
THE KEY. CAN BEGIN WORKING ON
THESE PLANS RESPONSE AND TO PUT
THE PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS TO WORK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THE FUND
HAS ALREADY RECEIVED. LINK
FORTY FIVE DOLLARS FROM KAISER
KAISER PERMANENTE A AND BLUE
SHIELD. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO FINALIZE THE
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT IN THE
FUND THE SPRING THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL ALSO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IDENTIFY AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR ACTIVITIES TO
PREVENT REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. AS
REFERENCE BY UNDERSECRETARY
BOSS THE FUND WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
AS THE OP- AT THE STATE SAFETY
NET HOUSING SUPPORTS IN QUIET
SINCE PROGRAMS THIS DEPARTMENTS
WELL POSITIONED TO SUPPORT
HOMELESSNESS IN THEIR HOMELESS
POPULATION. KEEPING THE HOUSE
BILL THE THAT IS THE STATION
FOR ALL OTHER LIFE EXPERIENCE
OUTCOMES. PART OF THE SERVICES
FOR A FOR EVERYONE'S BENEFIT IN
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS AGREED TO
ADD COMMIT SERVICES IN THE PAST
IT CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS FIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE HOUSING
HOMELESS SPACE ASSISTING
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS- ALSO SERVES WITHIN
CERTAIN POPULATIONS OF THOSE
INCLUDE FAMILIES PARTICIPATING
IN OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM. CHILD
WELL FARE COUNTY CHEN
ASSISTANCE AND GENERALLY RELIEF
PROGRAMS DISABILITY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS AND PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. LIKE THESE PROGRAMS
THE HOUSING. OFFERED THE FUNDS
WILL BE GRADED WITH SOCIAL
SYSTEM PROVED LONG OUTCOMES
WITH. WILL SERVE AND IMPROVE
THEIR ABILITY TO STAY HOUSE WE
ARE COMMITTED TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THIS PROCESS
INCLUDING A DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
RIVER FOR APPLICATIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD. TO IN DOLLARS THE WAY.
YOU SAY VERY MUCH DIRECTED.
NEXT WILL. I WISH THAT CATER TO
CHIEF DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT CARE SIR GOOD
MORNING SO MITCHELL AGAIN TAKE
ONE MINUTE AND INTRODUCED
MYSELF I'M DOCTOR GOLD I'M YOUR
NEW DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE BEAUTIFUL THIS IS
DAY FOR ONE YEAH. JUST WELL
I'VE SPENT TIME CAREER EITHER
CARING FRIEND THAT ARE
VULNERABLE ON MEDI CAL HI
AMADOR ADMINISTERED PROGRAM.
PUBLIC TURN TO COUNTIES WITH
ONE OF THEM PEARL PLAN. A CO
AUTHOR AND SEE SO IN EXCITED TO
TAKE THE JOB THIS IS THE NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART ABOUT HOW
YOU CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS- I
WILL BE RELENTLESSLY PHONE ON
TAKING CARE OF THE TOLD NINE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT TURNED
OVER TO JC. TO DO THE ACTUAL
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMING IT'S GREAT TO MEET
OUR DOCTOR AND IS IT HERE BUT
IF YOU HAVEN'T MET. ON DAY
FIGURES FOR EXCELLENT WELL
THAT'S RIGHT THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING EXCELLENT
WELL I TO GET A CHANCE TO MEET
NICE. WE'LL I'M SURE. BEEN SOME
TIME TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING ONE OF HE
PRIMARY GOALS OF CALLIE IS
IDENTIFYING AND MANAGING MEMBER
RISK IN NEED THROUGH A WHOLE
PERSON CARE APPROACHES IN
ADDRESSING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH I THINK THAT'S
EXACTLY THE THING THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK US AND LEARN
FROM COUNTIES WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS BUT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
AND BOTH LARGE AND SMALL
COUNTIES FROM LA TO SHASTA. TO
LEARN FROM YOU'RE DOING TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS CRISIS IN
FRONT OF US ALL OF THOSE PILOTS
IN PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON A FEW
THINGS OUT REGION ENGAGEMENT
INTENSIVE CARE MANAGEMENT. A
SUITE OF HOUSING SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO ADDRESS THIS SAYS
THREE WE PUT TOGETHER CAL TO IT
MANY THINGS. IT WOULD YES THE
WHITE FORM TO ADDRESS THOSE I.
KING IT FROM VERY GOOD PIE. BUT
LEARNING THOSE BEST. IN TAKING
TO SCALE STATEWIDE. I WILL WALK
THROUGH THOSE COMPONENTS- AT A
HIGH LEVEL THE FIRST ONE BEING
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT AND
HEALTH CARE MANAGEMENT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR A LARGE VARIETY
OF VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. IT ALLOWS FOR
PLANS TO CONTRACT WITH COUNTY'S
PUBLIC HOSPITALS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO DO ST
BASED OUTSIDE OF THE FOUR WALLS
ENGAGEMENT WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. IT ALSO WOULD IT
NOT ONLY FOCUS ON HIGH YOU
LETTERS OF MEDICAL COSTS ABOUT
MAYBE FOCUS IT WILL ALSO FOCUS
ON UNDER UTILIZED OF. US OFF
TIMES HIS HOME IS A PART
ACCESSING THEIR HOW SERVICES
AND THIS PACKAGE WOULD BE
AVAILABLE. BOTH OF THOSE INTO
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS TO BE. ALL
ALLOW AND HE MANAGED IT. THE
BRIDGE POSITION IN CARSON.
OFTENTIMES SOMEONE LEAVING
WHO'S BEEN IN FOR A LONG TIME
MAY HOMELESSNESS UPON THAT EXIT
AND THIS PACKAGE WHO'S A POST
SHIN BUT BROWN HAS HER MANAGER
LOOK DOES POINTS INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT WERE
PER. EARLY IN TO TRANSITION
SMOOTHLY THANK THEM WITH
PROTECT OPPORTUNITY. THROUGH
CAL AND WE HAVE A SPEED WAS
CALLED IN LIEU OF SERVICES
PROBABLY NOT THE BEST NAME- BUT
IT DOES MEAN SOMETHING TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE STICKING WITH AT
THIS POINT. BUT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT IT IS IT ANY OF AB
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT CAN BE
OFFERED IN ADDITION TO ENHANCE
CARE MANAGEMENT THAT IS IN
CALLIN. CALL IT. A BUNDLE FOR
LACK OF DESCRIPTION WHICH
INCLUDES HAVING A HOUSING
NAVIGATION SERVICES. HELPING
SOMEBODY IDENTIFIED. I'M IN
SECURING THOSE PIECES A LOT OF
ENGAGEMENT GOES INTO IDENTIFIED
SOMEONE WHO'D BE A GOOD
CANDIDATE FOR HOUSING AND
WORKING THEM TO GET INTO
HOUSING IT WOULD INCLUDE THE
DEPOSIT. MONTHS MONTHS RIGHT
YOU TOO IT APART IT'S NOT GET
SOMEBODY HOUSING INTO HOME.
ALSO INCLUDES LEE A SERVICES
ONCE SOMEONE IS HOUSED
TENDENCIES A STATE THIS IS
THERE KEEP OUT BEST HAS ISSUED
AMER TO WHAT MEDICAID CANNING
CANNOT COVER IN THESE INSTANCES
AND BE ALL A LOT. THIS IS FOR-
FOR WITHIN BOB FOR. IT THE VERY.
THE THEM HOUSE TO ENSURE THE
STATE HOUSE WELL MEDICAID.
RENTAL SUBSIDIES OR RENT WE CAN
PAY FOR THOSE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES TO ENSURE SOMEONE GETS
HOUSE AND CAN STAY HOUSE. THERE
ARE OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE
VERY COMPLEMENTARY TO THIS FOR
EXAMPLE RETRIBUTIVE CARE IF YOU
HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN
ADMITTED TO A HOSPITAL-
RECEIVING TREATMENT- AND WE
NEED TO GET THEM DISCHARGED
FROM THE HOSPITAL BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE A HOME TO GO TO. A
PHYSICIAN MAY NOT JUSTICE
CHARGE SOMEONE TO THE STREET
OFTENTIMES HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
CAN RESIDE IN AN INPATIENT
SETTING FOR EXIT A VERY VERY
LONG PERIOD OF TIME WE LONG
WITH THIS NECESSARY FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A PLACE
TO BE DISCHARGED. RECOUP CARE
IS OPTION OF SERVICE PACKAGE.
IS THE TODAY PLEADED. IN IN.
SETTING FOR UP TO NOW DAYS TO
GET SOME CLINICAL SIR IT ALSO
ALLOWS US TO ENGAGE EARLY TO
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT AND
CONNECT THEM TO POTENTIAL
HOUSING OP OPPORTUNITIES IN
FRONT OF THEM. THE OTHER PIECE
WHICH IS IN THERE IS CALLED DAY
HABILITATION PROGRAMS THIS
ALLOWS. CITIES OR AREAS THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION A PLACE TO MEET
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS ON
THE STREETS TO ENGAGE THEM
AROUND PERSONAL SKILLS AND
DEVELOPMENT. DAILY LIVING
SKILLS AS WELL AS CONNECTING UP
TO THE VERY SOCIAL SERVICES AND
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES WHICH WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT TODAY. ONE
PIECE IT'S ALSO INCLUDED IN
CALLIN IS INCENTIVES BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT THIS IS A LARGE
AMBITION THERE IS A LOT TO DO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS VERY
LARGE. SO THERE IS INCENTIVE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
IN OUR PROPOSAL TO HELP US
BUILD STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE
WE DO HAVE GAPS THE DEPARTMENT
IS CURRENTLY THINKING THROUGH
HOW WILL WE INCENTIVIZE THE
RIGHT THINGS TO BUILD THESE
GAPS STATEWIDE. AND THE NEEDLE.
THESE SERVICES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THE STREETS LEAVING
INSTITUTIONS AND CORRECTIONAL
OPPORTUNITY- FACILITIES WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT'S CLEAR
BECAUSE IT DOES ALLOW FOR THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE BUILT THIS
PROGRAM. TO CATCH THEM TO ALL
OF THOSE VARIOUS POINTS WHICH
IS A CRITICAL PIECE AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT WEIRD PEOPLE MAY
FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS AND
TAKING MORE PREVENTIVE AND
EARLY INTERVENTION. INSTEAD OF
JUST WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO
FALL INTO THIS MESS. I'M GOING
TO QUICKLY GO OVER A FEW OTHER
PIECES THAT ARE VERY
COMPLEMENTARY TO THIS AND CAL
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA.
OF THE REST OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING CALENDAR HOW CAN HELP. A
NUMBER OF FRONTS IN ADDITION TO
THE IN. IN LIEU OF SO WILL
WIRING IN OUR PROPOSAL BY
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THE ALL INDIVIDUALS LEAVING
INCARCERATION WOULD BE ENROLLED
FOR MEDI ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
OUT IF ELIGIBLE- PRIOR TO BEING
RELEASED ANYONE WHO IS
RECEIVING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHILE INCARCERATED
WOULD HAVE A WARM HAND OFF TO
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN THERE I NEED TO
ENSURE THAT TREATING CAN
CONTINUE IT IS. PART IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT AND ON THIS AND
TO CONTINUE TREATMENT- SO IN A
VERY GOOD ENVIRONMENT. AND LAST
BUT DEFINITELY NOT LEAST WE ARE
MAKING HUGE STRIDES ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
AREA. LARGE REFORMS THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE ABLE TO DO
PAYMENT REFORM CHANGING THE WAY
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT. THE
SAME. WELL AS LOOKING AT TO AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEMS BE HE
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE. MANY OF US KNOW
THAT IS SOMEWHAT MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE CO OCCURRING
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISEASES AND WE NEED AN
ENVIRONMENT IN A CLINICAL
SETTING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SETTING. THAT ALLOWS FOR THOSE
SERVICES TO BE INTEGRATED FOR
PEOPLE TO. BETTER ACCESS TO
CARE. SO A LEADING THIS I'VE
BEEN A BENEFICIARY OF MEDICARE
ALL AND I'VE ALSO BEEN A LOCAL
IMPLEMENTER AND NOW THIS TICKET
DIRECTOR I HOPE TO TAKE ALL
THESE IT. IS TOGETHER TO BE
ABLE TO HELP BUILD A BETTER.
APPRECIATE THAT BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT WITNESS I'M
GOING TO PAUSE AND ASK THE A
COMMITTEE SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL ROLE BECAUSE WE I DON'T.
SENATORS HAD FORMALLY LOST
APPOINT SOMEONE DO IT RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU AND IT IS MITCHELL
HERE. NIELSEN WELL. BARGES
CABALLERO. DOLLY DRAW SO HER
TADO LEYVA. MCGUIRE MY NAME.
MORE LOCK MORALE. PAN ROTH
SKINNER. STERN WHY BECAUSE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DESERVED
NOW THE OF A. NEXT. TWENTY FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION AND THREE
POSITIONS IN BUDGET YEAR AND A
TOTAL THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION OVER SIX
YEARS THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO IMPLEMENT
COMMUNITY CARE COLLABORATIVE
PILOT PROJECT THIS PILOT
PROGRAM SEEKS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL LIVING
WITH SERIOUS ILLNESS WHO
RECYCLING IN AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS AND INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING OUR STATE HOSPITALS
<c.yellow>AIL AND PRISONS. TO PROVIDE</c>
SOME BACKGROUND AND CONTEXT TO
THIS PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS PROVIDES
RESTORATION OF COMPETENCY FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOR FOUND INTO
STAND TRIAL ON FELONY CHARGES
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS BEING TO
BE TESTING TRIAL ONE WHO HAS
BEEN ARREST. AND I A COURT DUE
TO THEIR MENTAL. UNABLE
THIRSTING THE NEEDS OF THE
CHARGE AGAINST SOME OR UNABLE
ASSIST COUNCIL IN THERE TO. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOUND IN TO
STAND TRIAL ON CHARGE THEY WERE
TO THE DEPARTMENT INDIVIDUALS
ARE FOUND IN DISTINTA I MISS.
CHARGE ARE RESTORED THE-
RESTORING IT IN THE TO
COMPETENT RIVER FOLK JUST ON
STATE. THEIR MENTAL HOW SOME.
AND TEACHING THEM BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT COURT
PROCESSES AND ROLLS AND THEN
ONCE THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
RESTORE TO COMPETENCY THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS THEN RETURNED TO
COURT TO PROCEED WITH THEIR DUE
PROCESS THIS IS NOT LONG TERM
TELL HEALTH CARE TREATMENT FOR
END OF. WITH SERVICEMEN ILLNESS.
AND ALLOW SEVERAL YEARS. TO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR RESTORATION OF
COMPETENCY TREATMENT AND WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN AND MANY STEPS TO
RESPOND TO THE DEMANDS.
INCREASE CREASING THE NUMBER OF.
AND TREATMENT. FOR AT TO SERVE
IN. WHO HAVE BEEN IN CA TO
TRIAL WE'VE OPENED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BEDS. FIVE
HUNDRED OVER FIVE HUNDRED IN
THE HOSPITAL THREE HUNDRED IN
JAIL BASED PROGRAMS AND I'VE
BEEN PARTNERING BOSSING. CAN A
COUNTY TO OFFER COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF PROCESS KRUGMAN LET
LEGISLATIVE AND WE DO GOING.
BEFORE THE POPULAR BUT I'M ARE
CURRENTLY. TEMPLATE DIVERSION.
FOR AN FOR THIS. BUT DESPITE
THAT. THE INCREASE NUMBER HOW
THE OB ARE. OUR WORK. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE NEARLY EIGHT AND
FIFTY AND OF A WHO ARE PENDING.
TO A STATE HOSPITAL PRO BAD IN
END OF WHO IS PLAY IS WAITING
IN JAIL AND OFTEN UP TO SEVERAL
MONTHS. IN OUR EFFORTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CONTINUED
INCREASE WE REVIEWED OUR
POPULATION TO TRY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS DRIVING THIS
THE INCREASING REFERRALS. A
MAJORITY OF THE PATIENTS ARE
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT AS
INCOME TO STAND TRIAL HAVE A
MAJOR PSYCHOTIC OR MADE
DISORDER AND IT HAD MULTIPLE
PRIOR ARRESTS IN FACT.
APPROXIMATELY 45% FIFTEEN OR
MORE PRIOR ARRESTS AND NEARLY
HALF FOREIGN AND CHILDREN
HOMELESS STATUS AT THE TIME OF
THEIR ARREST. NEARLY HALF COULD
NOT ACCESS THEIR MEDIC ALL
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS IN THE
SIX MONTHS LEADING TO THEIR-
TERMINATION OF THE RESTAURANT.
DIED FOR YES HE IS THERE IS
OFTEN A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE ARREST AND THEIR CONDITION
UPON ONE MISSED IN THEIR SIDE
SOMETIMES AND WE ALSO LOW AT
THE IN THE INCOME TO STAND
POPULAR WHO WERE CHARGE FROM
OUR PRO IN FOR FIFTEEN TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT OVER THE
NEXT YEAR AND WITHIN THREE
YEARS OF THE DISK. THE 9% OF
THEM WERE REAR AND. ACTED WITH
CRIMES WITHIN THREE YEARS. SO%
DATA REALLY REFER THE IN. WITH
A- SO. OF SERIOUS ON OUR SITE
AND OF OUR J. AND INSTEAD. ARE
OFTEN IN AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS CONTINUING TO
CREATE MORE R. D. S. H.
CAPACITY AND JAIL BASE CAPACITY
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE FACTORS
THAT ARE. TO THIS CASE IN
DEMAND. THAT'S THE CONTINUED AT
COMMUNITY CARE POT- COLLABORATE
PILOT PROJECT THIS YEAR WHICH
FOCUSES ON DEMONSTRATING
STRATEGIES. TO DEVELOP THE
CONTINUING. UNITY HOW AND- I
READ. PLACE TO BUT AS A SIX
PILOT PROJECTS WITH THREE CAL.
OVER ON ONE NORTON NORTHERN
CENTRAL IN SOUTHERN CAL CAN AND
WE'RE FOCUSED ON COUNTY THAT
REFERS OF THE HIGH. NUMBER AT
INCOME STAND TRIAL PAGE TO
DEPARTMENT THERE'S TWO PRIME
COME. TO PROPOSE. ONE IS
FUNDING FOR THE COUNTIES TO
DEVELOP AND PROVIDE COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION PROGRAMS IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND THE SECOND
PIECE IS TIERED MY SON SENT TO
THE COUNTY IF THE IT TO
DIFFERENT. GOALS THE FIRST
BEING REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE REFERRED
TO THE DEPARTMENT ANNUALLY FOR
RESTORATION OF. THE CEASE SAYS.
SECOND IS A READER OF OVER.
DESIGNATIONS AND REDUCTION OF
THE OVERALL TECHNICIAN I HAVE
FOUND. IT TO STAND TRIAL MEAN.
THE ARREST SEVEN IT'LL SERIOUS
MEANT ILLNESS. THE ANNUAL
ADVENTURE GOALS A 60% OVER SIX
YEARS AND THESE AND SENT TO
INCLUDE TEARS FOR PAYMENT THE
COUNTY ACHIEVES A MINIMUM READ
AMOUNT EACH YEAR SO IT'S NOT AN
OR NOT PROP. THE FUNDING THE
COUNTY THROUGH THESE AND CENTER
WOULD BE TO BE INVEST INTO
FURTHER BENJI FOR A THE REST
AND RARE OF IT IT'S ALSO SIR
MENTAL ILLNESS. BY
PARTICIPATING COUNTY WILL
REQUIRED SUMMIT WAS TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OF AN OUTCOME FOR
SO THAT WE CAN AND THE PILOT
PRO. AND THE SIX OF THESE
PILOTS MORE INTO THE WITH MEANT
ILLNESS WILL BE TOO AND RE THE-
YOUR INDIVIDUALS WITH SERVICE
ILLNESS WILL CYCLE THROUGH THE
JUSTICE THIS REDUCE THE WAIT
LIST FOR INDIVIDUALS FOUND. TO
STAND OUT AND WE FOR THIS
HOSPITAL BEDS FOR A WHO NEED
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE IN A HIGH
LEVEL OF THIS CLOTHES IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN THE PARKS. ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SEE MR
THIS ONE OFTEN OUT WITH US SO
WE WILL IF SOMEONE FROM. GOING
TO. BE THERE AND I'LL SEE HE'S-
BUT- YEAH. PERFECT APPRECIATE
YOU THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU
VERY TO THE SO BATTLE. MOVING
ON TO FOR WHICH IS LOCAL CON
AND FIRST THE MULLIN BY. AND
YOU DURING. YOU HAVE TO CORRECT
ME HOMELESS ALLEN FOR THE CITY
OF. HEIDI MARSTON EXEC OF THE
LAW ANGELES HOME SERVICES ALSO
KNOWN AS LHASA. DINA FUENTES
THAT THE DIRECTOR DE EXACTLY
DIRECTOR THIS DINNER COUNTY CA
OF THE HOUSING. SHOULD BONTA
FOR. DIRECTOR MAP POSTED CAL
HELP THE SERVICES. AND WILLIAM
PICKLE CHIEF EXECUTIVE I OF
BRILLIANT CORNER. THANK YOU
VERY IN WE'RE INTO IN HEARING
PER SPECT AT THE LOW LEVEL
WE'LL GO IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
LISTEN THE AGENDA. GOOD MORNING
REALLY I MENTOR KINK YOUR
CLOTHES ARE BRIGHTER KINK AND I
WORK IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO'S HOMELESS SERVICES
DIVISION. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE ON
THE EFFORTS ASSOCIATED WITH
KEEP AND HOP. I'LL TOUCH ON THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS OUR
COMMUNITY ON THE STEAK AS AS
WELL AS AN OVERVIEW OF THE
INVEST MADE. IN OPPORTUNITIES.
THE FRONT END BEFORE. IT WAS A
WAR ENDING THE CITY OF SAN.
COUNTY OF SOCCER IN THE LOW
CONTINUE KERLEY AGENTS SOCCER
STEPS FORWARD. ESTABLISHED A
WERE GROUP WHICH SOUGHT TO
DEPICT FRAMEWORK FOR INVESTING
HE FUNDS INTO LOCAL. GROUP WORK
ESTABLISH A THIRTY PLAN WHICH
TOOK AND TOOK GATHERING
COMMUNITY INPUT ON LOCAL NEED
IDENTIFYING STRENGTHS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING RESOURCES. MISSION
COMMUTER WHITES KEY PROGRAM A
SUCH AS DURING RE HOUSE AND OUT
AND DEVELOP THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY FOR US TO ADMINISTER ANY
VALUE LOCAL. WE INCLUDED LABOR
EXIST ADMITS INFRASTRUCTURE
THIS AND CAL. IT IS THROUGH
THESE APPROACHES THAT ARE CAN
HAS DEVELOPED UNIFIED FORCE
AROUND KEEP AND HAPPEN
VESTMENTS BUT ALSO LOCAL
INVESTMENTS MORE FROM. THE HAS
LED TO THE CREATION SPACE FOR
BARBAROUS FALLS COMMUNITY DIE
I'M FUNNY ENTITIES THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS. ARE STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE FOLKS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SUCH CLUB
APPROACHES HAVE BEGUN TO BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS AGENCIES
WHERE. EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS HAVE STRICT BAN
SILO. THROUGH THE CITY WAS THE
FIVE POINT SIX DOLLAR AND THE-
CONTINUE OF CARE RECEIVED POINT
SEVEN WHILE THIS- THE COUNTY
DID NOT RECEIVE A DIRECT
ALLOCATION IF YOU FUNDING THE
CITY COUNTY AN SS. WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. ON THE
INVESTMENT STRATEGY WHICH- IN
THE CITY TAKEN ON MANY OF THE
SHELTERING PROJECTS AND THE
COUNTY ADMINISTERING OUR FIRST
COMMUNITY WIDE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
POOL. WHICH IS A RESOURCE THAT
IS CONNECTED TO OUR REACH AND
SHELTERING- AIMS TO MORE
QUICKLY RE HOUSE FOLKS-
ASSOCIATE WITH THOSE PROGRAMS.
THROUGH HERE THE CITY. A AND A
SAT WELL TO ME. THE NINETEEN
MILLION INVEST. TO X. EGGS.
PROGRAM ALSO NEW IN FAVOR OF
BROWN'S FOR. A DO YOU. ONLY AS
A SINGLE ADULT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THIS CALL EFFORT.
TO FUN OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SOME SEVEN. BY SO HUNDRED
FLEXIBLE. SLOTS X. OF OUR
COMMITTEE A RICH. FIFTEEN IN
ALL NOT THAT HOW DOES IT ARE
ADVOCATE. IT UNDER KEEP FOR
LARGE NAVIGATION CENTERS THAT
WE ARE OPENING AND THE YOUTH
PROGRAMMING THAT WE HAVE
STARTED. IN THE COUNTY-
ANTICIPATES THAT WITH THEIR
HAVE FUNDS THEY WILL ALSO
CONTINUE EXISTING KEEP
INVESTMENTS BUT NOT MOST
NOTABLY IN THE EXPANSION OF OUR
COMMUNITY FLEXIBLE HOUSING
POOL. THEY ALSO INTEND TO IMPLY
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH IS
AIMED AT SERVING SENIORS- AS
WELL AS PREVENTION RE HOUSING
ACTIVITY SPECIFICALLY FOR
TRANSITION H. YOUTH AND
CONNECTING THOSE TWO PROGRAM IS
TO DO WITH TO. AND THIS. THE
CAN OF CARE PRIMARILY ECONOMICS
THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING PULL FOR
HOUSEHOLD ALREADY ATTEND.
THROUGH OUR LOCAL COURT NEED
ENTRIES COMMUNITY Q. AS AN
EFFORT TO HELP MOVE THOSE FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN- SEEKING SERVICES
INTO HOUSING. AND THEY ALSO I
INTEND TO INCREASE LANDLORD
ENGAGEMENT THROUGH PROPERTY
RELATED TENANTS SERVICES AND
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
THINGS. THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
OUR SUCCESSFUL IN KEEPING FOLKS.
WASTE PLEASE WITH THE INTENT OF
LESSENING THE RELIANCE ON
HOUSING PLACEMENT THE
COORDINATED AT THE COMMUNITY
CENTER ENTRY SYSTEM WHICH IS
SOMETIMES NOT ALWAYS THE BEST
APPROACH TO RESOLVING
SOMEBODY'S HOMELESSNESS.
ALTHOUGH OUR COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
ABLE TO EXPAND RE HOUSING AND
SHELTERING SERVICES THERE ARE
STILL CONTINUED OPPORTUNITIES
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE LAST. THE
NEAT. MEANT AS- PART. ONCE AS A
CAN WE ARE LIKE SEEN A IN FOLKS
COMING ACTED FOR IN THE OF
SERVE AND ARE SO AS IT IS A NOW
IS CURRENTLY A TO QUICK MEET
THAT NEED WE SEE IMMEDIATELY
WHICH IS TO BE HAVE A HEALTH
AND EIGHTY TREATMENTS AS A
CRITICAL TO COMPLEMENTING OUR
COMMITTEES ARE REACHED SHELTER
AND WE HOUSING EFFORTS AND WE
SEE THESE SERVICES AS A PART OF
BETTER ASSISTING PEOPLE IN
RESOLVING THE HOMELESSNESS BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY MAINTAINING
THEIR HOUSING. LAST HAS BEEN
VERY APPRECIATE OF THE STATE'S
SUPPORT INTEREST IN
HOMELESSNESS BOTH IN OUR
COMMUNITY PUSHED ACROSS THE
STATE. AS WELL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIPS- AT THIS TIME LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE. AND IN
TIMES COME WHEN THE TIME COMES
FOR QUESTIONS I'LL BE AVAILABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
HEIDI MARSTON ACOSTA. I YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND TESTIFY
TODAY- LOSS AS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY BETWEEN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY OF LA AND IS THE
LEADING. TRADE OF ENTITY FOR
THE LOS ANGELES CONTINUUM OF
CARE. ADMINISTERING ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THIS
FISCAL YEAR AND FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS. IN OUR C. O. C.
WE SEE MORE PEOPLE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAN
ANY OTHER C. O. C. IN
CALIFORNIA- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ARE HOMELESS COUNT
SHOW THAT WE HAD. FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND FIFTY SEVEN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS 75%
OF WHOM WERE ON SHELTERED.
SPIKE CONTINUED INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS THE ADDITION OF
LOCAL RESOURCES HAS BEEN
ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL IN MEETING
FURTHER INCREASES IN LA.
HOMELESSNESS IN LA C. O. C.
ROSE BY 7% BETWEEN. EIGHTEEN
AND- IN. EIGHT OF EIGHT WHITE
INCREASE WHICH WAS 14% OVER
THAT PERIOD. LAST YEAR OUR
SYSTEM MADE MORE THAN TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND PERMANENT HOUSING
PLACEMENTS THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY
I'M MORE THAN 81% INCREASE FROM
OUR PLACEMENT RATES TWENTY IN.
THIS MENDOZA GRASS WERE. DARK
RIGHT BE THE LAST. THE END BUT
ANOTHER AND FIFTY PEOPLE FELL
INTO HOMELESSNESS EVERY SINGLE
DAY. THOSE ECONOMIC FACTORS
CONTINUE TO DRIVE ELOISE CRISIS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE NEWLY
HOMELESS HALF OF OUR ON
SHELTERED ADULTS IN LA C. O. C.
ARE ON THEIR FIRST EPISODE OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND OF THAT
NUMBER 53% SITE ECONOMIC
FACTORS INCLUDING OBJECTIONS
JOB LOSS AND RISING RENTS AS
THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF THEIR
HOMELESSNESS. IF YOU PLAY A
UNIQUE ROLE IN THIS EFFORT- IN
LA LHASA IS POSITION BETWEEN
CITIES WHICH CONTROL OUR LAND
USE AUTHORITIES AND THE COUNTY
WHICH ADMINISTERS OUR SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS CEO SEES BRING
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE TO.
RECORD THE RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS ONE EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS A NEW INITIATIVE THAT
LOSSES LEADING CALLED HOUSING
CENTRAL COMMAND WHICH LOST A
LOT LATELY ALL OF THE NINETEEN.
PRO TO THE DISASTERS MODEL TO
ART READ. THE LARGER OF PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN LA AND RE
HOUSING THEM RAPIDLY. IN LA
HOUSING CENTRAL COMMAND BRINGS
TOGETHER THE CO SEAT THE CITY
OF LA COUNTY HOUSING AUTHORITY
EVEN THE- VETERANS AFFAIRS. TO
SHARE DATA IN REAL TIME BUT
WHAT HOUSING RESEARCH YOUR
AVAILABLE TO IT IF I OBSTACLES
TO PLACING PEOPLE IN THE
HOUSING AND TO REMOVE THOSE
BARRIERS. HOUSE MEN'S. MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN AN
EQUITABLE AND EXPEDIENT MANNER.
IN LA R. C. S. IS RELATIVELY
YOUNG ABOUT FIVE YEARS OLD AS
SUCH LHASA IS CURRENTLY LEADING
A SERIES OF REFINEMENT
WORKSHOPS WITH OUR PROVIDER
NOW. TO LEARN WORKING IN A
PORTANTINO VICTORY SYSTEM WE
CAN CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS. SEE IF YOU CAN
ALSO LIFT UP WHAT WORKS AS THE
ADMINISTRATORS OF BOTH CVS AND
HMIS DATA IN STRUCTURE WERE
TASKED WITH UNDERSTANDING WHAT
INTERVENTIONS ARE WHAT. WHAT
ISN'T WORKING AND BRING THESE
FIND OUR PARTNERS. FINALLY WERE
THE ENTITY THAT WORKS TO
IMPLEMENT NATIONAL BEST TO SIT
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL. OVER THE
YEARS I'VE LEARNED THAT S
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES LIKE
HOUSING FIRST. OUT COM SUCH AS
LONG MORE STABLE STAYS IN.
HOUSING THE SEES CAN ENSURE
THAT THESE BEST PRACTICES MOVE
FROM GUIDANCE ON THE GROUND TO
PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION. WHAT
IS GRATEFUL TO SEE THE STATE
PLAYING A CRITICAL AND ROBUST
ROLE IN SUPPORTING IN
COORDINATING HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITH KEEP IT HAPPY. WITH
KEEPING HAVE LOST A HAS
INVESTED IN INNOVATIVE EFFORTS
AUGMENTED WHAT'S WORKING AND
DEEP IN COLLABORATION ACROSS
OUR JURISDICTIONS. WE USE OUR
KEEP FUNDING TO LODGE OUR
PROBLEM SOLVING PROGRAM BASED
ON NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED BEST
PRACTICES AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION DIVERSION. LOSSES
PROGRAM COMBINES MEANING OUT
PREVENTION FOR STAFF AT POINTS
OF ENTRY IT FROM OUR MEANS.
STONE AT RC STEMS ARE UPSTREAM
FROM THE HOMELESS SYSTEM SUCH
AS SERVICES PROBATION AND URBAN
OF CHILDREN IN MY SERVICES. IN
ADDITION TO PREVENT PREVENTION
TRAINING OF THE STAFF CAN
ACCESS FOUGHT A CIVIL FINE IT
ASSISTANCE TO REDUCE IT. YES
SIX MONTHS WE'VE TRIED TO FIND
FIFTY P. LA COUNTY THESE. LATER
THIS YEAR WILL BE USING HALF
FUND TO TRAIN STAFF FROM DOZENS
OF CITIES THROUGHOUT THE CEO
SEE AN INVITING THEM TO ACCESS
SIMILAR PREVENTION RESOURCES.
WE'VE ALSO YOU STATE FUNDS TO
AUGMENT SUCCESS USING HEAP WE
ENHANCE THE CASE MANAGEMENT OF
OUR RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAMS
FOR FAMILIES AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES WE PLACED
INTO PERMANENT HOUSING OVER ONE
THOUSAND. I BELIEVE SO CAN
BUILD ON. SHE THE GOVERNOR
COMMITMENT TO INCREASING
RESOURCES MORE FUNDING FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE ONE OF OUR
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSAL
WOULD BE VERY WELCOME TO
THURSDAY FOR A WAYS- WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD BE
ENHANCED ONE TIME FOR. AND
BEING WELL I'M I'M GOING
FUNDING IS WHAT THE SYSTEM
NEEDS TO MAKE THOUGHTFUL
INVESTMENTS THAT AND PEOPLE'S
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY RENTALS
SINCE IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
ADDITIONALLY LHASA IS A FUND
FUNDING SHELL BEDS EARLY USING
BEEN HAP. CONCERNED ABOUT IN IN
NEEDED TO PRO I'M THAT PROVIDE
IN CD FOR ANGELENOS WITHOUT A
SENSE OF HOW WAS PROGRAMS WILL
BE SUSTAINED HOW EXPENSE. WE'RE
ALSO CAN THAT IT'LL INDUSTRY
STRUCK. A CREEK THANK SYSTEM
THAT COST CORDON OR BRING TO
BEAR THE RESOURCES OF THE
COUNTIES WITH THEIR SAFETY NOT
SYSTEMS AND THE CITIES WITH
THEIR LAND USE AUTHORITIES. SEE
A SEIZE WITH THEIR DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND MECHANISMS
FOR ABILITY HELP TATE BRITIAN.
FIND IT WE RECORD THE POPPING
CARE FACILITY ARE CRISIS AND WE
NEED ACTION TO PRESERVE THESE
FACILITIES- BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCLUSION
OF BOARDING CARE FUNDING AS A
PART OF THE SEVEN. FIFTY
MILLION IN MEN FOR FACILITIES
OWN SEPARATE DEDICATED FUNDING
TO CHIEF STABILIZATION AND
INCLUDE THEM AS A PART OF THIS
APPLICATION COULD. COULD ENACT
GLOBAL. OR IN CASE BROWN THE
STATE AND DROP FUNDING AWAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS MATTER I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THEY YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU BEING HERE NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM. DEAN OF WINTERS
WITH YOU KNOW COUNTY ELEMENT
HOUSING AGENCY WELCOME. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT. DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNARDINO COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING A TEAM
THIS YEAR ACTUALLY MARKS MY
THIRTY FIFTH YEAR WORKING IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR THE SIX OF
THOSE YEARS THE MINUTES LEVEL.
YOUR WORK ANY OF OUR NINETEEN.
IF WE SAID IN A DRESS ALMOST
NOTHING MY EXPERTISE IS IN THE
AREA OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THIS PLATFORM TO
DISCUSS HOMELESSNESS AND
INVESTING FONG THAT ALLOW
LATITUDE STRUCTURE PROGRAMS
DRESS CODE CHALLENGES. ONE SUCH
PRIVATE PROGRAM THE STATUS
CREATED AS- PROGRAM THAT
POPULATION IS THE HIGHER RISK
HIGHS UTILIZING. AND THE
COUNTIES THE COUNTY OF. THOSE
ALLIES HOPPERS CARE FUNDS IT
HAS REACHED TO THROUGH
PROVIDING HOUSING NAVIGATION
AND OUT REACHED SERVICES THE
SERVICE EMPLOYMENT ACCORDING
NAY WITH THE VERY. BEST
PROGRAMS FIND BY STATE AND-
PLEASE FOR THE COUNTY OF MEDINA
THE PROGRAM IT. BY THEIR OWN NO
MEDICAL. CARE IS FOR THE EQUITY
HOUSING IS THE KEY PROVING AND
ENDING HOMELESS. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF ONE TIME FUNDS
ADDRESSED HOMELESSNESS TO HAVE
SOME PAIN. BUT THE STATE CREEKS.
PROVIDE SUSTAINABLE FINANCE.
NEWS TO CONSTRUCTION COST ONE
TIME FUNDS ARE NOT ENOUGH FOR
US TO COLLECTIVELY ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES BEFORE US THE OF
PEOPLE THAT. HOMELESS MANY ARE
DEALING PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED CHALLENGES SHORT
TERM PROGRAMS RAPID RE HOUSE
MAY NOT ACHIEVE A SUSTAINABLE
XIN FOR THE PRODUCT YES WHEN
THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DISSIPATES. LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ARE ALL SINCE. BEST NUMBER THEY
IS INCREASE SHELTER IN SHELTER
BEDS DOCTOR MEDIA PROVIDE.
LEAVE START OUR BELONG BUT
THERE IS. FUN OPERATE SHIP OR
FUNDS TO CREATE. NEW HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ALL THE FOLKS
THAT WE HELP JUST END UP BACK
ON THE STREET. IN MAXIMIZING
RES. URGE OF THE SHORT TERM
FUNDING BE CONSOLIDATED INTO
ONE ENTITY AND A ROLE THE
VARIOUS HELD HOMELESS GRANT
PROGRAMS AND ANY NEW SHORT TERM
RESEARCH. INTO A MASTER
AGREEMENT MANAGED BY ONE
APARTMENT THIS REDUCE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN RESULTING
IN MORE RESOURCES TO HELP THOSE
KING AND SERVICE. THE STATE
NEEDS TO BE AMENDED INCOME
FINANCING VEHICLES. CAPITAL
STRUCK NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
TO HOUSE THE CHRONIC HOMELESS
POPULATION WHO HAVE LIMITED
INCOME OR INCOME POTENTIAL ONLY
ONE STATE PROGRAM NOPE SPIKE
HOME PROVIDES FUNDS FOR NOT
JUST CONSTRUCTION BUT OPERATING
AND THE LACK OF ON SUBSIDIES AS
LIMITING OUR ABILITY TO YOU
KNOW. THE COUNTY OF SAN DINO
HAS THE PAPERS EFFORTS TO
ALMOST A THE LAST TEN YEARS
COUNTY HAS FINANCED OVER THE
NEW IT'S AN UNITS IN THE
PIPELINE SINCE THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY FIFTH ACCOUNT HELP
RESOLVE THIS FOR. VETERANS ALL
OF THE UNITS AND PART. STATE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND T.
TOWNIE PIVOTED AT THE HOW THE
F. TO CREATE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNIT. IN
PROJECT IS A DISTINCTION OF THE
COUNTIES GOAL TO DEVELOP
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THIS PROJECT INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THE CONTINUING HOUSING
NEEDS OF THE COUNTY'S HOMELESS
CHRONICALLY POPULATION WERE
LIVING WITH THE PAIR MENTALLY
MENTAL ILLNESS. OR ARE VETERANS.
RATING CITY FROM NOBLE LIKE
HOME CRUCIAL FOR THE LONG TERM
VIABILITY OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS THIS
IS EVEN MORE VITAL FOR OUR
COUNTY BECAUSE OUR LOCAL. STORE
NO- HAS THE TO PROVIDE PROJECT
BASED VOUCHERS VOUCHERS TO PAY
RENT FOR THE PERMANENT PART OF
HOUSING UNITS THIS IS BECAUSE-
I'M IT'S NOT. THANKS CHURCH
THAT CAN BE CONVERTED PROP
BASED. AND OVER THE YEARS OUR
HOUSING AUTHORITY HAS
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PERMANENT SUPPORT
OF HOUSE. AT AS A TO PLAY THEIR
BOXERS THE COUNTIES EFFORT TO
SECURE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
FUNDING IS HAS ON ONLY AT A
ROBOT DUE TO THE COUNTIES AND-
TWO. PLACE LIKE HOME THESE DUE
TO THE OF ACCESS TO PROJECT
BASED VOUCHERS AND OF THIS
CURRENT CROP. THIS IMPACT
COUNTIES THE HOUSE ARE HOMELESS.
AS YOU PROCEED AWAITING THE
BUDGET PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR AND FUTURE BUDGET YEARS I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING TO DEVELOP A CAPRI
STRATEGY WITH. THE STATE'S
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. CREATE SHORT
AND LONG TERM MONEY THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN RELY UPON TO
CARRY OUT THE STATE STRATEGY ON
THE LOCAL STRATEGIES THAT
REGIONALIZATION NEEDS TO OCCUR
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. INCENTIVIZE
ORGANIC EFFORTS CUSTOMIZED BY
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES. MODIFY
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CAPITAL PROGRAM THE STATE RUNS
TO INCLUDE CAPITAL OPERATING.
AS AN ELIGIBLE EXPENDITURE AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO FINANCE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATING. YOU
CONNECTING LOCAL HEALTH NOT
HEALTH FUNDING FOR HOUSING OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS CONSOLIDATE YOUR
SHORT TERM PROGRAMS INTO UNDER
ONE ENTITY TO MAXIMIZE SERVICE
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE TO INCLUDE
COUNTIES OF THE VEHICLE TO
COURT RESOURCES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICES. AND
WE CANNOT SAY WITH MOST OUT. TO
HOUSING AND- NEW UNITS ALL OF
WHICH TO BE COUPLED WITH
SERVICES I WANT TO THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNARDINO AND SEES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU.
BUDGET AND- ANALYSTS IF YOU'VE
GOT- WRITTEN TESTIMONY HE
WOULD- BE KIND ENOUGH TO SHARE
IT WITH THEM THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL HAVE ACCESS TO IT
FOR FUTURE REFERENCE THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH ONE DOES NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM CHIFFON QATARI-
FROM MARIPOSA COUNTY HEALTH
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY ON THIS
CRITICAL TOPIC. SORRY DIRECTOR
HELPING HUMANS. AGENCY FROM
MARIPOSA COUNTY. AND MY
COLLEAGUES AND I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LONG TIME
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE MADAM
CHAIR AS WELL AS THE LEADERSHIP
OF GOVERNOR NEWSOME. AS SHOWN
IN HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL AND HIS
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
RECENTLY. AS A HUMAN IS EIGHT
ZERO. AND AS A RURAL COMMUNITY
I WEAR MANY HATS I AM THE
SOCIAL SERVICES DIRECTOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR. AS WELL
AS OVERSEEN SENIOR SERVICES
VETERANS SERVICES HOUSING AND
HOMELESS PROGRAMS AND OUR WHOLE
PERSON CAN PROGRAM. FURTHERMORE
NOT FASTER IS IN RECENT YEARS
HAVE EXACERBATED THE HOMELESS
CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITY. I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE C. W. D. A
LEADERSHIP TEAM HAVING SERVED
AT THE AS ITS TWENTY NINETEEN
PRESIDENT. IN OVERSEEING THE
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS I DO I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS NO ONE
FACED A HOMELESS MAN SOON AS A
RESULT WE CANNOT HAVE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH INSTEAD
REQUIRE AN INTER WOVEN
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES SUPPORTS
AND HOUSING TYPES. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE DIVERSE INDIVIDUAL
GOALS THAT WE SERVE. ALTHOUGH
THE NEEDS OUT PACE THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE SEEN MANY
SUCCESSES IN MY SMALL COUNTY
AND WE ATTRIBUTE THOSE TORE
HIGHLY INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
CARE. THIS WOULD NOT BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE STATE'S
CREATION OF TARGETED HOUSING
SERVICES WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE INCLUDING CAL WORK.
CHILD WELFARE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES GENERAL ASSISTANCE
WHOLE PERSON CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS. WE
APPRECIATED THE STATE'S
LEADERSHIP TO KNOWLEDGE THE M.
SEVEN VETTING HELPS AND
SUPPORTS WITHIN CRITICAL
PROGRAMS ARE. SEVERAL PAIRS.
YOUR POST COUNTY AS A GROWING
ELDERLY POPULATION. WITH 36% OF
OUR RESIDENTS BEING OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY. LOCALLY AND
STATEWIDE WE ARE NOW DEALING
WITH SIGNIFICANT AND GROWING
HOUSING AND SECURITY AMONG OUR
OLDER RESIDENTS RESEARCH BY DR
TO SHELL OF UCSF FINDS THAT
ADULTS OVER FIFTY ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING SECTOR OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. THE VAST
MAJORITY ARE ALL I'M NEWLY
HOMELESS DUE TO ECONOMIC
REASONS THAT HAVE COME AN
INFECTION OR BOARD. FORCED OUT
OF HAVE SEEN. HOME WITHOUT.
CARRIES A BETTER RISK MUCH
GREATER RAY TO THIS POPULATION
EITHER FALLING ILL OR DYING
PREMATURELY AND HAS SIGNIFICANT
RAMIFICATIONS ON OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS. THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED SEARCH ON THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS WHICH
THE WTA WHOLE HEARTEDLY
SUPPORTS WELL THE STUDY WILL
GIVE US GREATER INSIGHT TO
GUIDE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION EFFORTS THERE ARE
THINGS YOU COULD DO RIGHT NOW
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THIS
ISSUE. FOR YOU CAN LEVERAGE
EXIST GRAMS LIKE THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM IN APS TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND SERVICES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR SENIORS
AND ARE DISABLED ADULTS.
BUILDING UPON WHAT WE ALREADY
DO WELL WILL ALLOW US TO ATTACK
THIS ISSUE HEAD ON WHILE
WAITING FOR THE RESEARCH.
SECOND WE MUST SUPPORT THOSE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND AND
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACROSS OUR STATE. WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO BE BUILT
AND MANY OF THE ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WILL
ADDRESS THIS WE KNOW THAT THESE
ARE COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING
EFFORTS ULTIMATELY NESSA'S
REALLY STRIKE AT THE HEART OF
THE KING PROBLEM. AT THE SAME
TIME THE PEOPLE WE ARE
STRUGGLING TO FOR THE PLACES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
IF YOU ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED HOUSING
SUBSIDIES WITH LONG WAITING
LISTS THAT RARELY OPEN. LONG
TERM RENTAL SUBSIDIES MUST BE
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS CRISIS WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO DEVELOP A SYSTEM OF
LONG TERM STATE FUNDED
SUBSIDIES. SURE THE FACT A HOT
SYSTEM. THIRD ALTHOUGH THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS MAKE UP ONLY A
QUARTER OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION STATE WIDE WE MUST
ADDRESS THIS POPULATION'S
COMPLEX NEEDS. FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL BOARDING CARE
PROGRAMS DIVERSION PROGRAMS NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INVESTMENTS
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT AND IN
LIEU OF SERVICES WHEN
ADMINISTERED CORRECTLY WILL GO
A LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING THE
POPULATION'S NEEDS. FOURTH IS
THE ISSUE OF BY AND- WE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH
IT WILL TAKE TO GET AHEAD OF
THIS HOUSING CRISIS. CRITICAL
THAT FUNDING BE ONGOING. WHICH
GRATEFUL TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR
KNOWLEDGE IN HIS STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS. ONE TIME ARE
UNCERTAIN FUNDING MAKES IT
RISKY AND DIFFICULT TO MAKE
MUCH NEEDED LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS AND THIS IS CUTE
INVESTMENTS TOWARDS ACTIVITIES
THAT HAVE LITTLE. OR NO. COST
INSTEAD OF MOST EFFECTIVE AND
CRITICS. ARE YOUR FRIENDS.
THOMAS OF ONGOING FUNDING
THROUGH MY YEAR. UNABLE CITY
AND HOW. DEVELOPERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO PLAN IN A WAY THAT
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO. IN
CLOSING I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME
PERSPECTIVES FROM A SMALL RURAL
COUNTY. SMALL RURAL COUNTIES
HAVE PER CAPITA HOMELESS
POPULATIONS THAT OFTEN EQUAL OR
EXCEED LARGER COUNTIES BUT
OFTEN ONLY A FRACTION OF THE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE
NEEDS. ARE HOMELESS POPULATION
SOURCES OF BREAD OUT OVER
LARGER GEOGRAPHIC AREA AS WHICH
WAS UNIQUE CHALLENGES. ALTHOUGH
THE POINT IN TIME COUNT HAS
BEEN ONE WAY TO CALCULATE THE
FUNDING RECEIVED WE CANNOT RELY
ON THIS MEASURE- OWN MEN KEEP
ARE TO. SMALL WORLD UNITIES
BECAUSE I WANT TO AVOID BEING.
AN ARE COUNTIES OFTEN SEE LESS
VISIBLE HOMELESSNESS. SOME
COUNTY ALONE DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY CAPTURE THE SCOPE OF
THE PROBLEM AND RESULT IN VERY
SMALL ALLOCATIONS TO COUNTIES
LIKE MINE AMOUNTS OFF TOO SMALL
TO IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS. THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES RE REGIONALIZATION AND
HIS PLAN. ALTHOUGH WAS TO. SEE
WHICH GRAY WHAT STRUCTURE
REGION'S ENSURE THAT THE UNIQUE
NEEDS O EACH COUNT ARE MAPPED
NO MATTER HOW SMALL OR REMOTE
WE MAY BE. IN MANY SMALL
COUNTIES THERE IS NO STRONG
NONPROFIT LEADING THE CHARGE
AND SO WE IS COUNTIES HAVE HAD
TO DEVELOP THE CAPACITY TO TAKE
THIS LEAD. I HAVE APPRECIATED
SECKER GALLEY AND CDSS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON'S WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
INPUT ON HOW BEST TO STRUCTURE
THESE REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
I FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MARIPOSA
COUNTY CW DA AND SMALL RURAL
COUNTIES TODAY AND I'M EXCITED
TO SUPPORT THIS. PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
FILE FINALLY WE'LL HEAR FROM
MISTER PICCO WHO'S THE CEO OF
BILLION CORNER. THANK YOU BOB
SO MY NAME IS WHEN TACKLE I'M
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
PLAN CORNERS WERE UP FIVE OH
ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT WE-
WORK STATEWIDE- PRIMARILY IN
OUR CAPACITY DEVELOPING OWNING
AND MANAGING. OVER TWO HUNDRED.
POLICE SUPPLIES RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES- FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND OFTEN COMPLEX
BEHAVIORAL MEDICAL CHALLENGES
WHO TRANSITIONED OUT OF THE
STATE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AS
THOSE LARGER INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS WERE CLOSING. OUR
PRIMARY HUBS HOWEVER ARE IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE INLAND EMPIRE-
AND IN LOS ANGELES WHERE WE
OPERATE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY AND SIMILAR PROGRAMS. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR MITCHELL
AND ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS WELL AS STAFF AND MYSELF WAS
FOR THE TWO TO SHARE. ABOUT THE
FLEXIBLE HOW. RATHER NAME FOR
AN INTO SCALABLE SET OF
EVIDENCE BASED AND FRANKLY
COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS- TO
HOMELESSNESS AND THE HOUSING
CRISIS FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT WE DO BELIEVE
CAN BE REPLICATED IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SO WHAT IS A FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL. SELECT THE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING MODEL THAT'S
ENDED HOMELESSNESS FOR NEARLY
SEVENTY SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND JUST
OVER FIVE YEARS. IT WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP LED BY LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SAYS ENDS.
IT'S HELPING FOR HEALTH
DIVISION AND OPERATED BY
BRINGING CORNERS- THE FLEX
FINDS INVESTMENTS. DOUBLE
SYSTEM PUBLIC OF MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH MANAGED CARE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PLANTER. TO
PROVIDE AND MORE WHICH MEANT
RENT SUBSIDIES A WHEN SUB
MISSED. ONGOING TENDENCY
SUPPORTS AN ONGOING INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR
LOS ANGELES'S MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS WHILE ALSO SPURRING
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW PRIME IN
SUPPORT OF THING AN INTERIM
HOUSING. OUR GOAL IS NOT JUST
ANOTHER PROGRAM ADDED TO THE
WELTER OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
MANY MANY OF WHICH ARE
WONDERFUL BUT DIFFICULT TO
SCALE AND DIFFICULT. DIFFICULT
IN THE GATE FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
FLEXIBLE RATHER BE EIGHT SYSTEM
LEVEL CHANGE ENHANCING THE
ABILITY OF SEALS AND COORDINATE
ENTRY SYSTEMS- WILL GO UP AND
FILL. HEALTHCARE NONPROFIT
AGENCY TO EFFECTIVELY. THIS
OPERATIONALIZE HOUSING FIRST
VALUES IN LOS ANGELES BRING
CORNERS TO GIVE A SENSE OF THE
LEVEL OF OPERATE AND IN LOS
ANGELES CORNERS MA'AM IS ACTIVE
PARTNERSHIP. WITH GREAT PRIVATE
LAND AND THAT NUMBER EVER MONTH
AND- EIGHTY INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICE PROVIDER
AGENCIES AS WELL AS WITH THE
ENTIRE AFFORDABLE AND TRANSPORT
OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY. AND BOARD CARE
ARE MULTIPLE VACANT UNITS
AVAILABLE AT ANY GIVEN TIME FOR
EVERY SINGLE PERSON
EXPERIENCING HOME THIS. SO THE
IS HOW DOES THE FLEX PULL WORK
TO TAP INTO THOSE EXISTING-
HOUSING RESOURCES FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. I'LL START
BY DESCRIBING A STAFFING MODEL
WHICH PROVIDES THREE ESSENTIAL
HOUSING REPEATED SERVICES THAT
TOGETHER FREE SOCIAL WORKERS IN
CASE MANAGERS OF THE BURDEN AND
THE REALLY SOMETIMES IMPOSSIBLE
TALENT OF FINDING SECURING. AND
PAYING FOR HOUSING FOR THEIR
CLIENTELE. FIRST IS A HOUSING
ACQUISITIONS TEAM WHICH
SPECIALIZES IN LAW AND ORDER
IT'S MEANT AND BRINGS A
PROFESSIONAL CUSTOMER SERVICE
MIND THAT TO CREATE DURABLE
LANDLORD PARTNERSHIP AND REAP
BIZ. BY PICKING WAIT UNITS AND
SECURING THEM VIA A SUITE OF
CUSTOMIZED LEGAL INSTRUMENTS WE
CREATE A DIVERSE INVENTORY OR
PORTFOLIO FOR POOL OF UNITS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN REAL
TIME. OUR PROGRAM- PARTICIPANTS
ARE NOT NAVIGATING TO TRY TO
FIND A UNIT OUT THERE SOMEWHERE
WE HAVE THE UNITS AVAILABLE. A
SECOND TEAM WE CAN SEE SUPPORTS
TEAM AND THE POSITION IS CALLED
HOUSING COOPER NADER- BY THE ON
GOING TENDENCY SUPPORTS FOR
EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANT WITHIN THE
FLEXIBLE. FROM INITIAL HOUSING
INTAKE AND ASSESSMENT AND
APPLICATION THROUGH UNIT
PREVIEWS AND MOVE IN AND
THROUGHOUT THEIR TENANCY.
HOUSING COORDINATORS ARE THE
CRITICAL LIAISON. BETWEEN THE
TENANT THE LANDLORD THE CASE
MANAGER AND EVEN FUNDERS AND
PROACTIVELY RESOLVE HOUSING
ISSUES TO PROMOTE LONG TERM
HOUSING STABILITY. A THIRD TEAM
INSIDE A BRILLIANT CORNERS IN
THE FLEXIBLE MODEL WE SIMPLY
CALL OUR OPERATIONS TEAM. AND
THEY PROVIDE COMPLEX RENT
SUBSIDY ADMINISTRATION PROCESS
HIGH VOLUMES OF TRANSACTIONS
EVERY MONTH INCLUDING URGENT
ONE TIME PAYMENTS AT TO
SECURITY DEPOSITS OR LANDLORD
INCENTIVES- PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AN ARRAY OF LEGAL
DOCUMENTS. AND PROVIDE- COMPLEX
MULTI FUNDER REPORT. AND THE
FINAL- STOP PIECE OF THE
STAFFING PUZZLE FOR THE
FLEXIBLE MODEL IS INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES WITH
THESE THREE IN HOUSE- HOUSING
SERVICES IN PLACE APRIL IN
CORNERS EACH AND EVERY FLEXIBLE
PROGRAM IS A PEN SO RECEIVED
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. SEPARATE CAUGHT BY LA
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND AS I MENTIONED
PROVIDED BY. ONE OF OVER EIGHTY
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICE
AGENCIES IN SOME LIMITED CASES
BRING CORNERS ALSO PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. THE OTHER
CRITICAL- WAY THAT WE IMPLEMENT
THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL IS THROUGH A STANDARDIZED
PACKAGE OF FINANCIAL TOOLS AND
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THOSE
TODAY THOSE INCLUDE RENT
SUBSIDY TO VARYING TYPES MOST
CRITICALLY LOCAL. SYMBOL IN
SENATE TERM RENT SUBSIDIES THAT
ARE THERE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AS
LONG AS THEY NEED THEM. EVEN AT
HOLD PAYMENTS THIS IS CRITICAL
INNOVATION THE ABILITY TO HOLD
THE VACANT UNIT FOR A MONTH OR
TWO. UNTIL WE CAN MATT SOMEONE
WHO IS IN A CRISIS NO LIFE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
EXITING THE SYSTEM MORE
SHELTER. MOVING PAYMENTS FOR
SECURITY DEPOSITS FIRST MONTH'S
RENT AT CETERA MOVING
ASSISTANCE FOR HOUSEHOLD GOODS
IN UTILITY SET UP. PROPERTY
PROVIDER IN STEPS SUCH AS
INSPECTION REPAIR FUNDS- OR
LEASE SIGNING BONUSES AND
LASTLY BUT IT'LL FLEXIBLE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR THINGS
LIKE PASSED TO RENT BOUNCES
UNIT REPAIRED DURING TENANCY.
ESSENTIALLY A FINE TO RESOURCE
THAT WE HAVE AS A LINE ITEM TO
ADDRESS EVERY POSSIBLE BARRIER
TO. OR WRIST PURSE LONG TERM
THINGS THAT TWENTY. I ALSO WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WE OFTEN SAY IS THE SECRET
SAUCE OF THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POOL WHEN COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY ASK US WHAT
MAKES IT WORK SO WELL. AND THAT
SECRET SAUCE- IT WELL IT'S
GOING TO SOUND A LITTLE BORING
WE TALK ABOUT IT AS A CRITICAL
SET OF GOVERNMENT NONPROFIT
PROCUREMENT INNOVATIONS THAT
ENABLE US TO FOCUS ON AND
SUSTAIN AND HOUSING COMES. MY
TALKING ABOUT ON GOING FUNDING
FOR A LOT ABOUT THAT TODAY FOR
INDEFINITE TERM RENT SUBSIDIES
INDEFINITE TERM SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES LIKE CASE MANAGEMENT
BACK TO A FIFTEEN YEAR CONTRACT
THAT'S POURTANT BLINK ONE BE
ABLE TO BUILD A COUPLE. HOUSING
OUT LONG TERM ALSO WHEN WERE-
NEGOTIATING WITH THE DEVELOPER
FOR A SUPPORT OF HOUSING SIDE
OR IN IN FROM HOUSING SITE
THEY'RE ABLE TO RELY ON THAT
FIFTEEN YEAR COMMITMENT THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING AWAY. WE HAVE A
UNIQUE IT AND STRUCTURE THAT
ALLOWS BRING CORNERS TO RAPIDLY
PROCESS WITHOUT MISSING A BEAT
OVER SX MILLION DOLLARS
MONTHLY AND RENT SUBSIDY
PAYMENTS. AND THAT'S IN LA
COUNTY ALONE WE HAVE SIMILAR
THINGS HAPPENING IN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE- FULL COST
FUNDING. FOR EVERY FORM OF
CLIENT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AS
I'VE ALREADY INDICATED. BUT
ALSO FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION. FOR RENT SUBSIDY
ADMINISTRATION AND FOR COMPLEX
DATA MANAGEMENT AND REPORTING.
AND REALLY LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
A SHARED MINDSET ACROSS
GOVERNMENT NONPROFIT
PHILANTHROPY HOUSING. THAT
EVERYONE LA SIMPLY CALLS
WHATEVER IT TAKES. THAT'S THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE NIPPLE MESS
THAT'S OFTEN LACKING IN
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS DESPITE OUR
BEST INTENTIONS. AND IT CAN
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TURNING DOWN A UNIT BECAUSE
IT'S ONE DOLLAR A MONTH MORE
THAN FAIR MARKET RENTS OR
TAKING THAT UNIT DOWN HOLDING
IT AND MATCHING IT FOR SOMEBODY
WHO'S CURRENTLY LIVING ON THE
STREETS- SO IN CONCLUSION. DOES
THE FLEX PULL WORK. WHILE THE
NUMBERS AND EVALUATIONS BY APT
ASSOCIATES AND RAND CORPORATION
I THINK TELECOM TELLING STORIES
WHEN THE- LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT
HEALTH SERVICES ANNOUNCED THEIR
INTENTION- TO START A FLEXIBLE
HOUSING SUBSIDY PULL BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN- THE GOAL
IN THE GOAL IN OUR CONTRACT WAS
TO SECURE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
UNITS IN THE FIRST FOUR YEARS.
AS YOU'VE HEARD IN JUST OVER
FIVE YEARS WE FREE HOUSE TO
SEVENTY SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE. AT
OUR PEAK EFFICIENCY WITH OUR
CASE MANAGEMENT ANOTHER
PARTNERS WERE ABLE TO USE-
HOUSE OVER TWO HUNDRED-
FORMALLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
PER MONTH. OUR HOUSING
RETENTION RATES RANGE BETWEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND 96% FOR THOSE
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS WHO HAVE
INDEFINITE TERM SUBSIDIES ARE
LIVING IN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SO GREAT RETENTION
RATES AND THESE ARE LONG TERM
RETENTION RATES FAR BEYOND- THE
STANDARD HUD SIX AND TWELVE.
PERIOD WE'RE TALKING MULTI YEAR
LONG TERM HOUSING STABILITY-
WE'VE DEMONSTRATED PROOF OF
CONCEPT BY SECURING INVESTMENTS
AND HOUSING OUTCOMES ACROSS
FORMERLY SIDE LOAD SYSTEMS
AGAIN WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED.
PRIVATE LANDLORD HOUSING
PARTNERS- AND MULTIPLE
GOVERNING AGENCIES TESTING AS
WELL AS LA CARE. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST IS DOCUMENTED I
BELIEVE IN THE RAND STUDY. FOR
MANY OF THE- MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ABLE TO
RE HOUSE AND SUPPORT THROUGH
THE FLEXIBLE FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR SPENT ON TENDENCY
SUPPORTS AND RENT SUBSIDIES AND
CASE MANAGEMENT. THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL ONE DOLLAR AND
TWENTY CENTS SAVED IN THE
HEALTH CARE AND OTHER SYSTEMS-
SO WITH THAT- I'LL JUST THANK
YOUALL FOR THE UP TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE FLAG POLE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE DOT BUG ABOUT
IT DURING THE QUESTION. I DO
HAVE MEANT THAT I CAN WE BE
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU CAN OFFICIALS THUMB THE
SERGEANTS I'M GONNA ASK YOU ALL
THIS DAY. AND I THINK WHAT THE
FOR HOMEINVOLVED- THE FOR TO
PASS. IF I COUNTED MY CHAIR
CORRECT. I SEE MR ACCOUNTS HE.
YEAH DESPITE STORM I'M SURE I
HAVE TO LEAVE. HOWEVER I WANTED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT WERE OPENING
UP THE MAYBERRY BRIDGE SHOW-
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING CENTER AND
ABOUT TWO HOURS AND SAN JOSE
SO. I WANT TO BE THERE FOR THAT
EXCELLENT- LANGUAGE GONNA BE
REAL EXCITED TO SCHOOL SOCIAL
HOUSING RIGHT NEXT TO THE NEW
BART STATION INCENTIVES ARE
EXCELLENT THANK YOU CENTER BAIL
YOU DRIVE YOU DRIVE SAFELY FOR
SHAKE THAT. OUT THANK YOU FIRST
OF ALL WANT TO THANK THE STAFF-
FOR I THINK WITH THAT BUT IF
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER PERFECTLY
THAT LAST PANEL BECAUSE I THINK
IT WAS WONDERFULLY DISBURSING
REPRESENTATIVE OF MULTIPLE
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE FOR ACTIVE
OF THE STATE AS A WHOLE ON AND
I WANTED TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT-
EITHER THIS **** MISS SUTTON IF
YOU WANT TO RESPOND AT ALL TO.
DO THE THINGS YOU HEARD FOR THE
SERVICE PROVIDER THE LAW
GOVERNMENT. FOR WE ALL. TO
INCREASE TO THIRTY EIGHT NOT A
PROBLEM. YOU JUST. I THAT I
LOOK FORWARD TO KIND OF WORK ON
AYE DE THE ON SORE AND I KNOW
THE COOK QUESTION OF WHAT'S
RESULT THAT THE LOOK FOR TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON THOSE THOSE
DEFINITIONS AND AGAIN. REALLY
IT INCLUDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDES NONPROFITS ARE
CONSORTIUM OF THOSE IS THAT THE
BROAD DEFINITION OF WHAT A
REGIONAL MINISTRY MIGHT BE.
AXLE I THINK WE HEARD
CONSISTENT MESSAGE THAT THAT WE
ALL HERE ON THE PANEL I'M SURE.
WITH IN TERMS OF THE NEED FOR I
DIDN'T. HAVE A PERMANENT
FUNDING SOURCE AND YOU KNOW
MISTER PICKLE I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH.
SENATE I THINK MAYBE SIX YEARS
GO AND TAKE A TRIP TO UTAH. TO
LOOK AT. THE MODEL THAT THEY
BUILT ON THAT LED THEM TO
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCING THEIR
CHRONICLE MOST POPULAR BUT LIKE
90% OVER TEN YEARS. AND QUE UP
WITH THE LEFT. OF A COUPLE
WHICH LEADS TO LEGISLATION THAT
THE- ALMOST FORTY THE COUNCIL I
CARED A BILL THE HOUSING FIRST
BILL. BUT OTHER PEOPLE LOVE WAS
REALLY RECOGNIZING IT'S GOT TO
BE. RAFEAL THIS AIN'T. THE THIS
IS WAS NO LONGER ON THE FRONT
THIS PAGE PER. TOP PAUL
GOVERNMENT JOB TO CAN. TO KEEP
OUR FOOT IN THE EXCEL. TO
CONTINUE TO BE THOSE SUPPORTIVE
SERVE TO KEEP PEOPLE HAVE ONCE
WE GET OVER EXITE. OF OPENINGS
IN RIBBON CUTTINGS WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO KEEP PEOPLE
HOUSE OVER TIME THAT WAS
CERTAINLY MY TAKE AWAY. THE
QUICK OR MOVE ON TO MY LIST OF.
I HEARD TWO DATA POINTS TO
SPECIFIC DATA POINTS TODAY- THE
REFERENCE I BELIEVE IT WAS MISS
SUDDEN ETHNOLOGY THAT THE AFTER
AMERICA POPULATION CALIFORNIA
IS UNDER 8% AND YET STATEWIDE-
ARE OVER REPRESENTATION IN THE
ON HOUSE- POPULATION IS 30% IN
MY HOME COUNTY VALLEY IT'S MUCH
HIGHER THAN THAT THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING DATA POINT. THE
SECOND DATA POINT WAS THE YOU
KNOW WHO EMERGING ON HOUSE ARE
THE PEOPLE OVER FIFTY WHO HAVE
NEVER BEEN ON HOUSE BEFORE. AND
SO I WOULD LIKE AS WE WENT TO A
QUESTIONS TO REALLY TALK ABOUT
SINCE THE ALL THE TO DATA
POINTS WHAT ARE ARE CPAS
STRATEGIES TO DEALING WITH
THOSE POPULATIONS. SOME OF SAID
THE NEED TO CONTINUE TO COLLECT
DATA BUT THOUGH THE TWO DATA
POINTS WE NOW. AND THE NATURAL
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO ABOUT THAT THERE'S
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE START THEIR-
I'M GLAD TO KIM JOHNSON SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT AND CAN WANT TO
SAY THAT IN TERMS OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE FIND. HOW
WE'VE ADDRESS SAID
DISPROPORTIONAL THE IN THE APP
PROPOSAL IS AS WERE LOOKING AT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY FOR THE
REGION'S- IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE'VE INCLUDED A
COMPONENT RELATED TO RACIAL
EQUITY. AT RECOGNIZING THIS IS
YOU SO THAT THE CONCEPT THERE
WOULD BE ADDS WERE LOOKING AT
THAT FORMULA WE LOOK AT WAIT
SICK AND THAT POPULATIONS
WITHIN THESE REGIONS AND MAKE A
DIFFERENTIAL THERE TO ADDRESS
THAT THE ADDITIONAL NEEDS.%
RELATED TO THE OLDER POPULATION
AND- THAT FIND PROPOSES- THAT
REGION'S WOULD DEFINE WHO THEIR
POPULATION TARGETS WOULD BE. HI
BUT WITH IN IT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT STATE. PARK
PRIORITY POPULATIONS IN THE
OLDER ADULTS OUR ELDERS ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT. IN ADDITION
OF COURSE WITHIN THE THREE
PURPOSES OF THE FIND ONE IS
REALLY SUPPORTING BACK AS
STABILITY FOR. BOARDING
FACILITY YEAH THAT'S ALSO WRECK.
BAD AT HEART THE CONTINUUM OF
SAID YOU'RE OLDER POP SINCE.
THIS WAY REST. AT THE WE ARE
LOOKING TO OUR DA IN HER TO HOW
WE THAT PACKAGE WHEN THE THINGS
WE COULD DO IS IDENTIFY VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
TARGET THROUGH THAT INCENTIVE
PACKAGE REDUCING SOME OF THE
DISPARITIES WITHIN THOSE
POPULATIONS. SO IS SOMETHING WE
CAN THINK ABOUT AS WE ARE
BUILDING OUR INCENTIVE PACKAGE
FOR THE IN LIEU OF SERVICES IN
THE ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
PORTIONS OF KELLY. AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL BECAUSE I KNOW-
IT WILL BE VERY COMPETITIVE
WE'VE HEARD ALREADY YOU KNOW
DON'T FORGET THE SMALL RURAL
COUNTIES DON'T FORGET THIS
GROUP DOES. THAT GROUP BUT I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL BUILD IN
SENT THE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE. ONLY OPEN REPRESENTED AND
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE THE
CONSTANT REMINDER THAT I'M
HAPPY TO SELL BECAUSE BUT ONE.
THAT TO GET LOST IN THE OVERALL
COMPETITION FOR DOLLARS. OF
COURSE YOU KNOW LIMIT DOLLARS
TO MEET- AN OVERWHELMING NEED-
BUT BUT WE'VE GOT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE FACT THAT.
REPRESENTED IN THIS CASE IN
THIS IN THIS- MORAL. DILEMMA WE
ARE EXPERIENCING SO WE'VE GOT
TO BE HONEST AND ADDRESS THAT
THERE ARE THE FOLKS WHO WANTED
TO RESPOND IN A COMMITTEE THE
SUDDEN. YES THANK YOU- THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO- CW DAY
IS WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA ON A PROPOSAL TO
ENHANCE THE- ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM. TO
SPECIFICALLY SERVE SENIORS AND
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WE FOUND
SOME REAL SUCCESS IN ACROSS OUR
STATE IN TERMS OF HOUSING AND
PROVIDING SOME INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT TO THOSE AT RISK OF
LOSING. HOUSING SO WE WOULD
WANT SUPPORT UP AS WELL
EXCELLENT YES AND I THINK FOR
BOTH FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR
THE STATE IT'S WHO ARE WE
TARGET BEING IN RELATIONSHIP TO
THEIR UP. TWENTY WO JUST IN
COUNTLESS AND BOTH IN.
REPRESENTATION AND THE GROWING
ON THE SENIORS AND OR THE MOST
VULNERABLE AS YOU. THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT EXAMPLE WAS BENEFIT
OF THIS TYPE. MISTER JONES THE
QUESTION TO ASK IS WHAT THAT
WORK NBC. IF MISTER JONES IS A
SENIOR. YELP THE END OF. THE IN
ASSIST. ANYWAY HIM TO ASSIST IN
THIS IS THE OUR SOURCE OF RAP.
OTHERWISE HE WILL END UP ON THE
SO AS YOU AT SEVEN AND MILLION
DOLLARS AND YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
BILLION CORNERS THE DESIRE TO
HAVE A MORE CONSISTENCY IN THE
FUNDS ACROSS THE PANEL IT'S
REALLY WHO ARE YOUR TARGET
POPULATIONS AND HOW YOU SHOULD
BE TO SIGN IN PROGRAM FUNDING
MECHANISMS. ANY BUILDING
PORTABLE HOUSING THE- LIGHT ON
A FIFTEEN YEAR COMMITMENT UP OF
INCOME ALLOWS THEN THE PROSPECT
OF A STATION THE CAPITAL AND
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE IN CREATING
PERMANENT SUPPORT OF. AND IF
YOU HAVE FOR WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE AND CALM-
THAT ARE YOUNGER AND TARGET
POPULATIONS THAN SHORTER TERM
RENTAL ASSISTANCE SO AS YOU
DESIGN YOUR PROGRAM YOU REALLY
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT. WHO IT IS
YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP AND THE
BIRTH OF THE TWO. AND IN
KEEPING WITH THAT I WAS
APPROACHED BY A WOMAN AT A TOWN
HALL JUST LAST WEEK- TALKED
ABOUT HAVING TOURED ALL OF THE-
AFFORDABLE FOR SENIOR KNEW
HOUSE AND ABOUT. IN LOS ANGELES
AN ON CONVERSATION AROUND
SENIORS AT KNOWLEDGE THAT NONE
OF BATHROOM FACILITIES WERE
SENIOR SENSITIVE. NOT THEM WERE
BUILT WITH BARS WITH THE SHOWER
PURITY THANKS YOU HAVE TO BE
MINDFUL IF THAT'S ARE GROWING
POPULATION AND WE'RE BUILDING
FOR THEM THE WE NEED TO BUILD A
PROFIT FOR THE WITH THE PLACE
THAT THEY REALLY CAN. CONTINUE
TO AGING. YOU HAD A- IN A DAY
SO WHAT I'M- CAN. ABOUT THE WAY
WITH THAT THE FUNDING COME
FORWARD TO DO SOME OF THAT WERE.
AT RIGHT NOW. IN STATEWIDE DATA
IS THE ABILITY TO COLLECT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AND SO THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT AT A STATE
LEVEL AND BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND- HOW TO HELP
COMMUNITIES LOOK AT THEIR DATA
LOOK AT THEIR ASSESSMENT TOOLS
SEE IF THERE MIGHT BE SOME
RACIAL RACIAL- COMPONENTS TO
THE ASSESSMENT TOOL OF
SCREENING FOLKS IN OUR OUT
BASED ON RACE AND SO SOME
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DOING A
REALLY GOOD. JOB ON THAT
ALREADY WE'VE BEEN FOR SOME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THAT I
THINK WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
BUT THERE ARE SOME BEST
PRACTICES AND LOOKING AT. YOUR
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM AND HOW TO
BETTER ADDRESS POTENTIAL
DISPARITIES IN IT WHILE NOT
LOOKING THAT THEY'RE SORT OF
BEFORE HOW. THE CENTER HOUSE.
WHO'S COMING IN. IN THIS WE
DON'T WANT. TO WAIT THAT
PROPORTIONALITY I AND I DON'T
US TO FOR BACK ON. OUR
INABILITY TO COLLECT RELEVANT
DATA BECAUSE OF TWO OH NINE THE-
REAR. UP TREATED REALITY IN THE
STREETS I DON'T WANT. TO USE
THAT COVERS FOR NOT. ON ASKING
THE RIGHT REAL ON OF QUESTIONS
ONE MORE QUESTION BEFORE I MOVE
ON. TO DO WOULD BE CARE I HAD A
SURE OF JOINING THE GOVERNOR ON
MY WITH THE UNVEILING OF TEN OF
THE NEW TRAILERS IN SEEN TEN
FAMILIES- MOVE FROM THEIR CARS
AND MOTELS INTO HOUSING AND
THEN I GOT A CALL YESTERDAY
ABOUT THE CLOSURE OF A TWENTY
ONE BAD BOARD CARE FACILITY IN
MY SAME COMMUNITY AND SO THIS
WE GIVE WITH ONE HAND WE TAKE
WHAT THE OTHER IS- TRAGIC. AND
SO MY QUESTION WITH REGARD TO
BOARD AND CARE. HERE'S AT THE
FEBRUARY- SIT AT A FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON LICENSE HOMES FROM
THE VULNERABLE ADULTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TESTIFIED THAT IT DID NOT HAVE
EXTENSIVE AGGREGATE DATA ON HOW
ALL THE CLOTHES IN THE BOARDING
CARE FACILITIES CONTRIBUTES TO
HOMELESSNESS. AND SO I'M REALLY
CURIOUS BECAUSE IT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT ROLE YOU
BELIEVE THESE FACILITIES PLAY
IN- SUPPORTING OUR ON HOUSE
POPULATION AND HOW WILL THE
BOARD AND CAR STABILIZATION
COMPONENT OF YOUR PROPOSAL
CONTRIBUTE TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AT WHAT WERE A COUPLE
OF THINGS I WANTED I-
ILLUSTRATE ACTUALLY THE AGENDA
NOT HEARING. DID A GOOD JOB OF
SPEAKING TO THE CAPACITY
CHANGES OVER TIME OF BOTH ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
BOTH CHANGE AND NUMBER OF
FACILITIES FACILITY TYPE. AN
ACTUAL TOTAL CAPACITY AND SO
WHILE AT THE END OF THAT
ANALYSIS WE AREN'T NECESSARILY
SEEING A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION
IN CAPACITY OF THOSE FACILITY
TYPES CERTAINLY THE NEED HAS
GROWN. AND SO THE OLDER
POPULATION IN THE NEED FOR THAT
PARTICULAR CARE TYPE HAS GROWN
AND ALSO WITHIN SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT IS NOT. THE SAME
RESULT THE STATEWIDE AGGREGATE
THAT SHOOTS COMMUNITY
CERTAINLY- THAT THE NUMBERS ARE
DIFFERENT. THIS PROPOSAL
ABSOLUTELY KNOWLEDGES BOARDING
CARE AS PART OF THE CONTINUUM
TO IT FOR ITS SERVICE AND SO
HOW THE AND WOULD THAT WORK IS
THAT TO HELP US STABILIZE THESE
FACILITIES THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS WOULD BE
PROPOSING. I THINK PROJECTS
PROVIDING OPERATING SUBSIDIES
CITIES FACILITY TYPES IN
EXCHANGE FOR A HOLD
AFFORDABILITY AGREEMENTS. A
RENTAL CREDITS DEDICATED
RESIDENTIAL CAPACITY FOR THIS
POPULATION- THE OTHER PIECE ALL
SAY ABOUT IN THIS IS PRIMARILY
TARGETING OBVIOUSLY THOSE
FACILITIES SERVING THE SS I SS
P. POPULATION. AND AGAIN AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT'S THE
PIECE WHERE OUR DATA ISN'T AS
PRECISE AS WE'D LIKE IT TO BE
SO WE- ESSENTIALLY TAKE- THE
CAPACITY INFORMATION WE HAVE OF
THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITY
IN AND- RESIDENTIAL CARE FOR
SO. FACILITY ARE SEE IF HE'S AN
ARTIST I'M GONNA JUST GO
WITHOUT IT WE KNOW IT THE
ACRONYMS ARE- IN AND WE DO A
DATA MATCH WITH THAT AS A SIDE
DATA SO IT'S NOT IT'S IN
PERFECT. THAT IF ACTUAL. THIS
IS THE- ARE AT THE RESIDENTS
WITHIN THE HOUSEHOLD ARE ALSO
RECEIVING SSI IT MAY NOT
REFLECT. ESSENTIALLY OVER A
REPRESENTING OUR WHO WHICH OF
THESE WHICH- ARE BEING PROVIDE
CARE NEEDS FACILITY TYPES
THAT'S THE IMPRECISION WE HAVE
IN OUR DAY CERTAINLY.
DISCONTENT WE GET A PLACE WHERE
WE NEED STABILIZE IN AND
SUPPORT AND CERTAINLY THE NEED
FOR- FOR CARE IN THIS FACILITY
TYPE IS GROWING OVER TIME AS
BOTH OUR OUR POPULATION AGES
AND LIVES LONGER ALONG THE WAY
SO. I WE DID COMMIT ADD TO THE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION KIND OF
LOOKING AT THAT DEMOGRAPHIC
POPULATION GROWTH LOOKING A
SOME SPECIFIC COUNTY
DIFFERENCES IN THE CAPACITY AND
WILL CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT INFORMATION I APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE I. DO WANT TO HAVE
A SENSE OF WHAT YOU BELIEVE IS
THE GAP BETWEEN SUPPLY AND
DEMAND MAYBE IT'S JUST MY HOME
COUNTY- BECAUSE- WE ARE FEELING
THE CRUNCH OF THE- THE NUMBER
THAT I HAVE HEARD REPEATED- IS
AS A THOUSAND. LOST FACILITIES
NINE BED WITHOUT LOSS
FACILITIES OVER THE LAST YEAR
TO AND SO I LOOK TO GET THE
INFORMATION FOR YOUR TERMS. GAP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ALSO
WANT TO RESPOND BEFORE OPEN IT
UP TO MY COLLEAGUES MISSED
PICKLE. I WOULD ONLY JUST ADD
VERY BRIEFLY THAT IN LA COUNTY
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE OF THE
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY PULL
BILLION CORNERS AND LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
HAVE BEEN PILOTING- A STRATEGY
TO. KEEP BOARDING CARES FROM
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS AND
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL INCOME
STREAM AND ALSO- ENHANCE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES THAT IN
THAT CASE BRING CORNERS IS
PROVIDING SO SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT I THINK ARE
EMERGING IN THE STATE VISION
ARE I THINK WORKING AT A PILOT.
WHEN I COUNTY RIGHT NOW.
EXCELLENT BUT YES. THANK YOU I
JUST ALSO WANTED TO ADD YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION TO THE SENIOR
POPULATION THAT IS GROWING AND
THEREFORE REQUIRING MORE
BOARDING CARE FACILITIES. WERE
SEEN ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SIDE OF THINGS THAT BOARDING
CARES ARE REALLY GOOD SOLUTIONS
TO SOME OF OUR FOLKS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING. A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES SO IN ORDER FOR US
TO STEP FOLKS DOWN FOR INSTANCE
OUT OF PSYCHIATRIC BEDS WE
OFTEN NEED BORDEN CARES AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE STAY. MAYBE IN
JAIL OR STAY IN THE HOSPITAL
LONGER THAN IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE.
THOSE RESOURCES IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO I WANTED TO ADD
THAT AS WELL. EXCELLENT GOOD
OPEN UP I'VE GOT A LIST SENATOR
NIELSEN FOLLOWED BY PAN AND
SKINNER WHY CATTLE SKI. SENATOR
L. ARGUE. STE ON I HOPE
SOMEBODY WILL WILL ASK YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
GOOD THE HEAT AND HELP FUNDING
DID AS WE TRY. TO SHOULD NOW.
TO THIS ONE TIME SEVENTEEN
FIFTY MILLION THIS IS MY SENSE
THAT. THAT THIS BUDGET THAT
INCLUDES I'M GOING FUNDING. TO
HELP PEOPLE ASK. TO MOVING ON.
TO BE DIM. SENATOR NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MANAGER IN A- GOT A
JOB I'VE TO LEAVE SHORTLY A
TIME LITTLE WHO WERE COME. IS A
DOWNSTAIRS AND I'M GOING TO BE
THERE FOR THE VOTING PORTION I
DON'T HAVE TO BE FOR THE REST
OF. THE GOVERNOR BUSH I AND
EIGHT EIGHT BIT BILLS ON THE
PAST WHAT I'M NOT SURE IS IT
GOING TO DISCONTINUE SOME OF
WHAT'S ALREADY IN PROCESS. AND
HOW THAT IS GOING TO BE
DETERMINED BECAUSE HE'S TALKED
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT
WE HAD GOOD GOT TO MONITOR WHAT
WE'RE DOING. TO SEE WHETHER IT
IS WORKING OR NOT. THE IT MAY
I'M JUST MAKING UP THAT MADE
SOME COULD OBSERVE AS TO THIS
HOW WE DO THEN ACHIEVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WHERE IS
INVESTED- SOMETHING'S WE MIGHT
NOT. DO BEFORE WHAT YOU CAN'T
DO IT JUST. BUILD ON SOMETHING
THAT DIDN'T WORK BUT KEEP IT
FUNDED AND MOVE ON. AB TO GIVE
GIVE THAT SOME CONSIDERATION.
AND THE REGIONAL MODEL. LET ME
FOR THAT SPECIFIC WE ASK YOU TO
RESPOND NOW THE OTHER ONE JUST
MAYBE THINK ABOUT AND THEN GET
THING INTO MY OFFICE FROM YOUR
OPINIONS ABOUT THAT THE
REGIONAL MODEL HOW WILL THAT
FUNCTION WHO IS THE AUTHORITY
THAT WILL THE COORDINATE IF YOU
WILL THE REGIONAL MODEL I SEE
MERIT IN IT BUT THERE'S ALSO
INCREDIBLE PAROCHIALISM THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO DEAL WITH. HOW WILL
WE ACHIEVE THAT MAYBE THE-
OWNER THE- COULD COMMENT. SO
THE REGIONAL MODEL AND AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NON
PROFITS COULD APPLY TO BE THE
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR IN ANY
GIVEN REGION- THE SPECIFICS OF
THE REGION WE ARE STILL IN
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ALL ABOUT
IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFICS OF
THAT IS TO COME IN CONTINUED
CONVERSATION. YOUR POINT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN METRICS- IS
HEARD AN AD IN ADDITION- IN THE
TRAILER BILL AS IT EXISTS TODAY
WE ARE PROPOSING TO USE
PERFORMANCE BASED CONTRACTS-
THAT REALLY WILL GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO DO- LOOK AT THE
RESULTS THAT WERE CHEATING
IDENTIFY THOSE OUTCOMES AND
FRIENDS- AND BE ABLE TO FOR NOT
SEEING THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
EXPECT TO REDIRECT FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE OUT WORKING
WITH. FOLKS YOU CAN ALSO GET
BANDS THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF- IDENTIFYING AND REFINING
THAT DATA COLLECTION AND
EVALUATION PLAN IS THAT
PROPOSED TO BE AND BE INCLUDED
AS PART OF OUR REQUEST FOR
APPLICATION PROCESS SO THAT'S
BEEN OFFERED BUT NATION WITH
OUR OUR PART. IT'S TO ENCOUNTER
WHO IS YET TO DO MORE APPLY MET.
ALL OF THESE AND- IN TERMS OF
LOOKING OUT COMES. THE IT ALSO
WAS A OF ISSUE THIS TO THE ONE
FROM MARIPOSA QUE A VERY SMALL
COUNTY. AS WE ARE PORTION
DOLLARS IT'LL BE FLOWING- HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
THESE SMALLER COUNTIES. GET A
FAIR SHARE OR- A PLACE AT THE
TABLE. ED AND THAT'S ANOTHER
POINT APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
THAT WE SHOULD LOOK AT
TYPICALLY AS WE'RE LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF FUNDING
METHODOLOGIES ACROSS OUR
PROGRAMS WERE LOOKING AT NEED
AND CAPACITY IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER ISSUES AND SO. I KNOW
SHOULD ON CAN CAN ADD
APPRECIATE THIS- AS WELL THAT
WE SOMETIMES DO A BASS LINE. AT
ALLOCATION FOR SOME OF OUR A
SMALLER COUNTIES IN IN REGIONS
AND SO WE WOULD WANT IT CAN
ABSOLUTELY ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION WHAT THAT NEEDS TO
LOOK LIKE TO FULLY BE AVAILABLE
TO RESOURCE THE NEED AND GIVEN
COMMUNITY. AT THE WILL OF THE
THIS PUSH ONE MORE THAN OUT RUN
I MAY HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS
BACK. THE GOVERNOR ALSO HAS
MADE OBD. AT LEAST IN THE- PLAN
AS PRESENTED TO ME. THE THERE
WOULD BE- THAT AN AGGRESSIVE
OF. ALL I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S A
SANCTION. TO COUNTIES THAT
DON'T MEET THE EXPECTATIONS OF
THE STATE. NOW THAT CONCERNS ME
A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THE STATE
IS IN NO SMALL MEASURE PARTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM. THEN I DON'T WANT TO
GET INTO THAT BUT IT'S-
OBLIGATED BUT IT RELATES TO
REALIGN. AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY NEW IT'S XCELERATED
BUT THAT SAID- I WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT WE DON'T AYE AYE WHAT
IS AT COMMUNITIES THING LOOK
LIKE IS IT INDUSTRY DETERMINE
WHAT THAT WILL BE A FREE OF THE
STATE DOESN'T LIKE WHAT THE
LOCAL. GOING HOW THEY WILL BE A
SANCTION BY SAY. SO WITH
SPECIFIC TO THE FUNDS IT IS
THIS PERFORMANCE SPACE
CONTRACTING MECHANISM THAT I
JUST REFERENCE TO ADD THAT WILL
BE USED TO LOOK TO SEE- WHAT
WHERE AT REGIONS ARE HAVING
SUCCESS AND WHERE THEY NEED
SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT
THAT WILL PROVIDE. BROADER THAN
THAT I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION. ALL
RIGHT I THINK YOU'VE BEEN VERY
INFORMATIVE AND I WILL BE BACK
VERY SHORTLY THANK YOU MANAGER
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME. THANK YOU
I AM I THINK THIS OUR NEW MODEL
OF HAVING ALL THE PANELS PRISON
FIRST. IS HELPFUL BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO HEAR ALL THE
WITNESSES BEFORE PEOPLE HAVE TO
COME AND GO- SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- HALL. THE AGENCY IF WHO
HAVE FALL PRESENTED NO WILL BE
DELVING AND MORE DEEPLY IN OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS-
ALSO AND MAKE NOTE THAT- I WAS
PLEASED TO. BE AS A MEMBER OF
THE- HUMAN SERVICES TO HEAR
ABOUT THE BOARD CARE HOMES AND
THEN JUST YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
WE HAD A WHOLE HEARING ON.
CAL'S MANAGED CARE CONTRACTS
AND CAL A APPRECIATE THE- AGAIN
DTS IS A PARTICIPATION THAT- I
DEFINITELY WANT TO IT WOULD BE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS TO
HOUSE STAINED THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION SO I GOT YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR SAID IT AND- AT
THE AT THE- BUT DIDN'T SPECIFY
HOW HE'S GONNA ACCOMPLISH THAT
SO I AM VERY MUCH. WELL I'M I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND WE ALWAYS
LOOK TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
LEADERSHIP- I GUESS THE
QUESTION I DO HAVE- SO
REGARDING THE SEVEN OR FIFTY
MILLION THAT'S GOING TO
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES- V.
DOES I THINK MAKES SENSE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RATIONALE
IS JUST TIE IT TO OUR EXISTING
SAFETY NET PROGRAM TO A
LEVERAGE THAT SO WHEN WE ALSO
NEED TO AND THEN STAYING AWAY
BUT- IN TERMS OF THE- HE SPEAK
TO I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE THE
TRAILER LANGUAGE. COMING TO US
CAN YOU SPEAK TO HOW THE
GOVERNOR FIFTY MILLION IS. THAT
GONNA BE UNDER DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THE RELATIONSHIP
IS BETWEEN THAT AND THE
EXISTING SAFETY NET. STRUCTURE
AND SERVICES THAT WERE
PROVIDING AND THEN ALSO PERHAPS
ALSO WITH SOME OF THE OTHER-
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WE HAVE AS
WELL LIKE MEDI CAL SO. I DON'T
THINK IT WAS SPECIFIED IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. SO WHAT
WE WOULD BE ARE PROPOSING IS
PART OF THE REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS TO REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS AS THEY WOULD
IDENTIFY. HOW THE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE CONNECTING TO THE
BROADER SOCIAL SERVICE ARRAYED
INTEGRATION. SO HE ARE YOU
REQUIRING THAT IS PART OF THE
RESPONSE OKAY AND WHAT WHAT AND
I ROUTE YOU KNOW I THINK TO
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS GOING
TO REGINALD IN TERMS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH. YOU HAVE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS WHO DOES AND SO FORTH
WHAT'S THE- FI CONNECTION
THERE'D THAT YOU'RE EXPECTING-
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO ACCEPT
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY
CONNECTED TO THE OTHER SERVICES
CAN SAY CAN YOU SPEAK TO. YOU
CAN HAVE YOU DISTRIBUTE FINEST
TO BE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE AUTHORITY ARE
LUPTON. YES I ABSOLUTELY YES
WOULD BE BOTH ON GUIDANCE TO
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS AND
GUIDANCE TO COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS AROUND HOW THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES WOULD CONNECT
WE'D BE. PROVIDING THAT AS THE-
IMPLEMENTATION- OPERAS OPERATE
OPERATING OCCURS WITHIN THAT
THE PROGRAM. THAT WE ARE NOT
PROPOSING THAT THERE'S A NEW
ENTITY DOING ELIGIBILITY IN
ROME AND IT'S ABOUT THE
CONNECTION AND MAKING SURE-
THOSE THOSE. PROCESSES ARE IN
PLACE BEAR STAB LISTS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE OUT
REACH OCCURRING. THAT THERE'S
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT AND
THAT'S GOING TO LOOK A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ACROSS THE STATE
BASED ON AT NEW RESOURCE THE
BILL STATING AND- AND CAPACITY
BUT CERTAINLY THE DESCRIPTION
AB HOW THAT RELATIONSHIP AND
PROCESS WILL WORK IS AN
EXPECTATION TO BE RESPONDED TO
IN THAT. OUR FAITH OKAY AND
THEN THE OTHER HE SAID SO ASK
THAT IS THAT NO WAY OUT. TALK
ABOUT TRYING TO DRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN TERMS OF.
PREVENTION TO- SO- AND I THINK
THERE'S SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
REALLY A MESS I THINK THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING. WHERE PEOPLE
SAY WELL YEAH I THOUGHT POINT
TO THE FOR MEDI SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE HOMELESS CERTAINLY THEM
BUT- NOT. HEALTH ISSUES THAT
LED TO SOMEONE HOMELESS. BECAME
THAT LEAD TO OR EXACERBATE AN
EXIT. HEALTH YOURSELF COURSE
OUR PLAY CATCH UP ONCE ARE
HOMELESS SO. GITA ABOUT HOW OLD
THE FUNDS SENATOR FIFTY MILLION
IS SO TARGETED TOWARD ART THE
OTHER FUNDS AS WELL TO
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM. GETTING
UNDER THAT SOME OF ITS THREE.
TRAPS FOR UP ASSIST. WE CAN
PEOPLE. HOMELESS SO THANK UP. I
THINK THERE'S A MAIN PIECES AND
IN THAT THINK WILL HAVE AND
UPPER HELPING US BE MORE WE
ENTER GEN I'M SO FOR THE IN HIS
CAR MANAGEMENT IT DOESN'T
PEOPLE OUT RISK OF TO AB- EARLY
INTERVENTION AS WELL AS
HOMELESS ON THE OTHER PIECES
BUT- IS THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT ENTRY POINTS OF
SOMEONE IS BEEN NCARCERATED-
RECENTLY THAT THEY WOULD ALSO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THESE SERVICES
ALREADY THERE WORKING UP FRONT
YEAH AND I GOT THAT SO I GUESS
WHEN THE THINGS I'M CURIOUS
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING. LEVEL GET
SOCIAL SPACES THAT MANY OF YOU
TALK ABOUT CALLING HIM AND SAID
WHICH BY THE WAY WE HAD THE
HEARING YESTERDAY IT'S TARGETED
TOWARD A YOU KNOW IT WAS.
INTENSIVE TO SET PEOPLE TO TAKE
SOME EMPLOYMENT WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT YESTERDAY- WE HAVE THE
SEVEN CITY AND WE HAVE FUNDING
FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH PIECE AND
THEN WE HAVE THE SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION ON THE SOCIAL SERVICES
SIDE SO IS THERE ANY OF THE
SITE I MAKE FUNDING IS SO BE IT
HOW THE TWO CAN AND ALSO. AS A
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ALSO HELPING FOR PREVENTION OR
IS IT ONLY ON THE MEDI CAL SIDE
TO SIDE THAT. WE'RE LOOKING AT.
THE THESE. IN ON THE AT I THINK
THAT THE THING IS SINCE WE CAN
PAY FOR THE RABBI SIR WE CAN
PAY FOR ALL THE NAPA THE EIGHT
ON SIR CAN'T PAY FOR THE AND SO
RIGHT THE WILL BE WORKING
CLOSELY TOGETHER CARE PLANS TO
ME NEED REGIONAL I'M A GET TO
BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE ENTITIES AS WELL AS ANY OF
THEIR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY HAVE-
CONTRACTED WITH FOR THE VARIOUS
HOUSING BUNDLES THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT WE'LL HAVE TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY TO IDENTIFY EARLY
INTERVENTION PREVENTION AS WELL
AS THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
HOMELESS. SO WE WERE KIND OF
THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND
THEN WE CAN'T PAY FOR THE LONG
TERM RENTAL ON SUBSIDIES AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD BE
WORKING CLOSELY HOUSING FUND
FOR THOSE CAN THOSE COMPONENTS
OKAY MAYBE JUST TO ADD TO THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY WAS
THAT IT UP TO EXPECTATIONS
HEALTH. THOSE CONNECTIONS. TO
MAKE IN THE JUSTICE SERVICES
MAKING THE CAN. THE BRILLIANT.
TO THE END. PROVIDE THE SERVE
AND THE COUNTY SO THAT. THAT
EXPECTATION OF THAT CONNECTION
ACROSS BECAUSE JC SAID THERE'S
THE ASSESSMENT. BUILDING TO DO
THE NAVIGATION BUT THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO YOU KNOW WHERE
THE DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THE ONGOING BUT I THINK ONE OF
THINGS AND ONE DELVIN I'M NOT
GONNA TAKE UP MORE TIME HERE-
AND SUBCOMMITTEE. IS THAT I
APPRECIATE SO I'M HEARING A LOT
ABOUT THE MANAGED CARE PLANS WE
AND WE HAD THAT DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY BUT I'M ALSO THIS IS
SOME EXAMPLE WHAT ABOUT THE
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AT THE
COUNTY WHO ALSO HAVE THE ACCESS
THE OTHER SERVICES. IS IT GOING
TO BE THROUGH THE MANAGED CARE
PLAN OUR CONTRACTS ARE OF HOW
WHERE DO THE WHAT WOULD YOU THE
COUNTY EDS WHO WHO ALSO HAVE
THE- FENCE THE UP. SERVICES AS
WELL SO THIS WHOLE CONNECTION
BETWEEN EXISTING SAY NET. AND
CAN ONLY EXCESS SERVICES AND
THESE OF MONEY I THEY NEED TO
BE CLARIFIED AND WHAT THE
DIFFERENT ROLES AND WHO CAN
ACCESS BECAUSE I'M AFRAID WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE. EITHER
FALLING IN THE GAPS OF THERE'S
NOT CLEARLY IN THAT- YOU YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING
WITH FOLKS WHO ARE RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS WHO ARE. CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SOCIAL SERVICES MAY
BE MORE FAMILIAR TO SOCIAL
WORKERS OR WORKING AT THE
COUNTY THAN THEY ARE TO THE-
SO. THAT OUGHT TO THINK NEEDS
TO GET SORT OUT AND THEN ALSO
TIMING WISE BECAUSE AGAIN WE
TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT THE TIME
IT TAKES TO ROLL OUT THE CAL
AIM AND DO YOU KNOW FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY AND I
KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO AS FAST
AS HE CAN TO. FOR EXACTLY OF
WHAT THE WAIVERS AND SO FORTH
AT WHAT POINT DO WE GET TO
THOSE. YOU KNOW WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY GET SOME THE SERVICES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WE'RE
FOR CONFRONTING AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW THIS HOMELESSNESS ISSUE
RIGHT NOW WITH NOT ONLY PEOPLE
ARE CURRENTLY HOMELESS BUT
PEOPLE ENTERING HOMELESSNESS
SO. SO EVEN AS WE'RE TRYING TO
THAT REVAMPS MEDI CAL AND DO
CAL AIM AND DO THAT THE IT HAS
SERVICES. WILL STILL A LITTLE
BIT IN THE FUTURE AT THAT'S
GONNA TAKE FOR THAT HAPPENED
AND THEN ALSO HAPPY AND THIS
CONNECTION WITH THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL- I THINK NEEDS
TO BE CLARIFIED. SO I WOULD
JUST ADD THOUGH THAT THE HOT
FUNDING THAT APPLICATIONS
REGISTERED AND WE CAN HAVE A
ONE OF THE ELIGIBLE USES FOR
THAT IS PREVENTION SHELTER
DIVERSION SO WE'LL SEE HOW MANY
COMMUNITIES CHOOSE TO TAKE AND
USE THE FUNDING THAT WAY. BUT
IN THE INTERIM WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THERE'S THE PREVENTION
FUNDING THAT CAN BE COMING
THROUGH THAT. THAT SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY FROM LAST YEAR AS WELL.
OKAY APPRECIATE I THINK WE HAVE
A LOT OF WE HAVE A LOT OF THE
SKY WE HAVE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION. COMING UP THANK
YOU. THAT WE DO THANK YOU SIR
TO SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM.
CHAIR AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ORGANIZING THIS HEARINGS.
PORTANTINO SORRY LISTEN TO ALL
OF THE- PANELISTS SO JUST
THOUGHT OF THE TSUNAMI OF
ACTIONS THAT HAVE LED US TO
THIS PLACE YEAH I MEAN WE
CLEARLY THE FACT WE'VE NOT
BUILT ENOUGH HOUSING OVER SO
MANY DECADES LED TO THE
SCARCITY WHICH ROSE THE COSTS
BUT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE. THE
FACT THAT WE ARE MASS
INCARCERATION SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT THIS NUMBERS OF
DISPROPORTIONATE IN FIVE IMPACT
ON OUR BLACK POPULATION OR
BLACK CALIFORNIANS. THEY HAVE
RECORDS AND THOSE RECORDS THEN
PREVENTED THEM FOR HAVING THE
TYPE OF EMPLOYMENT THAT WOULD
GIVE THEM THE TYPE OF- INCOME
TO REALLY AFFORD THE HOUSING
COSTS WE HAVE. ALSO THE KICK IT
ACCESS TO A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER DEPENDING IF WHAT KIND
OF RECORD THEY HALF. AN A SO
ALL THOSE FACTORS- MEANWHILE
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE INCREASE IN
SENIORS SO WE GO BACK TO THE
RECESSION. THE RECESSION
IMPACTED EVERYTHING MEAN THE
RECESSIONS WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED SEEN THE- RIGHT AFTER
THE RECESSION WHICH WOULD
COUPLE OF THINGS BUT THE BORDEN
CARE HOMES IN S. AROSE JUST
BEING WIPED OUT. SO THAT TYPE
OF HOUSING THAT WAS AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE AND THEN WE HAD LOTS
OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONATELY ARE BLACK
RESIDENTS LOST HOMES WHICH WAS
THEIR NEST EGG. AND HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO RECOVER FROM THAT
MANY OF THEM OLDER FOR LOS
RETIREMENT FUNDS SO. YOU YOU
THAT'S WHAT WE SEE SOME MORE OF
OUR AGING POPULATION. IN BUT
HOW WHAT THEY MIGHT HAVE HAD A-
TO BE ABLE TO THEM THROUGH THIS.
THIS TYPE OF- PRESSURES RIGHT
AND I WOULD ADD TO THAT SENATOR
SKINNER THE WORK- UNFORTUNATE
THIS LEGISLATURE DID IN TERMS
OF REDUCING OUR CAL WORKS
GRANTS YES SO THEY WERE IN THE
NUMBER OF PUBLIC POLICY
DECISIONS THAT GOT US TO WHERE
WE ARE TODAY YEAH AND SO IT
IT'S LIKE THIS TO TSUNAMI OF
IMPACTS AND THEN MEANWHILE WE
HAVE THIS ECONOMIC BOOM. AND
THE- BOOM. HAS CREATED A GIVE
THE SCARCITY UP. COSTS OF
HOUSING BUT A CERTAIN PERCENT
OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO AFFORD
IT. SO IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD IT
THEN WHOEVER OWNS THAT YOU KNOW
EITHER IF YOUR LANDLORD OR THE
GUY SELLING YOU'RE GOING TO
SELL TO THAT. THAT PERSON WHO
CAN AFFORD IT WHICH THERE IS A
PERCENT OF PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN. BUT THEN OUR WAGE
GROWTH IT'S NOT BEEN ANYWHERE
NEAR COMMENSURATE FOR MOST
PEOPLE SO THEY THEN CAN'T. AND
NOW. WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
SYMPTOMS OF THE CRISIS NOW AND
WE'RE DEALING WITH HOW DO WE-
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THIS
IMMEDIATE. THIS VERY. JUST SOUL
WRENCHING HEART BREAKING. EVERY
TIME WE GO HOME EVERY TIME WERE
EVEN IN THE CAPITAL SEEN PEOPLE
IN THE RICHEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WITH THIS
LEVEL OF PEOPLE BEING ON OUR
STREETS IN A MYSTERY AND IT'S
JUST AWFUL. BUT IT. WOULD
CLEARLY WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THESE IMMEDIATE BUT I THINK WE
ALSO HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS OTHER
STUFF OR IT'S NEVER GOING TO GO
AWAY. WE GOT EVEN REMOVE THE
OBSTACLES TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THOSE RECORDS FROM BEING
ABLE TO GET INTO HOUSING- GOOD
GOOD JOBS. AND WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH JUST THERE'S A LOT AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH YES
SPAWNING HAS TO BE AREN'T
GOING. TO DO WITH THIS
IMMEDIATE BUT WE BETTER FIX
THESE OTHER STRUCTURAL THINGS
HOME YOU KNOW THE TROUBLE SO
NOW POLICIES FOR MY EDITORIAL
BUT JUST OBSESSED CONSUMED WITH
THIS FOR A LONG TIME NOW MY
QUESTIONS. SO THE FIRST ONE.
THE LONG TERM RENTAL SUBSIDIES
HAVE TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
FOR ALL THE REASONS WE TALKED
ABOUT AND WE'VE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE FEDERAL
WHAT WE NORMALLY USE SECTION
IT'S NOT ADEQUATE SO. ARE THERE.
TWO OUR TO HEAR ABOUT OBSTACLES
THAT ARE KEEPING US FROM USING
THOSE MY UNDERSTANDING FOR
EXAMPLE FROM SOME PROVIDERS IS
THAT ARE THAT CERTAIN OF OUR
MONEY WAS TIED TO THE HIGH
DEFINITION. OF LIKE IMMINENTLY
HOMELESS AND THAT DOUBTS YOU
HAVE TO BE HOMELESS WITHIN
FOURTEEN DAYS AND THERE'S A SET
OF VERY LARGE SET OF PEOPLE
THAT NEED. THIS TYPE OF HOUSING
SUBSIDY WHO ARE NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO BE HOMELESS IN
FOURTEEN DAYS. BUT MAYBE THEY
WILL BE IN THREE MONTHS OR
WHATEVER SO IS THAT IT OBSTACLE
DO WE NEED TO FIX THAT AND
WHAT. OBSTACLES ARE WE
EXPERIENCING IN TERMS OF TWO TO
PROVIDE AT PREVENT GEN I. THAT
FIND. TO MY FIRST QUESTION.
REGARDING THE OBSTACLES AROUND
THE FEDERAL RESOURCES THE
PRIMARY THING THAT WE SEE IN LA
COUNTY IN UTILIZING OUR
RESOURCES IN ADDITION TO JUST
MAKING SURE RECORD DATING IN
THE RIGHT WAY IS THE RATE AT
WHICH THE REIMBURSEMENT OCCURS
RELATIVE TO THE COST OF LIVING-
SO THE VOUCHER PAYS IS NOT
COMMENSURATE WITH THE AVERAGE
COST OF LIVING IN LA OR THE
COST OF THE UNIT OR RENT IN LA
SO JUST IS NOT COMPETITIVE. IN
THE RENTAL MARKET. THE FEDERAL
YOU KNOW LIMITATION ANSWER WE
IS OUR FINING TRYING TO MAKE UP
FOR THAT. ADDING TO OKAY SO
THAT'S WHAT WE TRY TO BUT YEAH
I THINK THAT'S- CERTAINLY
BARRIER- I THINK THAT DOUBLES
LHASA AND- LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT
HEALTH SERVICES IN BERLIN
CORNERS THE OTHER PARTNERS ARE
DOING SOME VERY INTENSIVE SORT
OF PILOTING AND PROBLEM SOLVING
AROUND- UTILIZING- TENANT BASED
VOUCHERS- INCLUDING. AS A SITE
BASED MODEL BUT COUNTY
BACKSTOPS- WHERE THOSE CAN BE
STRUCTURED AS IF IT WAS A
PROJECT BASED AND THEN YOU KNOW
CREATE ACCESS TO THOSE UNITS- I
WILL SAY BROADLY AND NOT GOING
TO SPEAK TO THIS. THAT PUTS
TAKE OUT BY OF INFLEXIBILITY.
PLATE IN ADDITION TO THE
TALENT- THAT THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDY STRUCTURE HAS KEEPING
ACE THAT. COST IT'S AN. ANGEL
MICHAEL CALIFORNIA BUT OTHER
PARTS OF CAL AS WELL I WILL SAY
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF INFO. IS I
MEAN WE WORK WITH HOUSING
AUTHORITIES UP IN LOS ANGELES
CA AND OVER THE STATE AND IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND- JUST TO GET
IT. TO PASS INSPECTION YOU'VE
GOT SOMEBODY WHO'S WAITING TO
MOVE IN WHO IS IN A SHELTER ON
THE STREETS. AND THE UNIT MIGHT
NOT PASS INSPECTION FOR A
REASON THAT. I MEAN. UP UP
LIGHTS WHICH IS IN A- HIGHER TO
LOS OF THEIR JUST FOR. LEGACY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UNFORTUNATELY
VERY INFLEXIBLE. SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING IS TO TRY
TO PROVIDE. AROUND SERVICES
LANDLORD ENGAGEMENT. ENABLING
COME LIKE BRIAN CORNERS TO BE
THE FACE OF THE PROGRAM WHERE.
WHERE LANDLORDS MIGHT OTHERWISE
SEE A STIGMA ATTACHED TO
WORKING WITH HOUSING
AUTHORITIES OF THAT- THAT BUT
THERE ARE CERTAIN LIMITS YOU
CAN'T DO CERTAIN THINGS IN
TERMS OF PRIDE. PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE YOU WERE VIOLATE THE
FEDERAL RULES. IS THE STATE IS
OUR STATE FUNDING TIED TO THAT
HIGH DEFINITION BEING AN
OBSTACLE AT ALL FOR THIS-
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROVISION. I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S MORE WE'RE
HEARING THE TABLE AND I WOULD
SAY THAT THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
FUNDS IS ALLOWING US TO STOP
GAP SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE DOING AN
INSPECTION AND THAT THAT THE
THERE'S A BROKEN WINDOW OR
SOMETHING IS WRONG OUR FUNDING
IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE
TO FIX THAT. AND GET SOMEBODY
INTO USE SO I WOULD SAY THAT.
IT WORKING AROUND HAD
DEFINITIONS AND HIDE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND
HAD RESTRICTIONS. WITH ARE
FINDING LOCALLY- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT A SORT OF OUR OUR
FUNDING DEFINITION RIGHT NOW IS.
FOR OUR OUR OWN DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW IS THAT
IS THAT. EVEN IN THE TOP TEN OF
THE OF THE ISSUES WERE WERE
SAYING. AND IF I COULD ADD FROM
ABOUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHEN
YOU'RE SWIMMING VOUCHERS ARE
AVAILABLE. HOUSING AUTHORITIES
ARE NOT NECESSARILY GOVERNED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES MANY TIMES
THERE AND- BODIES. ALSO YOU
HAVE A LARGE. WELL BEING LIST
ON THE HOUSING AUTHORITY IS
THAT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
OPEN UP THEIR WAITING LIST-
EVERY YEAR FOR INSTANCE FOR SAM
BERNIE DINOS- THEY IT WAS SEVEN
YEARS. THEY DRESS RECENTLY
OPENED AT PRIOR WAS SEVEN YEARS
THEIR FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ON
THE WAITING LIST THE WAY HAD
ALSO MANAGES THEIR PLANS. IS
YOU HAVE TO PICK PEOPLE FROM
THE WAITING LIST SO IF YOU'RE
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE NOT ON THE
WAITING LIST AND YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO TENANTS BASED ALTERS. IT
SOME MORE THE OTHER. WHEN
RELATIONSHIPS. RELY PART OUT.
SO AM I THANK THIS TALK ABOUT
PROJECT SPONSORED. MISSION IS
SHE- OUR- WHAT. TO ALLOW PUT
THAT PRICE FOR THE NEW UNITS IN
A EITHER TO PER OR POTENTIALLY
PER AND I THINK THE OTHER ISSUE
IT IN RELATIONSHIP TO HELP OUR
TROOPS COULD BE DEPLOYED IT'S
HAS DEFINITION OF A UNIT ROOM
EIGHT AN AT AND ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT I TALKED ABOUT WAS
THE LOWERING OF CONSTRUCTION
COSTS SOME THAT BECAUSE
POLICIES SET UP. USING FAT
RESOURCES OTHERS FROM HATS
PERSPECTIVE A UNIT PASSED TO
HAVE TO USE A VOUCHER HAS TO
HAVE A BATHROOM AND A KITCHEN.
YEAH WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT AND
MANY AGENCIES- ARE LOOKING OUT
MY CAR COUNTY ARE THERE OTHER
HOUSING TYPOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE. TO BRING OUR
CONSTRUCTION COSTS DOWN BECAUSE
THAT'S ONE SIDE OF THE EQUATION
AND THE OTHER FLIPSIDE IS HOW
TO WILL LINE THE RENTAL
RESOURCE THAT'S OUT THERE AND
WHERE THEY'RE DISCONNECTS
BETWEEN FINANCING AND BETWEEN
REGULATIONS IN BETWEEN POLICIES
AN APPLICATION. SO JUST TO KIND
OF BE AWARE FROM WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED BY EVERYBODY RELATIVE
VALUE IN MARKET THERE'S
PROCESSES AND ULTIMATELY THE
INITIATIVE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
POUCH. IN IF I COULD ADD ONE
MORE COMMENT ON A POSITIVE NOTE
WHICH IS THAT- AS DIFFICULT
MEAN USING A LOCAL FLEXIBLE
SUBSIDY IS SO MUCH MORE
POWERFUL AND EASIER TO WORK
WITH DâN A FEDERAL SUBSIDY
HAVING SAID THAT IF THERE IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE IF THERE IS
CAPACITY BILL FOR LANDLORD
ENGAGEMENT RENT SUBSIDY AND
PENDENCY SUPPORTS. AS HAS BEEN
BUILT UP IN CORNERS AND SOME
OTHER AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE
THEN WITHIN THAT IT IS POSSIBLE
YOU HAVE DEDICATED TEAMS THAT
BRIEF PROBLEM SOMETHING AROUND
HOW TO UTILIZE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF SUBSIDIES HOW TO ENGAGE
LANDLORDS DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY
SO BY INVESTING IN MAC A CITY
WITH A CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO
HAVE FUN WITH RENT SUBSIDIES
EMBEDDED IN IT YOU WILL OVER
TIME I THINK IN A BILL AT A
STATE UTILIZED. ABLE FEDERAL
REESE INCLUDING SITE EIGHT
DOCTORS. SERVE COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS ON OBSTACLES ON THE
OTHER ONE IS SO WE SEE THIS AS
A LOT OF WARDEN CORONAS ARE
LEAST ENTITIES NOT THEY DON'T
OWN AND SO THEN OF COURSE IF
THE OWNER DECIDES TO CONVERT.
BUT WE'VE ON. THE REAL QUESTION
IS THERE ARE THERE ARE
POTENTIAL UNITS AVAILABLE
WHETHER IT'S VACANT HOMES OR
BOARD AND CARE OR MOTELS ARE
VERY STE THINGS BUT THEY WOULD
NEED TO BE PURCHASED FOR US TO.
TO UTILIZE IMPROPERLY ARE THERE
OBSTACLES IN TERMS OF OUR STATE
FUNDING FOR THE ABILITY TO
PURCHASE. WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE THAT POTENTIALLY EASIER.
BECAUSE THAT SECURES IT COULD
SECURE PROPERTIES THEN FOR LONG
TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO BUILD FROM
SCRATCH WHICH IS QUITE
EXPENSIVE. IF THERE ARE ANY
THAT'S GREAT BUT- I HEAR FROM
PROVIDERS THAT THERE ARE SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. SO
I'LL SAY ON THIS ONE I MAY HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU WITH SOME
DETAIL DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
THREE GOALS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO HOUSING FUND THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE OF
THESE HOUSING UNITS FOR MOVING
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS. WHETHER THAT
INVOLVES TO ADULT RIGHT
PURCHASE- EXCEPT FOR USE OF THE
FUND WE HAVE TO CHECK USUALLY
WE DO IT THROUGH OTHER YOU KNOW
MANDATES AND OTHER INCENTIVES-
BUT- WE'LL CHECK AND GET BACK
TO YOUR OFFICE ON THAT. WE
DIFFERENT BE IN ON IT YOUR HOME
IS MONIES HAVE A FIND FOR
REENTRY HOUSES. AND AT WEAK
CHARACTER TO WHERE THERE WERE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD ACCESS
TO PURCHASE PROPERTY BUT THEY
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO YOU FUNDING
FOR THE PURPOSE SO ANYWAY THE-
WHAT PURSUE IT. COUPLE REQUEST.
ANOTHER ONE IT. OUR YOU GRADING
ARE. Q. H. C. NEVER TALK ABOUT
THAT'S VERY COMMONLY THE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER FOR THEM AND I
KNOW AT LEAST MYERS AND I'M
THOSE CLAY HAVE REALLY SOCIAL
YOU KNOW MY OFFICE SENT SOMEONE
WHO IS IN NEED OF HELP TO A
CLINIC IN THAT MAKE THEM SOME
UP TO THE CAL GOT SIGNED UP FOR
CALIBRATION. KINDA THING. AND
I'M WONDERING IF IN THIS WHEN
WE LOOK ABOUT THIS- KIND OF
COORDINATED CARE ARE WE
UTILIZING. THEM AS A RESOURCE
ARE THE INTEGRATED IN THIS SO
FQHCS WOULD BE AN ELIGIBLE
PROVIDER TO BE AN ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT PROVIDER WHO COULD
CONTINUE TO BE THAT KIND OF
LEAD SOURCE ENTITY. IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
ALL OF THE VARIOUS PIECES
ACROSS- VERY SOCIAL SERVICES
WHETHER IT'S THE AND LIEU OF
HOUSING SERVICES TO CONNECT
THEM TO THE EFFORT TO DO THAT-
OR IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS THAT
THEY WOULD BE A CANDIDATE FOR
THE ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
BENEFIT AND WORKS WITH THE HELP
HOME MODEL. WE WERE AT THAT.
ENDING ON THAT IS AND WE'VE
COMMUNICATED THAT MEANS THEY'RE
SMART BUT ALL. WE'RE MAKING WE
HAVE COMMUNICATED THAT BOOK.
INTO THE IT THAT. ALSO GIVE
THEM CLARIFICATION REGARDS TO
HOW THEY WERE PAID. ON THE HELP
COMES NOT A WOULD BE CONSISTENT
IT WOULD BE ABOVE- IN SEPARATE
THEN THE PPS RATE ON THE MUNICH
BUT WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING IS. THE RIGHT OF.
CENTER. THIS IS THE WORD YOUR
CREDIT PART OF THE HEALTH.
PROGRAM WHICH VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO ENHANCED
MANAGEMENT SO THEY SITE. WHERE
THERE ARE SO. SPECIFIC SAYS
INTO THE FOR THEIR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH NEEDS
GREAT. GREAT AND JUST MY ONE
OBSERVATION HAVING WORKED FOR
CITIES AND THEN COMING TO THE
COUNTY AND STARTING TO LISTEN
TO LINGO ASSOCIATED WITH. ALL
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. IT WHEN
CONNECTING DIFFERENT SERVICES A
LOT OF TIMES SMALLER MEDIUM
CITIES. DON'T KNOW RESOURCE
THERE. AS WE AS THE STATE HAS
STARTED ON THE PROCESS. WE WITH
I THINK KEEP AND HOPS ON THE
REGIONAL THE REGIONAL PLANTS IT
IT STARTS PULLING THE CITY'S
MORE INTO THE TABLE PARTICULIER
SMALLER CITIES ARE LARGER
CITIES THEY HAVE MORE
CONNECTIVITY TO YOUR COUNTIES
MOST OF THE MAJORITY OF YOUR
CITIES REALLY DON'T KNOW THESE
TERMINOLOGIES AND WHAT'S THERE
AND AT THAT SERVICES PROVIDED.
I THINK SOME OF THE POSITIVE
ABOUT THAT HAVE OCCURRED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT BUT
DON'T ASSUME ALL OF THOSE
STOCKS CONNECTED TODAY AND
THERE'S GREATER OPPORTUNITY
SUCH AS- AS THE NEXT DAY EVEN
NOW THEY STOOD BEFORE YEARS AGO
QUITE BRIGHT. SOUND JULY
QUESTIONS ANOTHER ONE IS THAT
WE'VE SEEING CITIES NOW I THINK
SENATORS GOES DOWN THIS OTHERS.
WHO ARE PASSING LAWS TO GIVE
THE RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL TO
TENANTS IN CERTAIN CASES. WE
ALREADY HAD BELIEVE FORECLOSURE
WE HAD SOME SOME PROVISIONS
LIKE THAT. AND NOW THESE
TENANTS ART. ALL NECESSARILY ON
THE BRINK OF BECOMING HOMELESS
IF THEY HAPPEN TO BE FACED WITH
A LIVING IN A PROPERTY DEBTS
FOR CLOTHES BUT THE COULD BE
YOU KNOW IT'S ONE OF THOSE. AND
I'M MY QUESTION IS NOT SO MUCH
WHETHER THIS FUNDING. IS
AVAILABLE SAY FOR THAT TYPE OF
PURPOSE BUT RATHER. DO WE HAVE.
IN DO WE HAVE REVOLVING LOAN
FUNDS DO WE HAVE OTHER SOURCES
OF FUNDS THAT MIGHT ENABLE
EITHER OUR COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS ARE NON PROFITS FOR OUR
TENANTS TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
BECAUSE THIS KIND OF CAPITALS
HARD SOMETIMES TO ACCESS SO
THAT THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUY EITHER A FORECLOSED
PROPERTY FOR. OTHER PROPERTIES
THAT ARE IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
DO WE HAVE ANY SOURCES OF FUNDS
LIKE DONE THE STATE. SO I CAN
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT INTO THEIR
VARIOUS HOUSING AND HOME
RELATED ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS-
ONE THING THAT'S MAYBE A CHASE
INTO THE QUESTION THAT YOU
MENTION IS WHEN IT COMES FOR
LEGAL ASSISTANCE WHICH IS
OFFICE IN DIFFERENT COMPONENT
OF PEOPLE DEALING WITH
ADDICTION BUT WHAT YOU DESCRIBE
IS ALSO A FORM OF UNIT. BUT
FORM OF EIGHT. BUDGET ENACTED
LAST SUMMER INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THAT AND THEN ONE
OTHER PROGRAM AND I WAS LEGAL
ASSISTANCE RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
AND NOW WE'RE WORKING ON THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT
MONEY- BUT IN TERMS OF THE
OTHER SPECIFIC CAPITAL PROGRAMS
WOULD ALSO WANT TO GET BACK TO
YOUR OFFICE. OKAY GREAT AND
THEN FINALLY IN TERMS BURKE
HOLES. THINK OF A LOT OF ROOM
FOR ME TO PUT ANY IN PRIORITY
BUT CLEARLY WE HAVE. IN
ADDITION TO THE GROWTH IN. ON
BLACK POPULATION BEING HOMELESS
AN AGING IS CHILDREN. AND YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE SOONER WE
CAN GET A CHILD HOUSE STE. THE
MOON BETTER OUTCOMES FOR THEM
FOR THEIR WHOLE LIFE SO HOW
MUCH ARE WE- HAVE WE TARGETED
ANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY TO MAKING SURE
THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE HOUSE.
OUR HOME CHILDREN. SAID F. YOU
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WITHIN
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON THAT THAT'S THE CAO
WORKS HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM.
I WHICH IS FUNDED ABOUT NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
THIS THIS FISCAL YEAR- ALSO
REFERENCE IN YOUR AGENDA
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME WHICH IS
SUPPORTING THE CHILD WELFARE
POPULATION OF FAMILY
UNIFICATION. WORKS ALSO HAS A
SIXTEEN DAY HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR THOSE MIGHT HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE NEED AS WELL- SO I
THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
ESTABLISHED PROGRAMS FOR THE
POP PATIENT RECOGNIZED. IT'S TO
THE IT THE BILL FOR YOUTH. TO
ADDRESS AT WELL BOTH ON THE
FAMILY PERSPECTIVES. FAMILIES
TO BE HOUSE BUT ALSO FOR YOU. I
WOULD SAY WELL IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY CHILDREN BUT I
THINK ON A COMPANY DUE TO THE
REALLY KEY PIECE OF THIS THAT-
HAS NOT RECEIVED A LOT OF
FUNDING YOUR ATTENTION AND IN
YEARS PAST AND THAT. BOTH THE
HEAT FUNDING HAD 5% SET ASIDE
AND THE HAPPENING AT 8%
SATISFIED WITH THE DATA YOU
THOMAS'S HEARING HERE A COUPLE
DAYS AGO IN THE BUILDING- WITH
A FULL FOLKS I THINK THAT. A
LOT TO BE LEARNED FROM THAT IS
REALLY HELPING COMMUNITIES
FOCUS ON THAT IN A WAY THAT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO IN
THE PAST. IN AND AS OF- TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE- THE- OTHER
PROGRAMS WE MEAN THAT NOT
DIRECTED DIRECTLY SELFIE WITH
HOUSING. LOOKING AT- OUR FOSTER
YOUTH POPULATION AND I THINK.
IT MAY BE SENT TO BELLOW AS A
BILL TO EXTEND THE AGING OUT OF
TWENTY FIVE AND- KIND OF THE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE EXISTING
TAPE ROGRAM FOR THE TRANSITION
AGE. USE THAT. THAT THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S ONLY A- CERTAIN
POPULATION THEM WHO QUALIFY FOR
THE HOUSING. POST EIGHTEENTH
THE INTO THE SYSTEM OF CERTAIN
AGE. SO REALLY NEED TO LOOK.
MORE DEEPLY AT. THE EXTENSION
THAT WE DID CREATE. AN ARE ARE
WE THROUGH POLICY EXCLUDING
MORE KIDS THAN WE SHOULD. RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON VEGAS
INTO SKINNER CENTER WHERE CAL
STATE SO I'VE A SUGGESTION FOR
HOW I THOUGHT QUESTION AND
SUGGESTION SO. ON THIS REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATION THING MR
DISPLAYING OFTEN. IN THE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION WORLD WE
HAVE THESE ORGANIC
COLLABORATIVE SAID HAVE SPRUNG
UP IN THE LAST SIX FIVE SIX
YEARS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
PLANNING DOCUMENTS WITH CITIES
AND COUNTIES ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT WHAT TO DO
YOU IN CLIMATE TO OUR SEALABLE
RISER WHATEVER IT IS WINE WITH
THESE ORGANIC COLLABORATIVE
REGIONAL BODIES NOT BE. YOUR
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE THING
WHY SINCE IT'S BASICALLY THE
SIR HOMELESS ADVOCATES PLANNING
STUFF WITH ACROSS JURISDICTION
JUST A THOUGHT. JUST A THOUGHT
THAT WOULD BE THE PART YOU HAVE
TO ANSWER BUT TAKE THAT BACK TO
THE YOU KNOW WHO IT WAS I WILL
SAY SIMPLY THAT THE REGION'S
HAVEN'T BEEN DEFINED YET AS-
YOUR BILL SO- WE ARE WE ARE WE
CAN DISCUSS A NUMBER OF
POSSIBILITIES AND THERE'S NO
REASON WHY THAT CAN BE ONE OF
THEM. ON THE CAPITAL PROJECTS
AND I'M THINKING MANY CAPITAL
PROJECTS THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR HAVE DONE A LOT
IT'S- PASS LAWS LEGISLATIONS ON
EXCESS RE DWELLING UNITS.
LITTLE UNITS LITTLE HOUSES
HOUSES WITHIN A HOUSE GARAGE
CONVERSIONS LITTLE COTTAGE IN
THE BACKYARD ABOUT A THIRD TO A
QUARTER OF THE COST. SO MY
QUESTION IS WHY WOULD YOU NOT
WANT TO TAKE SOME OF THIS
CAPITAL MONEY THAT YOUR GUYS
ARE DISHING OUT. AND GIVE IT TO
SOMEBODY TO CONVERT THEIR
GARAGE OR MAKE A COTTAGE FOR
ITS FIFTY SIXTY EIGHTY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THEN BASICALLY. YOU'RE A FROM
AS MISTER JONES. IF HE GETS
BACK ON HIS FEET AND HE'S ABLE
TO PAY. THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
OR FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT
STRETCHES OUT THAT AGREEMENTS
YOU MAY NOT GET FIFTEEN YEARS
BUT YOU GET TO WHATEVER THE
DEAL IS WITH ALL THESE PEOPLE
WITH LL IN THAT SUBURBIA. OR
IN THE RURAL CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE THIS POSSIBILITY. THE
PROPOSAL THAT IS AN ALLOWABLE
USE OF THE FUNDS. THERE'S A
WONDERFUL ORGANIZATION LA
COUNTY I'M GONNA BUT MAYBE BUT
TO THE NAME LA MAS I THINK-
THAT IS THAT IS ATTEMPTING TO
SCALE THAT MODEL IN LA COUNTY
FOR PEOPLE EXPERTS IN
HOMELESSNESS- TO THE RANCH
TINGLING STATEWIDE BUT IT IS A
VIABLE MODEL YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LOOK AT THAT TO SEE IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO STRETCH YOUR TARA
DOLLARS. IN IN THE SUGGESTION I
THINK THIS IS A BACK YOU MISTER
THIS WHY NOT THEN. ONE OF THE
FUNDING MECHANISMS THAT WE HAVE
FOR HOUSING. IS OUR CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM. I'VE BEEN AN
ADVOCATE OF REACHING THE FLOOR
PRICE ON CAP AND TRADE FOR YOU.
HOMELESS ADVOCATES IF WE WERE
TO RAISE THE PRICE OF OUR FLOOR
TO THIRTY FIVE OR FORTY.
DOLLARS PER METRIC HI ACRE OF
POLLUTION WE WOULD CREATE ABOUT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THIS MAY
BILL FOR FIVE YEARS BUT 20% OF
FOUR BILLION IS EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD TAKE THAT
INCREMENTAL AND- USE THAT AS
YOUR CONTINUOUS SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR ALL THESE THINGS
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHY IS THAT
A BAD IDEA. THE SENATOR Y.
CASCADE- THIS ISSUE ALSO CAME
UP AT THE CLIMATE HEARING LAST
WEEK SO I WILL TAKE YOUR FEET.
SELECT I WILL TAKE YOUR
FEEDBACK BACK TO ALL THE
RELEVANT PARTIES. THE NOW SEE
THE GOLDSTAR FOR CREATIVITY
TODAY THAT'S RIGHT WE FOUND THE
FUNDING SOURCE- TO OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE GUESTS MISTER. ALLEN
YOU WELL FIRST OF ALL WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT'S REPRESENTED BY
YOUR PRESENTATIONS I KNOW- YOU
KNOW EVERYONE HERE IS WORKING
HARD ON TRYING TO ADDRESS WHAT
IS BECOME ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CRISES IN OUR BIGGEST SOCIAL
CRISES IN OUR STATE SOMETHING I
HEAR ABOUT A LOT FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS WANTED A MOMENT TO
BE HERE WITH ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING. I MEAN I
DO I. ALSO LITTLE SURPRISED
THAT. AB THE KIND OF QUESTION
THAT. BUT SOME OF THE
PRESENTATIONS OF. I HAVE- YOU
KNOW MAYBE ALLUDED TO A LITTLE
BIT BUT THE BUT THE CORE
QUESTION I THINK THAT THAT THAT
THE CHAIR MITCHELL RACES THAT I
THINK IS AT THE HEART OF ALEJO.
SET OF CONCERNS IS THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF YOU KNOW HOW WE
FULLY THOUGHT ALL THIS THROUGH
WE OBVIOUSLY HAD HE BEEN
HAPPENED AND- AND THERE'S SO
MUCH REALLY GOOD WORK HAPPENING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- YOU KNOW
WE'VE CREATED ALL THESE
INFRASTRUCTURES YOU KNOW AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO PROVIDE ALL THE
SERVICES. AND YET HERE WE ARE
NOW COMING IN WITH A BRAND NEW.
PROPOSAL ON. YOU KNOW. WITH A
LOT OF REALLY INTERESTING IDEAS
AND I'M I'M CERTAINLY BEEN.
NUMBER SO TRY TO SOAK IT ALL IN.
VIDEO WE KNOW WE HAVE A CRISIS
ON THE GROUND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT QUICKLY-
BUT THEN WE'RE ALSO. TRYING TO.
YEAH CREATE THIS WHOLE NEW
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR
INFRASTRUCTURE I'M I'M STILL
NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR ABOUT HOW
THE REGIONS ARE GONNA BE
DEFINED AND- HOW FUNDING IS
GOING TO BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN
THE REGIONS AND WHOSE CAN ACT
AS A REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR
AND- AND- ALL THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. IT IT IT ALMOST FEELS A
LITTLE LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD THE PLANE WHILE IT'S IN
THE AIR AYE AYE YOU KNOW SO. I
LIKE TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
WHERE THIS FITS INTO ALL OF THE
WORK THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENED
AND THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
THE LOCAL LEVEL- I APPRECIATE
THE- THIS IS SEEMS TO BE A- AN
AGGRESSIVE OWNERSHIP OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKING OVER OVER
THIS ENORMOUS ISSUE- BUT IS
THIS IS THIS THE RIGHT WAY TO
DO IT ON THIS TIME FRAME- THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I
THINK THE LA- BROUGHT BRINGS UP
IN ITS REPORT I JUST LOVE SOME.
SOME DIRECT ANSWERS TO AYE
CONCERNS FROM FOLKS. I SENATOR
ALLEN- VEGAS WOULD OFTEN FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'M
HAPPY TO SPEAK- BRIEFLY ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND THEN
MY COLLEAGUES MAY WANT TO WEIGH
IN AS WELL. I THINK THE FIRST
AND MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
WITH HE'D BEEN HAPPY TO THOSE
INVESTMENTS AS DESCRIBED IN
THIS HEARING A LOT OF THAT
FUNDING IS JUST DURING THE
GROUND RIGHT NOW SO WE ARE WAYS
ARE FOCUSED ON. MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING
USED EFFECTIVELY I THINK WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PACIFIC OPPOSE
ALL- LIKE YOU MENTIONED AND
MIKE THE GOVERNOR SAID IN THE
STATE OF STATE. EVERYONE IS
PATIENT AND EVERYONE'S ACT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT CALIFORNIA ACCESS
TO HOUSING FOR. CERVICAL THE
TWO MAJOR. ARE TO. MOVE PEOPLE
OFF THIS. AND INTO HOUSING AND
DEVELOP MORE THOSE HOUSING
UNITS AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROGRAM. IS INTEGRATED
WITH ALL THE OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SERVICES THAT THE
STATE IS PROVIDING AND THAT THE
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES ARE
PROVIDING. BUT WE THOUGHT WITH
THIS ONE TIME SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR FUND. PUT
IT RIGHT IN THE TENS OF THOSE
TWO PURPOSES WAY OUT THREE VERY
CLEAR OBJECTIVES IN TERMS OF
HOW THE MONIES. AND I THINK THE
BROADER. FRAME FOR IT THAT IS
TWO FOLD WOW FOR. LOCATION OF
APPROACH. CONTINUE ACCOUNTED.
PATRICK'S AND THEN THE SECOND
THING IS RECOGNIZING. I THINK
IN SOME THE QUESTIONS ABILITY
TO THIS WHEN WE HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND POTS OF
MONEY- AND THEN WE- HAVE SO
MUCH OF THE FUNDING BY SPECIFIC
FORMULA. IT BECOMES A LITTLE
BIT OF THE FUNDING HERE A
LITTLE BIT OF THE FUNDING
THERE. AND SO. I THINK EVERYONE
RECOGNIZES THAT A NEW APPROACH
IS NEEDED AND SO. THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEST BET FOR
HOW THAT CAN GO BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO. WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT IN
TERMS OF. OUR FIGHTING ALL THE
DETAILS TO GET EVERYTHING RIGHT
BECAUSE IT IS NEW. AND THEN I
THINK THE LAST THING THAT I.
SAY IS THIS IS ONE TIME FIND.
AS DISCUSSED. DURING I THINK
EVERYONE AT THE TABLE AND
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ONE
TO IDENTIFY AN ONGOING SOURCE
OF FUNDING. AND I THINK AS THE
MATCH CONTAINS. I'M SORRY.
WE'LL HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
WHAT YOUR PRO IS A REAL MOVING
THE BILL AND WHERE WE SHOULD BE
TO THAT I CAN MY CONCERN IS
BECAUSE ON GOING FIGHT IS ONE
TIME FINDING AND YOUR CREATING
THIS WHOLE INFRASTRUCTURE TAKE
IT IS THAT YOU KNOW I GUESS
THAT MAKES THAT MAKES ME EXTRA
NERVOUS. IF WAS BILL IF THIS IS
A LONG TERM COMMITMENT. WE
DECIDED AND COURTNEY DID
STRATEGIC MANNER THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BUILD THIS WHOLE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS GOING TO
BE THE NEW WAY. FOR US TO
APPROACH HER. OUR REGIONAL AND
LOCAL AND- STATEWIDE NEEDS. IT
THAT WAY I WOULD FEEL BETTER
BUT BUT- IT. SHOULD ONE TIME
FINDING GO TOWARD THE EXISTING
SUCCESSFUL INFRASTRUCTURE. SO I
THINK THAT THE KEY THING HERE
FOR THIS IS A WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE METRICS AND
THEY ARE IN THE TRAILER BILL.
ARE VERY CLEAR SO. CERTAINLY
THE- TAKEN. WILL BUY YOU WAITED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF FIND OF
WHETHER WE'RE ACHIEVING THOSE
TARGETS THAT ARE SET OUT IN THE
TRAILER BILL. YEAH WELL. OKAY I
CANNOT FOLLOW UP ON YOUR POINT
BEFORE YOU GO ON DID THIS I'M
SITTING HERE LOOKING AT- THE
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTATIVE
HAVING HEARD. THE WONDERFUL
WORK THEY'VE DONE WITH HE BEEN
HAPPENED I'M WONDERING SO THAT
ENDS. HOW YOU GUYS BRIDGE MINE
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE SACRAMENTO EXAMPLE WE HEARD
TODAY WELL FIRST A WE'RE GONNA
BE MINE IN MONITORING HOW THAT
FUNDING IS BEING USED TO THAT'S
FINE THAT SENATE FUNDING IS
BEING SPENT THIS YEAR I THINK
SECOND- THAT MONEY WAS ALSO ONE
TIME FUNDING IN THE BUDGET THE
LAST TWO YEARS IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES- NEED
MORE ASSISTANCE I THINK A
NUMBER THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
WORKING ON. A RECOGNIZED PRICE
THEY ALL NEED FOR A SIX YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO FIND WAYS
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
BUDGET THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO DIRECT RESOURCES IN THE
RIGHT WAY AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT GOVERNOR- MADE SO
CLEAR IN THE STATE OF THE STATE
THAT WE NEED TO FIND A STABLE
ON GOING REVENUE SOURCE. HAS
AND THAT'S BASICALLY WHERE
UNDER SHOULD GO BUT CERTAIN.
KEY ACTORS AT THE TABLE. AND
ALL A PART POLLUTION. I THINK
REALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
FINE AN THE REQUEST FOR EARLY
ACTION. IT'S MORE THE SENSE
THAT WE CAN'T WAIT AND WHICH IS
WHY EVEN THOUGH THE PROBLEM IS
FAST AND A NUMBER OF WAYS YOU
CAN APPROACH IT ARE PRETTY
FAST. WE WANTED TO CONFINE THE
FINE TO ADD VERY SPECIFIC
OBJECTIVES VERY SPECIFIC SET OF
SOLUTIONS. AND I GET THE
CONCERNED ABOUT ONE TIME FIVE.
AND YOU KNOW THE MONEY GOES OUT
THE DOOR AND THEN. WHAT HAPPENS
TO IT. BUT VERY CLEAR PATRICK
ON IT WOULD BE OF. BEFORE HE
FOR FINDINGS. BY THE TO THIS
PROGRAM. AS I CAN GET BACK TO.
ALLEN I ALSO. THAT THAT WE'VE
HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR AND
HEARD THE GOVERNOR LAWTON CLEAR
TERMS OR IN ACCESS TO THE
FUNDING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND YET WE DON'T HAVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET. PROVIDE CLEARLY TO
US TODAY ABOUT. HOW THE
REGION'S WILL BE DEFINED WHO
THE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS
WILL BE. AND YET WE ALREADY
HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
KEEPING HOUSE. WHERE IT CAN HIT
THE GROUND IT SEEMS TO ME A
LITTLE FASTER THAN. LIKELY WILL
WITH A YET TO BE DEFINED.
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
DILATATION. RITTER ALLEN READ
THE GOING TO SUCH A POINT YOU
pBEEN SPENDING ALL THIS MONEY.
AND THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
CHALLENGES- I'VE BEEN. ASKING
US TO SPEND UP. ANOTHER HUGE
CHUNK OF MONEY WITHOUT. YOU
KNOW A CLEAR DEFINED.
STRATEGIES AND I THAT'S THAT'S
THE OLD. FEAR IN AND I THINK
IT'S I THINK WE KNOW THIS IS
SUCH AN ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY
YOU'RE ASKING FOR US TO INVEST
I THINK. THERE'S A LOT OF
WILLINGNESS TO INVEST THIS KIND
OF MONEY BECAUSE OF THE
SEVERITY OF THE PROBLEM. AND
YET I THINK THE LEGISLATURE.
YOU KNOW IN THE ALLEY-
ARTICULATES IS VERY VERY
EFFECTIVELY. REALLY NEEDS TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE THA THERE'S A
CLEAR STRATEGY HERE AND THAT
THERE'S A CLEAR STRUCTURE AND-
THAT I THINK IS THAT. THE
CENTRAL CONCERN THAT I KNOW A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE. SO
AND I SEE YOU PRESSING YOUR- IT
JUST MADE ME MAKE ONE POINT IS
TO POINT OUT THAT THE FINDING
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WITH
CAL AIM THE ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT IN LIEU OF SERVICES
THAT HOUSING BATTLE. THAT IS AN
ON GOING THE WOULD BE A NEW
MEDI CAL BENEFITS SO THAT THOSE
TWO PIECES ARE ON GOING-
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THIS. THIS TOPIC. I WOULD ALSO
JUST PIGGY BACK AND TELL THE
STORY OF- YOU KNOW GOING TO MY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WITH THE
PROPOSED. CONTRACT FOR THE LA
COUNTY FLEX POOL. AND THEY SAID
TO ME WITH A LITTLE LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO BUILD
THE PLANE WHILE YOU'RE FLYING
IT- YOU KNOW WE HAD FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS COMMITTED
WHAT'S NOW OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. OUR ANNUAL- FLEXIBLE
BUDGET MATCHES BRING CORNERS
LOAN INCLUDING THE RENT
SUBSIDIES OTHER PASSED THROUGH
FUNDS. AND BY. DEMONSTRATING
THE POWER OF THAT MODEL WE HAVE
TO SECURE ONE GOING INVESTMENTS
VOTER APPROVED- THE-
INVESTMENTS FOR OP RENT
SUBSIDIES SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
ON AN ON GOING SUSTAINABLE WAY.
AS WELL AS INVESTMENTS FROM LA
CARE PHILANTHROPY- AND WE'RE
SEEING THAT PROCESS ALREADY
MARRIED HERE IT AT THE STATE
LEVEL WITH. FIVE MILLION
COMMITTED TO HEALTHCARE AGENCY.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT. UP BUT CONCERNS ARE
ARE ARE LEGITIMATE- WE BELIEVE
THAT. IT TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REFLECTS ON OF THE BEST
PRACTICES. IN THE EXPORT. IT IS
NOT STARTING SOMETHING NEW TO
CLICK IT IF. BUT RATHER
PROVIDING A SET OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND STAFFING
RESOURCES AND PROVEN STRATEGIES
THAT WILL ENHANCE THE CAPACITY.
OF EXISTING LOCALITIES
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM. TO
ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE INTO
HOUSING UNITS. WITH A FOLLOW UP
ON THAT I MEAN LOVE TO GET LOT
MORE FOR ME ABOUT WHAT EXISTING
DATA OR KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
USED TO CREATE THE REGIONAL
PROGRAM AND- HE USED TO
DETERMINE THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES WITHIN THE REGIONS
ARE. GOING TO BE A COUPLE
GUIDING DATA POINTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE AT THE HEART OF
THIS. ALLOCATION TO DECISIONS
YES THE- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT'S CURRENTLY POSTED ONLINE
AND FINANCES WEBSITE SPEAKS TO
THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY THAT
WILL BE USING SO IT IS. LOOKING
AT POINT IN TIME COUNT- IN THE
END AND THAT. ADDITIONAL NEED
FOR HOUSING FOR PERSONS WHO ARE
EXISTING HOMELESS POPULATION IT
ALSO HAS THE NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
BURDENED BY THEIR RENT OR
MORTGAGE- TO INCOME RATIO. AND
THE NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS PER
CAPITA IN HOUSING NEED-
DETERMINED BY INCOME LEVEL AND
THAT FOURTH COMPONENT THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER IS RACIAL
EQUITY SO. THOSE WOULD BE THE
FACTORS THAT WOULD BE USED TO
DEVELOP THE METHODOLOGY THE
CONVERSATION ON. KIND OF THE
WEIGHTS THAT WOULD BE USES ON
GOING AT. NOW IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF HOW IT LOOKS ACROSS
THE REGION AND WHAT THAT WOULD
YIELD IN TERMS OF THE
ALLOCATIONS. LET ME BRING UP
BUT ANOTHER ISSUE THAT HAS IS
VERY RELATED TO WHAT YOU JUST
BROUGHT UP AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW
COUNCILMEMBER BON AND TALKED
ABOUT AND LA. LA CITY COUNCIL A
WEEK OR TWO AGO AND THAT'S THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO ARE CONSIDERED. NOT
HOMELESS ENOUGH. TO GET
SERVICES SO THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO IN THE HELL IN THE REPORT
TALKS ABOUT- OTHER PEOPLE THE
COLLEGE KIDS YOU MAY BE COUCH
SURFING OR- OR YOU KNOW-
HOMELESS FAMILY THAT MAY BE
GOING IN AND OUT OF. STAYING
WITH OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS- YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOT SO MUCH- THERE
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST HANGING AROUND THE EDGES
IS ONE THING THAT WE KEEP
HEARING. LOCAL FOLK. AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO IT'S ALMOST LIKE
THE- YEAH. IT THESE ARE FOLKS
WHO HOME A LITTLE BIT
INVESTMENT CAN GO A LONG WAY IN
TERMS OF DETERMINING WHETHER
THEY END UP OF WE KNOW. MORE
MORE. A MORE SERIOUS CASE. AND
I GUESS A ONE OF THE CONCERNS I
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THAT A LOT OF
THE- EXISTING BUREAUCRACY NAME
AND I WORRY THAT WE MAY. IF YOU
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
JUST MENTIONED TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT IT
WITH THE COURTS INDICATORS THAT
WE MADE DOUBLE DOWN ON A SYSTEM
WHERE- WITH THERE'S VERY. FEW
DEDICATED SOURCES FOR FUNDING
FOR FOLKS WHO OF. LOW ACUITY
WHO YOU KNOW OR THE LITTLE MAY
BE EASIER TO HELP BETTER I AT
HIGH RISK OF ANY UP ON THE
STREETS AND SO. ON ARE WE GET
IT. WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO SET
ASIDE SOME MONEY TO HELP THOSE
FOLKS WHO WERE LIVING IN CARS
PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL HAVING.
HAVE THEIR JOBS OR MAYBE COUCH
SURFING- BUT YOU KNOW THEY'VE
BEEN. THEY'VE BEEN. STUCK IN A
PARKING LOT MY DISTRICT FOR THE
LAST SIX MONTHS. BECAUSE
THERE'S NO RESOURCE TO GUIDE
THEM OUT AND THEY'RE JUST. YOU
KNOW. AND YOU KNOW. CAR PAYMENT
AWAY FROM MISS AND LOSE THEIR
JOB AND THEN ENDING UP ON THE
STREETS ENTIRELY OR- ONE MISS
SHOWER WHEN MR. BUS YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO HELP
THOSE FOLKS. SO I WOULD SAY
THAT THE HOT FUNDING- I
MENTIONED BEFORE CAN BE USED ON
PREVENTION AND SHELTER
DIVERSION AND SO THAT WOULD
ADDRESS A LOT OF THOSE FOLKS
YOU JUST MENTIONED. WHAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES RIGHT
NOW ON AND THINKING ABOUT AND
AS WERE REVIEWING THE
APPLICATIONS WE'VE ASKED THEM
TO SORT OF TAKE A LOOK AT. WHAT
HOW THEY'RE USING THEIR FUNDING
AND WHAT OTHER RESOURCES THEY
HAVE AN AND REALLY TRYING TO
ENSURE. THAT YOU KNOW WE WERE
AT A HEARING IN SAN FRANCISCO.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND I THINK
MAYOR SHAFT BUT REALLY WELL
SORT OF A AN INTERVENTION BY I
APPROPRIATE RATIO OF
INTERVENTIONS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. SO THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST
BUILDING SHALL NOT JUST BERMAN
BUILDING PERMITS A PART OF
HOUSING WHICH TO HAVE ENTIRE IN
YOUR CHIN SYSTEM THAT CONTRAST
FOR YOUR- ON THE- OF. AT THAT
RATE OR ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
A COMMON. AND SO. THE FLEX. AND
OF HOW. REALLY ALLOWS YOU TO
BUILD OUT THAT ANTI SET OF
INNER. LOOKING AT WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE COMMUNITIES ALREADY
INVESTING IN A WHAT GAP YOU
NEED TO FILL TO HAVE THAT FULL
RANGE OF INTERVENTIONS. YES AND
JUST TO ADD TO THAT THE ONE
THING THE STATE HAS PROVIDED IN
THEIR PROGRAMS IS A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY AND IT IS CRUCIAL
FROM PREVENTION TO HOUSING AND
DIVERSION KEEPING PEOPLE AND
HOUSING BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS WE
ALL KNOW IT'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY
SO WHEN YOU COME TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY TO SAY YOU COULD USE
THIS FOR DIVERSION YOU COULD
USE THIS FOR PREVENTION OR DO
YOU USE THAT FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SO YOU'RE MAKING
TOUGH CHOICES ACROSS THE BOARD
SO ES HAPPENED IN CAN PROVIDE
THAT. WILL IT BE USED IN THAT
WAY BASED UPON THE LOCAL
PRIORITIES IT MAY OR MAY NOT BE.
CAN I ASK OUR YOU KNOW HI
EIGHTY EIGHT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IN LA COURSES COME
IN FOR WITH A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
FUNDING PROPOSAL HOW DO YOU SEE.
WE ARE WE ARE DO YOU SEE THESE
PROPOSALS BEING FUNDAMENTALLY
CONFLICT JEWEL OR OR HARM IT DO
YOU SEE A WAY FOR US TO MARRY
THE NEEDS AND ISSUES THAT YOU
HAVE ON THE GROUND IN LA WITH.
THAT WHICH IS BEING PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR. I THINK THERE'S A
THERE IS A WAY TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT A
LOT IN LA IS THIS CHALLENGE
AROUND IT'S A DELICATE BALANCE
OF HOW DO YOU. BUILD A SYSTEM
IT'S REALLY EFFICIENT MAKE
TWEAKS AS NEEDED- BUT ALSO
DON'T TAKE A STEP BACKWARD IT
UNINTENTIONALLY FRAGMENTING
THINGS AND BREAKING THE CURRENT
SYSTEM A PART IN AN EFFORT TO
MAKE THE SYSTEM BETTER- AND
THAT'S A HARD BALANCE FOR US
SO. I THINK FOR US WHAT IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO DO AROUND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS MAKING SURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE MEASURING IS.
HEALTH OF THE OVERALL SYSTEM
AND NOT JUST DIFFERENT PIECES
OF THE SYSTEM SO WHAT I MEAN
IS. HOW THE HOW DO WE LOOK AT
HOW THIS. IS FUNCTIONING WITH
ALL OF ITS COMPONENTS AND HOW
THOSE ARE INTERACTING AND USE
THAT TO JUDGE THE EFFICACY OR
THE EFFICIENCY OF OUR SYSTEM.
NOT JUST HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GOING PLATE AND IT ARM HOUSING
OR A DECREASE IN THE ON
SHELTERED BY WHAT'S THE ACTUAL
OUT COMMON IN ARE WE- ARE WE
TAKING A BALANCED APPROACH IN
OUR INTERVENTIONS AND SO. PART
OF THE CONCERN FROM THE OUTLAYS
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH
WORK DONE TO BUILD UP A SYSTEM
THAT. IT BALLOT NUMBER. BRING
ON ANOTHER LAYER BERMAN. PUT
THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE CITY
COUNTY CO MODEL. FURTHER SOME
THAT WERE REALLY WORKING. TO
BRING TOGETHER SPECIAL GIVEN
THE LOCAL RESOURCES WE HAVE
COME AND A LOT. HOW DO YOU DO
THERE ARE. I GO OUT. IF
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LA COUNTY-
ELLIE CITY IN THE C. O. C. BUT
I KNOW THAT NOT EVERY
JURISDICTION IS LIKE THAT SO I
THINK. ALLOWING THE
JURISDICTIONS TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE NEED TO
DECIDE YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY FOR THE MONEY TO COME
IN I THINK THAT THE- THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS ARE. ADDICTS ARE ABLE
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS FOR
THEIR OWN. THEIR OWN
JURISDICTIONS. OKAY I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S ANSWERS
AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE-
THE FOR PARENTS OF THAT OF THE
CHAIRMAN. YEAH THIS IS I DON'T
HAVE TO EXPLAIN ANYONE HERE
ABOUT ABOUT. YOU KNOW NORM IS A
PROBLEM THAT THIS IS ON OUR ON
OUR STREETS AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW I'M-
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE-
EXTRAORDINARY ATTENTION THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
MINISTRATION GIVING TO THIS
ISSUE I THINK IT'S IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT- I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- CAN AFFORD INVEST
THIS KIND OF MONEY WHICH I
THINK. WE WERE INTO A RIGHT
GONNA CHRIS STRUCK SECTION IN
YOUR FOR. IN AND NOT RECREATE
THE WHEEL UNNECESSARILY AND SO
I MEAN THE LAST THING WE NEED
TO DO IS TO BE AT THE END OF
THIS LOOKING BACK AT THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND- NOT SEE.
PROPERTY YET SEEING ENORMOUS.
OF PUBLIC IN. AND THAT'S- OKAY
TV MY CONCERN I KNOW THIS
BUDGETARY SHARES THAT CONCERN I
JUST THINK THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO. ENGAGE IN A VERY
ROBUST MANNER TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A CLEAR.
WELL THOUGHT THROUGH STRATEGY
IS CAN BE WELL INTEGRATED WITH
THE SERVICE FROM THERE'S ON THE
GROUND. THAT THAT WILL. GET THE-
IN I YOU COMMITTEE TO THAT
MATTER CHAIR BUT- I IT WILL BE
ABLE TO. DIEM BY MAJOR CAN. OF
MINE. FORWARD THE SEVERITY THIS
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LAW THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
APPRECIATE THE CIRCLE AROUND
THE TABLE. IT'S KIND OF A NICE
OPTED WE SHOULD TAKE A PHOTO-
I'M JUST CURIOUS HAVE ANYONE
HAVE YOU BEEN TO HAVEN FOR HOPE
IN SAN ANTONIO TEXAS. MISS
MAYOR STEINBERG BEEN REFERRING
TO IT AND I'VE BEEN THERE AND I
WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO JUST DO A
LITTLE RESEARCH ON THAT THE
SILLY. WHAT THAT CITIES DOING A
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESS
SITUATION- IT'S A CAMPUS THAT-
IS RATHER REMARKABLE- IT IS
NEAR DOWNTOWN BUT THE RIVER
WALK IS NICE. IN THE ALAMO IS
NICE AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE. AROUND
HERE IN SACRAMENTO OTHER PLACES
SO IT'S A MODEL PRIVATE PUBLIC
OPPORTUNITY IT'S DOES DOING
REAL WELL WOULD. IT BE WELL
WORTH YOUR TIME. I JUST MAYBE
TALK TO THE AG ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT YOU CAN GET REIMBURSED. LEX
POOL ARE BRILLIANT CORNERS-
MISTER PICKLE I JUST WANT TO
KNOW I DON'T HAVE A TREND I
JUST SEE BIG NUMBER SO FROM
TWENTY FOURTEEN IS A DOING THIS
SAID THAT IT'S BY CAN COME
DOWN- WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE
TREND SO- WIT WHEN OCTOR MEETS
CAT AND HIS TEAM ANNOUNCED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF- HEALTH
SERVICES ONE TRY TO- RE HOUSING
KEEP HOUSE AT TEN THOUSAND-
HIGH FREQUENCY- UTILIZES A
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICES PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THEY
CAME OUT WITH THE- A REQUEST-
IN OUR IF THE THAT SAID THE
PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED TO DOUBLE
IN EACH OF THE FIRST FOUR YEARS
SO THREE HUNDRED UNITS OCCURRED
AND HOUSEHOLD THREE HOUSE IN
THE FIRST YEAR SIX HUNDRED THE
SECOND YEAR UP TO TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED- AND SO AS I SHARED
OVER THE FIRST FOUR YEARS WE
ALREADY SURPASSED FIVE
THOUSAND- PEOPLE AND WE'RE NOW
OVER. TOWARDS THOUSAND IT'S
BEEN. THAT TYPE OF GROWTH YEAR
OVER YEAR- FAIRLY SUBTLY I
WOULD SAY THAT WITHIN THAT-
PART OF THE FLEXIBILITY- IS
THAT THERE WERE ABLE TO PAVE IT
AS NEEDED. WHEN NEW
OPPORTUNITIES PRESENT
THEMSELVES OR NEW CHALLENGES
THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED. ONE
OF THE BIG CHANGES THAT
HAPPENED. BOB AFTER THE LAUNCH
OF. THE HOUSING FOR HEALTH
DIVISION WITHIN THE HEALTH
AGENCYAND THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SUBSIDY POLL WAS THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE OF DIVERSION AND
RE ENTRY. AND THE OFFICE OF
DIVERSION RE ENTRY HAS BEEN A
MAJOR SOURCE OF REFERRALS- INTO
THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POOL SENT TO CREATION A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO AND THAT'S FOLKS
THAT ARE. THAT HAVE JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT- THAT ARE EITHER
HOME. MINUTE RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESSNESS SO WITHIN THE
GROWTH WE'VE SEEN PARTICULAR.
GROW FASTER THAN OTHERS OR
SUBSIDE. WE HAD A RAPID RE
HOUSING MODEL THAT NO LONGER
EXISTS- CALLED HOUSING AND JOBS
COLLABORATIVE WITHIN THE
FLEXIBLE WE HAVE AN ON GOING.
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
PROBATION THAT STILL GROWING
CALL BREAKING BARRIERS. THAT
THOUGH HAS REUNITED
PROBATIONERS WITH THEIR FAMILY
AND PROVIDED THEM WITH THE SAME
PACKAGE OF SERVICES. GROWTH HAS
BEEN PRETTY. AND STEADY AND-
WORK BEING TOP HOUSING SHORTAGE.
NOT BAD THERE'S NO ROOM. WHERE
YOU FOR THE INVENTORY
EVERYWHERE WE- IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH ISN'T EVEN TIGHTER-
HOUSING MARKET OBVIOUSLY IT BUT
THAT PENINSULA THERE- SUGGEST
SOME. OF THE ENVELOPE ANALYSIS
BELIEVE THEY'RE OVER FIVE UNITS
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON IS
CURRENTLY HOMELESS. THAT POINT
COUNT SAN SAYS. ARE JUST A
MATTER OF THE- STAFF WE HAD A-
T. OF. ENGAGEMENT BUT SO TO US
I SAY BRING. PROFESSION SERVE.
MATT AND MY. THE MY- OF OUR UP.
NEW UNIT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
FIRE OR REPEAT BUSINESS FOR. WE
HAVE LAND THAT WE'VE WORKING
AND SIMON FOR OVER A DAY. AND
THESE ARE A HIKE APART SETTING.
SO THEN DO YOU HAVE A TUBE.
DOCU OR SOMETHING THAT YOUR
SLEEP WE HAVE WE DO HAVE.
ACTUALLY TIPPING POINT
COMMUNITY- A FOUNDATION AND
SERVICES GO THAT'S ONE OF OUR
PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS- IT'S
NOT BRANDED AS BRITAIN CORNERS
VIDEO BUT- AS PART OF THE
LAUNCH OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SO THE PEOPLE
THIS YEAR. THEY DID A CUTE
LITTLE ANIMATED VIDEO THAT I
COULD GET TO A LINK- AND WE
HAVE SOME OTHER MATERIALS AS
WELL I THINK IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
STORY SORRY DAD LEFT TO LEARN
MORE- IS THERE AN APP BERNIE.
THING THAT YOU USE OR DO WE GO
WE DON'T USE WE DON'T USE AN
APP BUT I CAN I CAN REACH BACK
OUT TO GET IN TOUCH WITH THEIR
STAFF AND MINISTRY GREAT AND
THEN. LAST QUESTION I HAVE- THE
GOVERNOR I WAS ABLE IN HIS
STATE DATE. AND MENTIONED. LAW
MENTION. LETTERMAN SHORT ACT.
AND MENTIONED THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING MORE THAN JUST A FIFTY
ONE FIFTY OLD BY.
INTERPRETATION SO I THOUGHT
THAT WAS. BRAVE AND COURAGEOUS
WHAT WAS HE SAYING BETWEEN THE
LINES WHAT DOES IT MEAN. ALL
ALL OF THE GLADLY DEFER TO
OTHERS ON THAT ONE BUT BUT BUT
I WILL TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
JUST TO SAY THAT THERE'S SOME
EMERGING CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THE NEED FOR SOME HIGH ACUITY
PROBABLY SMALL SITE MODELS- AND
BRING CORNERS IS EAGER TO BE
PART OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE
CREATING TOM HIGHLY- SERVICE
AND RATES SPECIALIZED-
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
PEOPLE MOVING OUT DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS. AND I'LL JUST SPEAKER
TO THE GOVERNOR'S COMMENTS-
NOTHING BETWEEN THE LINES- THE
SMOKE OUTLINED IN TERMS OF THE
GENERAL TYPES OF CHANGES. THAT
YOU WANT TO SEE BUT YOU ARE
CORRECT THAT- ON LIKE THIS
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO HOUSING
FUND WHERE WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
AND NOW SEE THERE'S A LOT OF
FEEDBACK IN THE CONVERSATION
WE'VE BEEN HAVING. ON THESE
CHANGES HE SET UP THE BROAD
OUTLINES OF WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
BUT WE HAVE NOT- DEMONSTRATIONS
NOT PUT OUT A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
YET. I'M I AM ONE WHO BELIEVES
THAT LPS IS REALLY FAILED OR
MAYBE THE STATE HAS FAILED AND
NOT PROVIDING SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY SERVICES WHEN THEY
CLOSE THE INSTITUTIONS IN THIS
BEEN GOING ON FOR FIFTY YEARS.
AND SO I WAS. REALLY ENCOURAGED
BY THE STATE OF THE STATE AND
THAT. WE'RE LOOKING FIND ME AT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED THE
TRANSITION FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS TO THE STREETS TO
THE JAILS AND SAW THE LARGEST
MENTAL INSTITUTION AN ORANGE
COUNTY IS THIS THE CENTRAL JAIL
IN DOWNTOWN SANTANA SO I'M I'M
GLAD THAT WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
BUT I'VE GONE DOWN THIS ROAD
NOW BEEN BEAT UP IN COMMITTEE.
SO I'M JUST KERN THIS. WHAT
WILL HE BE DOING THAT THAT WILL
HELP THIS LEGISLATURE CHANGE
ITS PERSPECTIVE ON LPS SO SICK
TO THINGS AND SO MY COLLEAGUES
MAY WANT TO ELABORATE THE FIRST
THING IS I THINK MY ONE THING
I'D SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR WAS
NOT SAYING IS YOU KNOW WE
SHOULDN'T ROLL THE CLOCK BACK
TO EXACTLY WHERE I WAS BEFORE
YOU KNOW HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE DID IS WE EMPTIED THOSE
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE PROMISE
THAT THERE WOULD BE COMMUNITY
SERVICES ON THE OTHER AND THEN
FOR A NUMBER OF COMPLICATED.
REASONS DOES EVER REALLY
PROVIDED AT A LEVEL THAT WAS
NEAT- BUT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THE STATUS QUO ANTE IS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OR ANYBODY ELSE
WANTS TO USE IN A DIAGNOSING
THE PROBLEM THERE AND THEN I
THINK AT THE SAME THING AND
COLLEAGUES CAN ELABORATE ON
THIS IS A WE TALKED ABOUT
POPULATION THAT'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE AT RISK OF
THAT THAT ALL HAS THESE COUPLE
CORING DISORDER. EIGHT PEOPLE
IN A MIX OF SETTINGS SOME HAVE
FAMILY WANT TO COMPEL SOME
DON'T HAVE ANY FAMILY AT ALL-
SOME EXPERT IT'S BOUNCE. SEVERE
MENTAL. NUMBER THAT FOR OKAY.
HEY THAT WAS THAT HE AND
MINISTRY ARE NOT SATISFY WITH
WHERE WE ARE NOW BOTH IN TERMS
OF THE THAT CAN SERVICE WAS
WERE NEVER PROVIDED THAT LEVEL
AND THE FACT THAT SOME THESE
LAWS WHILE MAYBE WELL
INTENTIONED I PERHAPS BECOME
TOO RESTRICTIVE IN TERMS OF THE
TYPE OF FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
NEED TO ATTACK THIS ISSUE. YOU
BECAUSE WE WOULD NEVER LET
SOMEONE WITH ALZHEIMER'S JUST
ROAM THE STREETS RIGHT AND- AND
SO WE'RE DEALING WAS SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE THAT JUST.
NEED THE RIGHT MEDICATION WHAT
THE RIGHT DOSAGE TO. START
MAYBE MAINSTREAMING AND DEALING
WITH THEIR SCHIZOPHRENIA AND
THE REST. AND JUST TO KIND OF
JUST LET HIM STAY OUT THERE DAY
AFTER DAY AFTER DAY- SO THAT'S
WHY I WAS ENCOURAGED BY THE
STATE OF THE STATE AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE APPROACH. AT IN
ANYTHING I CAN DO TO HELP LET
ME KNOW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK. ALL THE WORKERS ZERO.
WELL IF I MAY IN MY BRIEF THE
DEPARTURE FROM THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION AND BRING IT
BACK TO MORE COMPLICATION FOR
YOU. BUT I WAS ASKED WHY DON'T
WE FOCUS ON. TREATMENT FOR
BATTERERS AS A PART OF THIS. IT
THE INDIVIDUALS TO BECOME
ABUSIVE DOMESTIC PARTNER WELL
ANYWAY BUT I THINK YOU SEE IT
THE MARK REMARKS I MADE BEFORE
I LEAVE- THAT I THINK ON THE
COMMITTEE THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN ABOUT. THERE'S
ENTHUSIASM ABOUT ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT THERE'S
REALLY SOME CONCERNS ABOUT IT.
THAT IT MAY NOT BE QUITE COOKED
YET ONE ELEMENT OF THIS IS THE
VERSION AND I HAVE TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF- THAT ACTIONS THAT
HAVE. RUINED ALL APART. OF THE
SUCCESS OF DIVERSION AND THAT
IS THE DRUG COURT GO BACK TO
THE EIGHTIES AND I WORKED WITH
THESE DRUG COURTS IN THE
COUNTIES ARE REPRESENTED
THEY'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE THEY WERE BUILT ON A
MODEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
TREATMENT A BABY AND THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES IF YOU DON'T. WELL
PROP FORTY SEVEN WIPE THAT OUT.
AND NOW THE OF THOSE WHO ARE OF
NEED OF TREATMENT. THEY OPT FOR
THE EASY FLASH INCARCERATION
WHICH FRANKLY FOLKS IS A JOKE.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T HELP
ANYBODY WITH THEIR ADDICTION SO
THEY JUST SIT IN THE IN THE
JAIL FOR FIVE DAYS AND THEY'RE
RIGHT BACK ON THE STREETS AND
RIHT INTO THEIR HAPPEN AGAIN
SO THAT TOTALLY UNDERMINED THE
MERIT OF SOMETHING THAT WOULD
WORK FOR DECADES. THAT'S WHY
IT'S A PREMIUM FOR US TO REALLY
CAREFULLY EXAMINE. HOW THIS ALL
FITS TOGETHER. AND THE REGIONAL
STRUCTURE MAKES LOGICAL SENSE
BUT THE IMPLEMENTATION IS
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLICATED I
THINK THE POINT THAT I MAKE AND
WOOD WELL ON HERE. IT'S GOING
TO NEED A LOT OF WORK THIS
COMPLICATED IDEA. IT AND THEN
SOME OF THE APPLICATION I THINK
OF OBVIOUSLY WE'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND GET A LOT OF THE GOVERNOR
FOR TAKEN A LOOK AT THAT NEED.
IT JUST JUST PROVIDING HOUSING.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THAT OTHER ASPECT
THAT I DID THROW IN A HOMELESS
ADVOCATE WHO SAID JIM WE CAN.
BUILD SHELTERS FOR PEOPLE BUT-
THE COST SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
MORE BECAUSE OUR STATE
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSITIONS AND
REGULATIONS. THAT REALLY
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR ANYBODY.
PROVIDING HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
OR THE AVERAGE CITIZEN BEING
ABLE A YOUNG COUPLE TO BUY A
HOME. SO THOSE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT IN THE MACRO WE NEED TO
EXAMINE THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
MORE WORK THAT'S ALL. THANK YOU
CENTER CABALLERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR-
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION WE'VE
HAD HERE TODAY I THINK IT'S-
BEEN VERY VERY HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING I'M- ALL
OVER THE STATE- A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS AND THEN A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- ONE IS- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REGIONAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE A DISCUSSION-
ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL AND I
HEARD PEOPLE SAY THAT- WE HAVE
SOME AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
WORK REALLY WELL TOGETHER AND
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE. THAT
DON'T FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
REASONS AND I REPRESENT A RURAL
MORE RURAL DISTRICT- THAT HAS
PARTS OF OR ALL OF IN INTER IN
TOTAL SIX COUNTY SO I'VE KIND
OF LOOKED AT- WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH HE BEEN HAPPY ON IN IN
THOSE COUNTIES AND SOME ARE.
DOING A REAL GOOD JOB IN
OTHERS- ARE REALLY STRUGGLING
AND SO I GUESS THE FOR THE
FIRST QUESTION IS- HAVE WE
LOOKED AT WHERE THE SUCCESSES
ARE AND WHAT'S COST THEM OR
WHAT TO MAKE SUCCESS AND WERE
WE'VE- WHERE IT'S THAT THE-
RESTRICTIONS OF. STRUGGLED I'M
I'M A SUPPORTER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO QUITE FRANKLY MY
DRUTHERS STARTED DOING THIS
WORK. THIS BUDGET WORK WOULD
HAVE BEEN TO MAKE GRANTS TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND THEN
REQUIRED THEM TO WORK WORK
TOGETHER- BUT- SO THAT'S THE
FIRST QUESTION IS HAVE WE
LOOKED AT THAT AND IT DO WE
HAVE ANY ANALYSIS OF WHERE
THAT'S- THAT'S WORKED IN WHERE
IT'S NOT. AND THEN ON. THE
OTHER QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH-
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS TODAY. AND WE
DON'T HAVE ARE THE STATE'S
MAJOR HOUSING ENTITY AT THE
TABLE SO THE QUESTION. IS
RAISED WHERE'S EACH SEAT IN
COLLEGE OF A WHICH DO THE
FINANCING AND- REALLY DOG
WHETHER COMMUNITIES ARE
BUILDING HOUSING OR NOT THEY'RE
NOT THEY'RE NOT AT THE TABLE I
WONDER IF THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT. I CENTER CARRIER ALL
SPEAK BRIEFLY TO BOTH OF THOSE
AND THEN COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE
COMMENTS AS WELL I THINK ON THE
FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT
ONE SIZE. DOESN'T FIT ALL AND
SO AND WE'VE BEEN THINKING A
LOT ABOUT NOT OF COURSE IT'S- A
BIG STATE FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
COUNTIES OVER FOUR HUNDRED
CITIES. AND SO I THINK- WE HAVE
DONE YET IN THE ANALYSIS
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE TO DO BUT-
IN TERMS OF SPEAKING WITH
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SOME OF
THEM REPRESENTED AT THIS TABLE.
TO INFORM HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THINKING
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL. AT ONE
POINT THAT I DEFINITELY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS- IT IS CERTAINLY
THE CASE AND IS GONE A LOT OF
ATTENTION THAT. NONPROFIT YOU
KNOW NON CITIES OR COUNTIES.
CAN APPLY TO BE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS. BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT EMPHASIZE THAT
COUNTIES AND CITIES CAN ALSO
APPLY TO BE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR SO THEY- ANY.
ENTITY THAT APPLIES IS SUBJECT
TO A 10% ADMINISTRATIVE CAP
BUT- CERTAINLY IF A CITY OR
COUNTY- IS DOING GREAT WORK
ALREADY. AND THEY'RE
COLLABORATING WITH THE OTHERS
LOCAL. STICKS THAT ARE THERE.
AND THEY APPLY. FOR THE FAA.
THE RISE. TOP OF THE NOW BASED
ON THE CALL. IN THEIR- I
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT THEY
WILL WIN THE REASON ON. WRITER
APPLICATION AND BE ABLE TO.
CONTINUE TO COURT WITH THE DAY.
FINE AND THEN ON THE- QUESTION.
ANOTHER TABLES ALREADY PRETTY
CROWDED WITH A LOT OF US
ALREADY. I WILL SAY TO JUST
SPEAKING. FOR FINANCE I THINK-
OFTEN WITH THESE HEARINGS YOU
KNOW THERE'S SO MUCH GROUND TO
COVER AND WE- TEND TO FOCUS A
LOT ON WHAT'S NEW IN THE
BUDGET. THIS YEAR. THERE WERE
TWENTY. TWO HOUSING PARTICULAR
THERE WAS ALMOST TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FUNDING. LAST
YEAR- IN IN THAT'S IN ADDITION
TO THE HOMELESSNESS. FUNDING
THAT WE DISCUSSED. SO I THINK.
THAT WAS A LOT OF THE HOUSING
DEPARTMENTS THEY'RE LOOKING OUT
IMPLEMENTED FUNDING. AND HERE
OF COURSE ONE OF THE BIG YOU
PROPOSALS IS THAT ACCESS TO
HOUSING BONDS. WITH HHS AND DSS
SPECIFICALLY BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THE.
BROAD ARRAY OF PROGRAMS. YEAH I
THAT THE CHALLENGE THAT FOR ME
JUST IN TERMS OF HOW WE'VE
ROLLED OUT MONEY IN THE PAST IS
ON THE CEO SEES IT PLAYED AT
THE CENTRAL ROLE- AND- IN SOME
COMMUNITIES A DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB BUT- THEY THE REALITY
OF THE SITUATION. IS THAT WE
HAVEN'T REQUIRED A PUBLIC
ACCOUNTING OF WHERE THE MONEY
GOES WE HAVEN'T- REQUIRED THEM
TO HAVE PUBLIC HEARINGS WITH.
INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC- I HAVE
NO IDEA WITH THEM THE MONEY IS
GOING TO THE CEO. THE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WHETHER IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING INTO VOUCHERS OR
ANYTHING ELSE- AND FRANKLY IN A
COUPLE OF THE OF A- OF THE
AREAS THAT I REPRESENT I BASS
FOR IT FOR. INFORMATION AND-
AND QUITE FRANKLY HAVE NOT BEEN.
WELL RECEIVED ASKING FOR THAT
INFORMATION AND TO ME IT'S KIND
OF WHAT I'VE SAID IS LOOK
YOU'RE ASKING ME TO VOTE. FOR
MORE MONEY- IT'S A CRISIS WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO TELL ME
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING AND SO
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED. ABOUT
THAT BUT BUT- BUT I APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THE
UNIQUE- IF A STRUCTURE THAT'S
BEING AT LEAST WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
SO FAR THIS CUP- CONTEMPLATED
HERE- IT JUST OCCURRED IT IT
AFTER HEARING ALL THE
TESTIMONY. I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN WHAT BRILLIANT
CORNERS IS DOING BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY INNOVATIVE IT'S A
DIFFERENT WAY OF LOOKING AT THE
ISSUE- AND THE IDEA THAT WE
HAVE MORE HOUSING THAN PEOPLE
THAT ARE HOMELESS. IS I HAVE
NOT HEARD ANYBODY SAY THAT SO
FAR. I'M I'M ON THE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA BOARD AND I'M
PROBABLY IN BIG TROUBLE FOR. WE
NEED TO BUILD A WHOLE LOT OF
UNITS IT THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT AND I I'VE BEEN A HAVE
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATE
FOR THAT I WON'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY YEARS BECAUSE I'LL TELL
YOU HOW OLD I AM BUT- BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT TO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE VACANCIES I'M-
WE HAD A PRESENTATION. THAT LED
ME TO BELIEVE IN LA THAT. THAT
WHEN PEOPLE LOSE THEIR HOUSING
BECAUSE OF THE RENT GETS
INCREASED OR THEY LOSE THEIR
JOB OR THEY GOT A MEDICAL BILL
AND NOW THEY CAN'T PAY FOR
THEIR HOUSING. THAT THOSE ARE
THE ADDRESS IT THOSE ARE THE
UNITS THAT PEOPLE ARE THAT ARE
HOT HOMELESS ARE BEING PLACED
IN SO THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
RECYCLING PEOPLE. IN A WAY THAT
WILL NEVER GET AS THE SITUATION
AND SO. SO I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
NEED TO BUILD AND WE NEED TO
COME UP WITH A DIFFERENT WAY OF
HOUSING PEOPLE AND I'M- I'M I'M
INTEREST. BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT. THE AND THERE'S A SENSE
OF HOPELESSNESS THAT WERE EVER
GOING TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS.
SO IT IT JUST OCCURS TO ME
THAT. THAT TAKING IT IN A MUCH
MORE DELIBERATIVE PROCESS WHERE
YOU HAVE YOUR MODEL. AND WE
LOOK AT IT AND TRY TO SEE IF WE
CAN TRAIN. PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
STATE TO DO A VERY SIMILAR
MODEL. IS GOING TO. BE MUCH
MORE DELIBERATE HAVE AND WE CAN
MAKE A LONGER TERM COMMITMENT
TO IT. THAT WILL ALL HAVE THIS
EELING LIKE WE'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING JUST FOR ONE YEAR AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO WALK AWAY
FROM THE PROBLEM BECAUSE WE
SPENT. TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS AND WE
DIDN'T GET ANYTHING FOR IT AND
SO ANY ANYWAY I THAT'S- I AM I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE- WHAT WE NEED IS THE HOPE
THAT THERE IS. A PROCESS THAT
WILL HELP US TO REDUCE THE
HOMELESS. POPULATION AND THAT
WE CAN THEN START DEALING WITH
ALL THESE OTHER- AT DANGERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE PEOPLE THAT
ARE AT RISK OF BEING HOMELESS
FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
REASONS I THINK YOU'VE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
MANAGER. I SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
CLASSY BIASES REYES AND
SOMEBODY PUBLIC MEMBERS INTEND
TO COMMENT OKAY IF YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP. OUR WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE EVERYONE. ONE MINUTE I TO
SEE HOW MANY FOR Q. AND A WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU- THE
PALACE FOR PARTICIPATING
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
YOU MIGHT WANT TO JUST AT LEAST
TO GROW IN THE AUDIENCE IN
CASE. PUBLIC COMMENT RAISES
ISSUES YOU MIGHT WANT TO.
CLARIFY OUR ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ASK AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO RESTRICT YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THE SIGN AT THE- TEN. SECOND
MARK LET ME LET. FOLKS CLEAR
AWAY SO WE COULD BE SURE TO GET
YOUR ON CAMERA. AGAIN THANKS TO
THE PANELISTS FOR STAYING IN
ALL YOUR ANSWERS. IT WAS AN
ENGAGING HEARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE FIRST WITNESS ONE
MINUTE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M SO LONG TERM
ACTUALLY I'M HERE WITH US JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING. THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING OUT WHAT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AMONG ALL PEOPLE
I'M HERE TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOLKS SEEN OUR
THINKING RESOURCES AND FUNDING
ON ADDRESSING HOMES IS AMONGST
YOUTH- HISTORICALLY THIS HAS
NOT BEEN SOMETHING AT THE STATE
OR THE FEDERAL LEVEL. THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT ON THE
FEET BUDGET CYCLES THE STATE
HAS TURNED A CORNER AND WE'RE
VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT IN BOTH
KEEP AND HAPPY- REITERATE OR
BUILD UPON RATHER MISS SUDDEN
ALMONDS AND THEN THE VIEW MAP
CHAIR WE- ARE YOU. SIDE IN ANY
ONE TIME IN ON FUND TO ADDRESS
YOU HOME S. I'M AND THIS IS A-
IS WORKING KEEP WITH THE ISSUE
TO WORK TALK THIS HER WE'VE-
DODDSURVEYED AND INTERVIEWED
CONTINUE CARE AND LARGE CITY IN
THE BACK BILLION SAID TWICE THE
AMOUNT MORE THAN TWICE THE
AMOUNT ELEVEN PERCENT. VERSUS
5% STATE WIDE. IN HOMELESSNESS
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AS YOU
SAID AT OUR EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM. AND TO CONSIDER
ENHANCING THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLACEMENT FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE BUT HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT SO THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS NOT ERODING THE
SUPPORTIVE. BECAUSE IT'S
PUSHING OUT THE FUNDING THAT
CAN GO TO SUPPORT OF SERVICES
AND EATING IT UP WITH HOUSING
COSTS. AND YOUR PREVIOUS BILLS
EIGHT SB SIX TWELVE ACTUALLY
CALLED FOR WORK GROUP TO LOOK
AT THE T. H. P. AND EMPTY RATE
THAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND
UNANIMOUSLY IN APPROACH WAS
SELECTED ANALYSIS HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT APPROACH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING IS OFFERING A BILL
IN THIS APPROACH AB EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY AND ALSO
CHAMPION OF A BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO DO THIS. THANK GOODNESS
MINUTES AB SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
THAT CHAU CALIFORNIA WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THIS HEARING
AND THE FOCUS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PLACING ON
THIS ISSUE THE MISSING THAT
WOULD KEEP IGNORING IS A LACK
OF SUBSTANTIVE ON LONG TERM
ONGOING INVESTMENT INTO COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICES SAFETY NET WE
CAN PLACE PEOPLE IN HOUSING BUT
IF WE DON'T MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
BENEFITS THAT WILL KEEP THEM IN
THEIR HOUSING AND THEM ON A
PATHWAY TO SELF SUFFICIENCY AND
THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS BY
IN. THE NEED FOR OF ELLEN
WORKERS SOCIAL WORKERS LIKE
HEALTH NURSES ETCETERA
EMPLOYMENT THIS IS
PROFESSIONALS REALLY HAVING
THEM OUT IN THE STREETS HAVING
THEM OUT AT SCHOOLS HAVING OUT
AT LIVE HOW NUMBER OR IS
HAPPENING THAT SURE THE 75% OF
THE POP. OF HOMELESS THAT IS
NOT PROMPTLY HOMELESS THIS NEW
UNLESS BECAUSE OUR POOL. ARE
OVER THE AGE FIFTY. BECAUSE
SOMETHING HAS HAPPENED IN
BECAUSE THE STOP AND WE NEED TO
CAN THEM TO WITH THE SUPPORTS
AND SERVE. RATHER THAN CREATING
A NEW. WE ARE LATER WHICH IS
GOING TO KEEP THEM AWAY FROM
THAT DIRECT TO LIVE FREE OF
SERVICES THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S STATEMENT IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE THAT WE NEED
AN ONGOING SOURCE OF REVENUE.
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND WE
DO WE ARE FLOATING THE IDEA AND
DONE SOME RESEARCH AROUND OF
MILLIONAIRES TAX- WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LA
PROPOSAL FOR TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING- FUNDING- AND
HAVING THAT FUNDING GOING TO
EXISTING SYSTEMS RATHER THAN
CREATING ANOTHER SILO- WE DO
THINK THOSE EXISTING SYSTEMS
OVER. THE LAST YEAR OF HOUSE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND SO WE BUILT ON
THAT APPROACH TO MAKE IT MORE
SUCCESSFUL. COACH ALSO. US SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
BENCHMARKS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD NEED TO MAKE
GIRLS THE FUNDING COULD GET OR
ARE RE DIRECTED AND WE THINK
THAT WOULD BE MORE FEASIBLE
WITH AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING- I JUST WANT TO TOUCH
QUICKLY ON CAL AIM I'M WHILE I.
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ATTEMPT TO HAVE SOME FUNDING
FOR HOUSING BASED SERVICES WE
REALLY THINK THAT THIS NEEDS TO
BE OFFERED THROUGH A BENEFIT.
THAT ALL HOMES PROGRAM IS A
BENEFITS THE- CAL LAME IS
PROPOSING ELIMINATING THAT
PROGRAM. PLACING IT WITH- IN
LIEU OF SERVICES WHICH IS NOT A
BENEFIT AND WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE VOLUNTARY
NATURE FOR. HEALTH PLANS TO OF
OFFER A- THROUGH IT INTO THAT
WILL GO AWAY SOON HERE- SO A
AGAIN STRONGLY RECOMMENDS
HAVING A BENEFIT THAT WOULD
FUND HOUSING BASED SERVICES
THROUGH MEDICARE. AND THAT
COULD ATTRACT FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND WE DO SUPPORT AT HOME A SET
ASIDE AND WHATEVER PASSES-
THROUGH OF YOU THROUGHOUT WEBER
PASSES THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WHAT. ONE MINUTE. CHRIS MY-
HEALTH YEAH ONE UP THE GUY AND
THE THIS. FOR THEIR TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS- A
CONSISTENTLY AND- THE PLOT THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE CREATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA EXCISING AND-
SERVICES FUND WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE- APPROACH.
PUT FORWARD IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- OF POTENTIALLY
CREATING A NEW SILENT APPROACH-
COMPANIES CITIES AND CONTINUE.
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE HAVE BEEN
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
COORDINATING THEIR RESOURCES
AND- CREATING A APPROACH THAT
IS REGIONALLY FOCUSED AS WAS
HIGHLIGHTED BY BOTH. LOSS IN BY
A SACK NO ANSWER WE SHOULD
BUILD UPON THAT APPROACH AND
NOT CREATE SOME NEW SILENT
APPROACH- THAT- IGNORES THE
PROCESS PROGRESS BEEN MADE
THERE. ARE STRONG SUPPORTIVE OF
THE- OF THE OUT OF PLAY FOR TWO
BILLION ON GOING. TO ADDRESS
THE SCALE OF THE NEED- AND
APPROACH THAT I'M GOING IN OF
COURSE. WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT
THE APPROACH GIVEN FOR A- MAN
ONGOING REVENUE SOURCE TO FIND
THAT ON GOING SOME THANK YOU.
TO NEXT THAT'S ONE. I'M SURE.
SYLVIA'S BOBBY OF CITY LOS
MAYOR GARCETTI A HEARING
SUPPORT AS FOR THE TWO BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL AS DESCRIBED BY
MISS MARTIAN FROM LHASA. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT. TOPIC WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M TIRE IN THE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I'M A
COUPLE POINTS AROUND CAO AIM A
AND B. BOARDING CARE- SO WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS SOME
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
VISIONARY SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION
THEY'RE CALLING. IN TERMS OF
OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE DO HAVE HOWEVER HAD
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL SHORTCOMINGS WITH-
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT IN LIEU
OF SERVICES WE DO BELIEVE THAT.
ARM IN ARM. AND CARE MANAGEMENT
REQUIRED HEALTH PLANS TO DEAL
WITH GLOBAL OF CASE MANAGEMENT
WITH POPULATION THAT THEY'RE
AND FAMILIAR WITH- PARTICULARLY
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. AND THOSE WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS- BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH COUNTY
SADDAM. TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
AMPLE COORDINATION AND THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING CASE
MANAGEMENT OUT. FOR OUR FOR OUR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE AND
ALSO IS A LARGER QUESTION ABOUT
THE BOND IN NATURE I. LUIS
SERVICES. THE INSTEAD SINCE
THIS IS. THROUGH AND WILL SERVE
ARE WANT IT THEY ARE FOR NAPA.
RATHER THE ACTUAL I'M
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULDN'T. RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT ONE MINUTE NEXT
WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY
RIBEIRO COUNTY REPS AS OF
CALIFORNIA A REPRESENTED THIRTY
SEVERAL COUNTIES I WOULD I WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION- WE WOULD JUST
LIKE TO- POINT OUT THAT. THE
WORLD COUNTIES WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE A HOMELESSNESS ISSUE- IN
FACT SOME OF THE SMALLER
COUNTIES HAVE A PER CAPITA
HOMELESSNESS- RATE THAT IS
HIGHER THAN SOME OF THE LARGER
JURISDICTIONS AND THE RURAL
COUNTIES HAVE MORE OTHER UNIQUE
ISSUE WITH GEOGRAPHIC STANCES
AND ALSO NOT HAVING. THE
STRUCTURAL FOUNDATION HAVING
NON PROFITS OR PROVIDERS- TO
HELP WITH THE HOMELESSNESS
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE WE
ARE JUST ASKING THAT AS THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUES THAT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS. OF DIFFERENT
REGIONS ARE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION I THINK WE HEARD
THAT HERE TODAY THE- NO NO ONE
SIZE FITS ALL- WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A MINIMUM OR FOR
AMOUNTS- GIVEN TO SOME OF THE
SMALLER JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE
SURE ITS MEANING THERE'S A MEAN
FULL AMOUNT OF. BEING YOU ARE.
THE THANK YOU ONE MINUTE THAT
FOR TURN MEMBERS STICKER
REPRESENTING ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M GONNA
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH HEIDI
MARCIN FROM LAWSON WHO MAKE
COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT I'M SURE
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ON BOARDING CARE- THE
BOARDING CHARACTERS AND NOT IN
OUR COUNTY ARE ACROSS LEVEL BE
CONTINUE TO LOSE PADS WERE
ABOUT OVER TWELVE HUNDRED BACK
TO THE LAST FEW YEARS I THINK
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AS
LATE AS LASER FOCUSED ON THAT
WE WERE AT THIS TIME. WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ME TO PULL
THE BOARDING CARE ISSUE INTO
ONE THE BUDGET YOU YOU THIS.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAR WITH WHAT'S
CENTER LAW PA WERE VERY HAPPY
AN APPRECIATIVE THE GOVERNOR
BRING FORTH SUCH A ROBUST
PROPOSAL AM IN PARTICULAR WE
SUPPORT THE CALL FOR A STATE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THIS
IS THE SINGLE BEST THING THAT
WE CAN DO THIS YEAR BECAUSE
HOMELESSNESS IS AT THE CORE OF
POVERTY ISSUE. URGING APOCRINE
BUT HOUSING COSTS WHAT PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD TO PAY IS THE NUMBER
ONE THING THAT WE NEED TO DO WE
WILL ALSO THOUGH URGE A STRONG
PROPOSAL AROUND PREVENTION WE
MUST KEEP PEOPLE IN PLACE. AND
WHETHER THIS BECAUSE A SENATOR
SCANNERS COMMENTS EARLIER OR
GOES TO- AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE IDENTIFY WE KNOW WHO IS AT
RISK AND WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
OF TARGETING SHALL RESOURCES TO
THEM. AND THEN LASTLY WE ALSO
CALL WE DO SUPPORT THE TWO
BILLION DOLLAR ASK BY LA COUNTY
AND OUR PARTNERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU MADAM MEMBERS AIRING
BROTHERS WITH THE STATE QUE.
ELEMENTAL DESERVE. BENCHERS
FOCUS. POINTS EARLIER IN THE
HEARING THERE IS ONE THE KEY
OUR MEMBER UP IN THE IT'S
THERE'S A HIGH THOUSAND
REGIONAL CENTER ADULTS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
THERE HOUSING IS GOING TO BE AT
RISK INDEED THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT KEEPS FAMILY MEMBERS WITH
LOVED ONES WITH HERBAL PALSY
AUTISM DOWN SYNDROME AWAKE AT
NIGHT THINKING WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR COVER
GHETTOS OF LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA WITH HER OFFERING OF
SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTEEN AND
WE APPRECIATE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE YEAR
WITH THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE AS
WE LOOK AT WAYS TO SUPPORT
EXPAND THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
WERE TALKED ABOUT BY AND MISTER
PICKLE FROM BILLION QUARTERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEAR IF AND WHEN
I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS MATTER TODAY. AND ELEVATE
SOME OF THAT ADDITIONAL STATS
AROUND YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAT MOSTLY ABOUT
80% EVER YOU THREE THE COLOR.
AND ANYWHERE IN STATISTICS FROM
2240% ARE LGBT Q. YEAR. AND IN
PLACES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO IT'S
ALMOST 50% SO WE ARE SEEING
OVER REPRESENTATION EVER YOUTH
POPULATIONS AND ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES. AND
REALLY ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE ITS LEADERSHIP AROUND
A SET ASIDE ESPECIALLY FOR YOU.
I'M YOU'VE DONE THAT IN THE
LAST TWO ALLOCATIONS AND I
THINK IT IS MISSING. FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER AT 20% SO WE
CAN GET A HEAD. OF DON'T.
CHRONICALLY BELTS AND CAN. THEM
DOWN THE ROAD AND HAVING THESE
PROBLEMS- AND THINKING ABOUT.
ENCOURAGING WAYS TO ENSURE THAT
YOU CAN GET SERVE IN THE
SYSTEMS WHETHER THAT BE
THROUGH. HAVING A YOUTH COURT
IN ENTRY SYSTEM ORANGE NECK.
COMMUNITIES ARE HAVING
PRIORITIZATION POLICIES THAT
ACTUALLY WORK FOR YOU. AND SO
THAT THEY CAN BE SERVED IN THE
SYSTEMS AROUND THEM AND THE
ABOUT THE WHOLE SPECTRUM OF
BEING. ESPECIALLY AS A HOUSING
TIME LIMIT HOUSING BECAUSE
THOSE REALLY WORK FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU KNOW. AT EIGHT
TWENTY AM NINETY TO PLACE. IT.
THAT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON A JURY OF NON
THIS WITH THE LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER WE ARE THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF SERVICES TO LGBT
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WE SEE
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND CLIENT
VISITS A MONTH WHICH INCLUDES
OUR DROP IN CENTERS FOR BOTH
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SENIORS
EXPERIENCING. OVER THE LAST
YEAR WE HAVE SEEN A 70%
INCREASE IN SENIORS COMING IN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
WE SEE UP TO A HUNDRED YOUNG
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE DAY IN OUR
DROP IN CENTER THREE TO FOUR
NEW MEMBERS EVERY INGLE DAY
EXPERT LESS STRESS- SINCE THE
OPENING OF ONE OF OUR NEWEST
LOCATION CENTER SOUTH SEN LAMAR
PARK- WE CONTINUE TO HAVE YOUNG
BLACK COMPOUND- GAY AND BY WELL
AND BLACK TRANS WOMEN COME INTO
THE CENTER EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS- I'M LOOKING FOR A
WIDE SPECTRUM OF SERVICES
RANGING FROM EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. I'M THE
NOW THAT THERE IS A MERE YADDA
OF LOCAL FUNDING STREAMS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ON THEIR
UNSUCCESSFUL IN BEING ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THESE BECAUSE OF THE
VARIETY OF EXPERIENCES THAT
THEY HAVE BUT ALSO MANY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
IN LOS ANGELES ARE NOT. WITH
THE IN TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO YOUNG ENDING
HOMELESSNESS AND SO TO BE TO
BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN HOMELESS
WRITERS AND ALL WORK FOR I'M SO
WE SUPPORT A 20% ASIDE FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU. PUT
MINUTE. AFTER DOESN'T MATTER
NOT HERE TODAY I'M A OF HAVE
FOR YOU CAL I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR THEIR REVISED. IS VERY
IN FOR WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION HERE AS WE
DISCUSS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK CENTERS SKINNER FOR
BRINGING UP PURCHASE ASSISTANCE
AND CENTER CARILLO FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON HOMEOWNERSHIP
ASSISTANCE GENERALLY- HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY BUILDS DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOMES
SERVING THAT SENIORS AND
WORKING FAMILIES SOME OF WHOM
ARE ECONOMICALLY HOMELESS- AND
SO THAT IS A BIG PORTION OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE. WE
UNDERSTAND HOMEOWNERSHIP ISN'T
FOR EVERYONE BUT IT CAN BE A
HAND UP OUT OF POVERTY LEADING
TO EQUITY BUILDING- STABILITY
AND BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES. SO
SOME OF THE- SUMMER FORTY ONE
AFFILIATES ARE ENGAGING IN
INNOVATIVE AND UNIQUE MODELS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES- MANY ARE BUILDING
MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS OUTSIDE
OF THE SINGLE FAMILY HOME MODEL
THAT FOLKS GENERALLY BELIEVE
HABITAT BUILDS- AND ALSO
BUILDING EMERGENCY HOUSING WAS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES INCLUDING.
THE ANY HOME THAT OWNER IS TO
IT SO WE JUST THAT HOMEOWNERS
INCLUDE IN THE FIRST ASIAN
THANK YOU FOR YOU WITH THAT. I
HOW FOR MANY HAS A FIVE. THE
FIRST OFF CALIFORNIA BE SIDE.
THE INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA MAKE.
I AND HOPEFULLY ONLY FILLING
THE GAP FAIR MARKET CLOSED THE
GAP BETWEEN FOR RK AND- HOUSE.
WITHOUT DISHING OF THE REFORM
ROBERT SUBS IF THE COP THE
FUNDS. TO MAKE THE ONES GETTING
BANG I CAN AS MANY IN AS WE CAN
SUCH. THANK GOODNESS ONE MINUTE.
JOSH DUGGAR WITH THE FORTY
STATE ASSOCIATE OF COUNTIES
FIRST JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
WERE. AT APPRECIATE OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT THINK
INVEST ON TOP HE UPPER CRITICAL
TO ME INSTEAD. PRESS. MISSION
ALWAYS OUR REGION. I'M LOW THE
BILL WHEN IT COMES IT'S TIME.
S. MAY. THAT BEING SAID DO WE
THINK THAT GUY PER. IN THE DOES.
ON KEY. THAT WILL HELP MAKE.
PARTICULAR RENT. ASSISTANCE
AND- INVESTMENTS IN NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS WE'D
WILL NOTE THOUGH HOWEVER THAT
HALF APPLICATIONS WERE JUST DO
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
SOLVE AND MAKE SURE WE PARTNER
IN THAT SOLUTION- WE ARE
SLIGHTLY CONCERNED ON HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WILL BUILD OFF OF THE-
APPLICATIONS THAT COUNTY
SUBMITTED IT. WANT TO SUSTAIN
THAT PROGRESS AND WE DO THINK
THAT THOSE APPLICATIONS WILL
SHOW CONSIDERABLE-
COLLABORATION THANKS THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE. THAT
MADAM CHAIR JEAN HEARST HEARD
HIM AFTER THE URBAN COUNTIES TO
CALIFORNIA THE STATE'S LARGEST
FOURTEEN COUNTIES WHICH FRANKLY
ARE EXPERIENCING THE LARGEST-
HOMELESS CRISIS IN IN- IN THE
STATE. I'M WHEN A EXPRESSED PRE
FOR AND. FOR I'M HEARING TODAY
WE THOUGHT LOOK. I WAS
PARTICULAR. NO EXACT WHAT WORKS
AND WHAT DOES LOCAL WE WERE TO
COME WITH CONVERSE ABOUT LOCAL
CLUB WE WE'VE HEARD ARE COUNTY
MEMBERS IS THAT COLLABORATION
IS IMPROVING THAT THE HEAT AND
HOT PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE PUT IN
PLACE ARE ENCOURAGING
COLLABORATION AND WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE-
CONTINUED RELATIONSHIPS ARE
INCENTIVIZE AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
I ALSO WANT TO JUST SAY THAT
INVESTMENTS IN PREVENTION ARE
CRITICAL- TO ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS AND WE ARE VERY. STRONG
SUPPORT OF INVESTMENTS IN
RENTAL SUPPORTS OUR ON GOING
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT
HELP ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND BOARDING
CARE SYSTEMS THAT IS CRITICAL
TO ADDRESSING SOME OF FOR SOME
OF THE NEEDS OF FOLKS IN
CRISIS- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU
AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON-
MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE- TO COME. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK PLEASE MINUTE.
NOW I'M SURE REMEMBER RANDY ARE
NOT HALF OF THE IT'S HEALTHCARE.
AND IT'S HEALTH HOUSING FOUND A-
I'M I WANT JUST POINT OUT TO A
TO PAULA AREA A- NEED
CONSIDERABLE. AND BUILDING ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT CENTER
CABALLERO TO START JUST RAISED
IN HER COMMENTS. FIRST IS THAT
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO KEEP
FROM RECYCLING. I'M PEOPLE THE
HOME THIS AND TELL A COUNTIES-
DATA ABOUT HAVING MORE PEOPLE
OUT INTO HOMELESSNESS THAN
THEIR RATE ACTUALLY PUTTING
INTO PERMANENT HOUSING IS
TROUBLING- SO THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO.
NUMBER ONE WE NEED TO FIND WAYS
TO GET PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING INFO AND MAKING SURE
THAT BERMAN HOUSING IS CREATED
WE CANNOT BUILD OURSELVES OUT
OF THIS. AT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT IN LOS
ON SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A UNIT. IN SANFORD. WE
NEED TO OTHER WAYS OF DOING IT
LIKE A DEATH RE. AFTER THE BEEN
ONE OF THE LEADERS ON THIS. I'M
A- THE LAST YEARS WE ARE NOW
IT'S HUNDRED NINETY ONE UNITS
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. ALL
ADAPTED FROM EXISTING BUILDINGS
TURNED INTO DECENT HOUSE
HOUSING AT SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT. THE
SECOND ISSUE WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH IMMEDIATELY IS RENT
CONTROL. THE JURASSIC ERA THAT
THAT RENT CONTROLS ADOPTED IN.
THIRTY THIRTY YEARS AGO WE HAVE
TO BRING IT UP TO DATE- SO THE
PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING SHOVED OUT
OF THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T. KEEP THE RENT UNDER
CONTROL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FINAL WITNESS ONE MINUTE. I
SENATORS ADJUSTING HIGHER WITH
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
OUR THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBER
COMPANIES- TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERN. IT'S OUR TOP PRIORITY
IS THE HOUSING CRISIS- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT. SB SEVEN NINETY
FIVE IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
OF THIS OVERALL CONVERSATION
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
DELEGATION OF THIS DIALOGUE BUT
SENATOR- WELLS AS EASY. S.
NINETY FIVE IT THING THAT WE
THINK CAN REALLY HOW BRIDGE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GAP BY
CREATING A PERMANENT- SOURCED
FUNDING FOR PERSON. AND
COUNTIES. THAT HAVE SUFFERED IN.
THE TO PROVIDE THAT. FORD WILL
HOUSE. SINCE THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT TWENTY TWELVE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING.
IN THIS PROCESS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. VERY MUCH. SHE HELLO
THANK YOU MISTER OFF AND
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO IN HAS OF
THE STATE THERE ARE LOCAL IN
SERVE PROVIDER SERVICE PROVIDER
PANELS VERY INFORMATIVE-
TODAY'S HEARING STANDS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.